Heat. Heat. N.
Hey,
down
down.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Huh?
Are you
you?
Hey [ __ ]
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
Are
you
knocking?
Heat.
Hey.
Hey. Hey. Yeah.
Don't do that.
No.
Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Peace.
I feel
alive.
Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Hey. Hey. Hey.
Oh,
heat, heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Welcome Riftbounders to the next
installment in the regional qualifier
series. This time we find ourselves in
one of the oldest cities in the United
States, Hartford, Connecticut. Now
although this place is known for its
rich history, new pages are about to be
written in these history books as the
next epic riftbound story is about to
unfold.
So far in the saga of the Unleash
season, Allen's EQ and Squirtle have
claimed their second RQ win. solidifying
their status as the best of the best in
the game. Will returning champions
continue to claim victories or will a
new competitor climb to the top and
rival these titans?
Speaking of rivals, Vendetta is on the
horizon, which makes Hartford the last
stop in the unleash season before
Riftbound moves on to its fourth set.
Legends will clash, champions will fall,
but only one player in these halls will
be crowned a new champ.
And here we are. Good morning,
Riftbounders. I'm Bear Bryant, joined by
the wonderful Gretton, one of our
casters for this weekend. And here we
are, Hartford, Connecticut. And I am so
excited for this weekend for one reason
and that reason of course is this is our
last unleashed regional qualifier and
people are still cooking on these decks.
>> Yeah, it's crazy. We haven't really seen
anything like this in the history of
Riftbound where we are at a point now
where this is our last qualifier for uh
for excuse me for Unleashed, but we've
seen so many different decks come and
go. And I'm just very excited to see
what our, you know, metare or top eight,
all that fun stuff is going to look like
this weekend because this is where the
set becomes the most competitive, right?
This is where people have had the
longest amount of time to play with this
pool of cards and they're going to be
able to kind of bring their agame today
and we'll be able to crown our final
unleash champion. And it's not even just
that. We just came off an incredible
weekend in Utre where we had eight
different legends in our top eight and
there were still even other legends in
contention to make that cut. Of course,
we'll talk about some of that in a
little bit, but first we want to even
pay homage to the man himself. We got to
talk about Squirtle and Azir, Emperor of
the Sands. And the reason why is because
he's had one of the most incredible runs
we've seen in Riftbound history so far.
Of course, to then be against Allan ZQ,
who was the other person in this
conversation, and now Squirtle is, of
course, our second twotime regional
qualifier champion playing the same
legend.
>> Yeah. What's obviously very impressive
is not just the fact that he has just,
you know, mastered and piloted Azir to
the level that he's able to perform at,
but also that in both of his wins, he
didn't drop a game.
>> Not a single one.
>> Which is in an exceptional feat for
those of you at home who have haven't
played one of these regional qualifiers,
they are long days, right? You're
playing, you know, eight rounds in day
one, five more rounds in day two, and
then you have to play a top eight where
you might get, you know, an hour, hour
and a half break between your Swiss and
top eight, but then it's back to back.
It's untimed rounds. It's grueling.
you're playing against exceptional
players. So, not only is Squirtle, in my
opinion, you know, the spokesperson for
Azir, so to speak, but he's also just
the mental fortitude he has is just
phenomenal.
>> And and we can even see how he's been
iterating on this deck because obviously
we saw him in Leo and then haven't seen
him against until last weekend. And in
his deck specifically, we talked about
unleash. So, we have to talk about some
of the new pieces that have gone to this
deck, but even some counts have changed
across the board. So, you know, we've
got things like, of course, these
unleash cards, Scuttle Crab and Vi being
added to the deck, although they're only
one-ups, but you could see so many
times, at least when you're playing card
like Scuttle Crab, where you go into
Battlefields, you just let it die just
to get hand information, which is so
vital in this game. Or at the end of the
day, wears equipment really well. Yeah,
exactly. I mean, it's a it's a two cost,
no power, you know, you just play him,
draw a card, it replaces himself, and
you get free information. Obviously, we
have the Vi as well, which with Unleash,
this has been making waves in all order
decks. I don't think I've seen an order
list that doesn't run Vi because she is
such a powerhouse, right? Just being
able to surprise stun in a combat and
just swing that might differential five
in your favor is exceptional. But I do
want to highlight this soul sword over
here, right? Azir's problem uh and I put
problem in air quotes back in Spirit
Forge was that there were only so many
one drop equipments which for Azir turns
it into a two drop right cuz you'll use
your legend ability to create that sand
soldier to pick up that equipment. So
this deck not only got more consistent,
it got more Trixie, too. Especially with
cards like back off as well, where
previously if you know Azir hit a card,
you're like, "Oh, that's a guards." You
know, it's kind of a no-brainer. But now
it's it could be a guards, it could be a
back off. You could play the back off
from hand to kind of draw cards as well,
which is very important. And this deck
just obviously it goes. It seems so
phenomenal. And it allows you to kind
of, you know, use cards like Scuttle
Crab to protect your Arise, which was
Azir's weak point in the past is when
your opponent was really prepared for
that Arise turn, they're like, "Oh,
you're on six next turn. Great. Let me
develop. Let me set up. I know what's
going to happen." But now, when you have
that scuttle crab where you can get that
info, you set up the Arise turn on your
turns. And I'm hoping that we see the
kind of ripple effect here of what
Squirtle has done because I think people
keep talking about his deer, but not
necessarily being like high in
representation in these tournaments. But
as I was kind of looking a little bit
ahead at some of the information that
we'll talk about later today, um
>> I think he might be persuading some of
the public to play a little bit more of
this legend. But of course, we want to
talk about someone who is going to be
here in this room this weekend. Now,
sadly, Squirtle won't be here, but on
the other side in our top cuts of that
bracket in Utre was Dewali. And we got
to talk about Diana because not just
Dwali piloting this deck, but playing
different versions and having an
incredible run in Utre as well, making
all the way to top four. and then
falling out of course to Red Axel with
that victor that we saw in the finals,
but only dropping one match across the
entire weekend. You know, having had a
draw that happened. I think again just
goes the time. Sometimes it happens in
the tournament and then you have to win
out. And of course, Dwali, no, you know,
no surprise to him. He can of course
pull it out, but still piloting that
incredible Diana list, right? And it's
different because we've been looking at
people like Allen ZQ, have already won
with Diana in this regional qualifier
season of Unleashed, but plays a
different version and there's like small
bits and pieces that constantly change
inside of this deck list. So, I'm really
excited to see as this last one here in
the Unleash season, what else is going
to be changed, not just here for Dewali
specifically, but Allen's EQ, who we
know is also in the room. Yeah, Diana
has always been a very fascinating deck
to me in set uh in unleashed because I
don't think we've seen a regional
qualifier where, you know, our best of
Diana was running the same list. It's
changed every single time. Uh we saw
back, I believe it was in uh in
Vancouver where Dewali was playing a
very strong Swiss version of Diana and
then Allen ZQ was playing a Diana with
it was really teched for top eight and
for you know those kind of rounds where
you're playing more of the quote unquote
meta decks. But now we're seeing a very
similar list from both players back in
Utk uh last week which we're bringing in
cards like Sprite Fountain, right? We're
bringing cards like Eclipse. The
acceptable losses is a very versatile
card uh in this in this matchup because
not only is it just, you know, it's one
cost. So you can use your Diana to, you
know, cast an acceptable losses, but
also it's just discard fodder for your
Hay if you need it to be right. So it's
good when it's good and when it's bad,
you just you use it for something else,
right? So this list has been very very
refined by these players. Obviously
Dewali, Allen's EQ, all these Diana
players are exceptional at their craft
and they really really understand the
game and they know what they want to do
with the deck. So I'm very interested to
see, you know, it's probably going to be
like one to three cards, but what's
changed in our final regional for
Unleashed? Well, you say that and my one
big thing I want to highlight is
actually that Kha'Zix mutating horror
because when I was talking to Alan ZQ
about this card specifically in Sydney
and he goes, "Yeah, like in the
beginning of the format, it was a
surprise factor. It was something that,
you know, you could keep up X amount of
energy. You know, because of Diana,
people aren't necessarily used to the
deck yet. You could keep three runes up
and then including Diana, you're like,
"Oh, actually, I can play this ambush
unit." And then Allan said he took it
out and he's like, "I don't think it's
really that good anymore." And then
boom, all of a sudden
>> it's back.
>> We're back. And so it, like you said,
it's just we're going back and forth.
you know, a big, you know, small shout
out to smokeokesc screen seeing some
more play again. Um, just an incredibly
powerful card that just allows you to
really take a full swing. I mean, it's
the same amount of mic swing that can
happen for things like Defiant Dance for
Ireelas. And so, this is something you
can't really forget about. But speaking
of forget about, let's talk about some
other players, people that we know are
going to be in the room this weekend,
and we want to call them our sort of
like top four heroes that we think can
come up and maybe take down a regional
qualifier win this weekend. And yes,
prismaticism is going to be on this list
with that Annie that we know is in the
room. And of course, he already has a
regional qualifier win from Atlanta, but
these other three players, Billionaire,
Colin Kaiser here representing, of
course, challenger TCG. And then Swag
Yellow 420. Yeah, who we know has
already gotten a top cut with Dazzling
Aurora. These players are still here to
play. And Villionaire got a huge shout
outs here. Ano winning in last weekend
gets paired down into probably his worst
matchup being the Rexai that we see take
it down and go into top eight. this
close being the first Avalar to make
into a top eight. Yeah, it was a bit of
a Cinderella story for Villionaire where
he was he had an exceptional run and
then all he needed to do was, you know,
he could uh he could ID into, you know,
top eight, but unfortunately he did get
down paired because of his tiebreakers.
Had to play it out. Probably the second
worst matchup, I would say. Victor kind
of being the first, right, for most
Aurora decks, but took a game off the
Rex eye had everyone on the edge of
their seats. I know Aurora is a very
contentious topic in the community. Some
people love it, some people hate it. I
absolutely love Aurora decks. feel like
it rewards player agency when you don't
find your Aurora. You have to get very
creative and craftsy with it. And both
these players here, Swag Yolo420 and
Villionaire are prime examples of that,
right? They don't see Aurora. It doesn't
really matter in the grand scheme of
things. They'll find a way to come back
into the game and potentially win. And
then obviously Colin, we should stop
calling him Colin. Just call him set at
this point. Uh kind of the the master of
uh the boss himself. So he's had
multiple top eight finishes, right? but
can never really push himself over the
finish line and he's feeling pretty
confident today.
>> I think you have to be right when you're
playing a legend like set that I think
is so well tailored has incredible
domains to be playing with. I don't
think anyone thinks that order I mean
order has such a high representation
just last weekend in our top eight
across so many different decks. But also
the body domain of course being probably
the second strongest or third strongest
in some people's opinions when you know
depending on where you put calm. But,
you know, it's just this idea of this is
a legend and you can become a specialist
in this game. And he's playing a kingpin
version that I think for so long so many
people were so sold on playing set
brawler. And every single time Colin
shows up and plays this version. And I
love irresistible faithfolk and that
card's really good in that deck. But of
course, you also pay pay attention how
like there's not a lot of main board
draw in that deck. And you just utilize
all of your battlefields to do so. And
again, I I tell him I tell this every
time when I talk to him. He's so good at
playing the game of Riftbound on a only
a few amount of runes to like actually
have access to because every recycle
cost you pay is so significant,
including with the set legend ability
himself. Want to talk about Prisbat just
a little bit.
>> Y
>> we've already seen him reiterate on this
Andy deck so much. I mean, he has five
best of that you can see him wearing
around his neck if you find him in the
hall. But uh not on top of that, but he
has made small changes. And one of the
biggest changes I really applauded last
weekend specifically was triple long
sword in the main board. And it means
that these units that you normally play
in this Annie deck that you're kind of
be more about like skittish in combat
and you're just here to really get
points and then play all these tricks.
Now your units are significantly
stronger than normal.
>> Yeah. And it also opens up a lot of
question marks for your opponent right
when you see it the first time. If
you're not really, you know, if you
don't know Prismat's list, which, you
know, not everyone in the room is going
to study everyone's list, right? So, if
you don't know Prisma Prismat's list and
you see that long sword the first time,
you're like, "Oh, okay." You usually
assume it's probably a one of or a two
of, right? So, when you start seeing
them multiple times and the fact that,
you know, Annie gets to ready two runes
at the end of their turn, it kind of
opens the range of possibilities that
your opponents have to kind of take into
account when they're entering combat,
it's no longer just, you know, some
flashes or a star crossed or something
like that. It's very important for them
to also take into account this long
sword, which is a pretty big thing to
kind of add into your math when you're
trying to take over that battlefield
away from an Annie player.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And of course, I mean,
we can even take a list or take a look
at like Colin's list, right? Because uh
he did top cut last weekend, so I'm
interested to see what he's necessarily
going to be doing that's different. Of
course, we already talked about the
kingpin being that chosen champion here
in your in the deck, but the
irresistible fateful folk and just like
making your opponent not want to be in
combat when you want to be. Of course,
we know challenged does a similar idea,
but the movement of this deck just
really, you know, shines. And we've
already talked about of course the VI uh
Peacemaker. As you said, if you're
playing an order deck and you're not
playing this card at least as a one of,
maybe reconsider that because these
tricks from hand that are key to the
similar conversation about the long
sword with prismaticism, if it's not a
spell, it can't get counter spell.
>> Correct. It just instantly resolves,
comes into the battlefield. And this is
uh what we're looking at here also is
the orange Rengar. This is kind of a new
addition to the deck. Obviously, one of
the strongest uh body units in the game
currently. uh ambush with extra steps,
right? Ambush with you don't really need
units. It can just come in as a
surprise. But what I really love about
this deck, like you mentioned with the
kingpin, is that it's kind of a reverse
protect the president where the kingpin
is your president, but you're not
necessarily protecting him. You're using
him to protect the cards like
irresistible faith folks. You can get
multiple applications. Really own one
battlefield and then using cards like
Fiora to get her mighty to gank over to
get you that extra point when you need
it. just really owning that one
battlefield, using your set legend
ability to save that kingpin, and just
continuing to outvalue your opponents.
This deck really rewards knowing what
your opponent wants to do and then
telling them no.
>> Yeah. And our small teaser, of course,
we don't want to forget about um Swag
Yellow 420. Yeah. Um I have heard
through the Grapevine that he is doing
something drastically different with
this Aurora list. Something that we did
not see in Vancouver when he got that
top cut. So, I'm hoping maybe we get to
keep get an eye on that deck or at least
something similar to it across the
weekend. But speaking of this weekend,
we got to talk about the format and what
these players in this hall right now are
going to be competing in. It's going to
be some long days here, Brentton. We've
got eight rounds of Swiss here on day
one happening right now at this very
moment as we are kicking things off. Of
course, 18 points gets you qualified for
day two where you will play five more
rounds of Swiss and then of course the
coveted top eight that we keep talking
about where single elimination comes
into play. Yeah, like you mentioned,
it's it's a long weekend for these
players. I'm usually wearing a different
shirt when I'm here. I'm wearing a judge
shirt when I'm here, and it's long for
the judge staff as well. So, I can only
imagine having to actually play, you
know, eight rounds and think of these
interactions, sideboarding, and all that
stuff. And day one, Swiss is the wild
west. It's a zoo. You know, you don't
know what you're going to run into. You
don't know what you're going to sit
across from. Day two, you'll have more
consistency. You'll kind of, you know,
understand that you're going to face
more of the meta share and grind your
way into top eight. But these players
not only have to come prepared with
their decks, but prepared with their
mental as well. And that's something
that I feel like a lot of players maybe
undervalue sometimes when they go to
these big events. And we kind of see it
where most of these players who have
attended multiple RQs are getting better
at these RQs cuz they're understanding
how rough these days can be sometimes.
>> And speaking of getting better, there's
a reason to be better because we have
some excellent prizes to be playing for.
Of course, that Vex playmat, which was
added to the prize pool, something we
didn't see earlier on this year for your
top 128. And of course, we have to talk
about it. We've already been saying the
last unleashed regional qualifier means
this is your last opportunity to go home
with this incredible Poppy defender of
the Meek alternate art playmat. Of
course, that champion one, this is it.
This is the last one that's going to
exist. And of course, we have the other
ones in the top eight. And of course, we
can't stop talking about the cash
prizing that does go all the way down to
top 32.
>> Yeah, this is a a fun area of Ripon that
I really enjoy is how diverse the
prizing is. You don't have to, you know,
think you're the best player in the room
to come play in RQ. If you really love
Jyn or you really love Lux, spoiler
alert, I love Lux. Uh you'll come to
this event, right? You'll try to get
that best of lux. Hey, maybe you sneak
into a top 64 and you get your regional
championship invite or, you know, maybe
you go home with a nice playmat, some
prize wall tickets. So, it's very, very
diverse. You don't have to kind of play
a deck you don't love just because you
want to put up good results. Well, you
said you like Lux, so um let's see what
our casters have predicted to take down
the entire event. And wow. Yeah,
Grenton. Um Lux Lady of Luminosity,
which is a hot topic right now. And we
even had a chance to showcase what this
deck is doing now and how people have
already reiterated on the sort of new
style. Um speak to that a little bit.
You really think it can take down the
entire regional qualifier? That is a
high skillbased deck.
>> Yeah, it's a deck that doesn't really uh
it punishes one mistake very very badly.
If you make a mistake, you've probably
just lost. Uh, however, if you're a
pilot who plays fast and you don't get
punished by the clock too much and a lot
of ends have to happen and you make, you
know, day two and top eight, I think
this is a deck that has a very real
chance of winning. That being said, I'd
be very surprised if we have, you know,
more than a couple of them who are in
day two or, you know, in top eight, but
it is a deck that's near and dear to my
heart. I played a lot of Lux Control in
set two, so for me, this is, you know, a
bit of a pet pet deck choice.
>> Yeah. And of course, you know, shout
outs to Charmer here. really thinking
Aurora might be here to play. I think I
think a lot of people players in North
America do really like that Aurora list
that's going around. Kangas, of course,
paying attention knows that Prismaticism
is in the room. And Josh picking the
Kha'Zix here, which I think is such an
interesting choice. And the best thing I
love about all of your predictions are
the fact that they're all unique
legends, which based off of last
weekend, that seems to be the name of
the game and what you should be deciding
on what you think is going to show up in
this top cut. And once you get to that
sort of high skill, untimed rounds, like
you said, decks like Lux can really
thrive. Any of these decks can thrive
because you have that time to figure out
how to solve each puzzle of each game.
So, with that being said, I think we've
got a round one that we really want to
jump into soon. And I would love to hear
from our casters for that first round as
well. So, we're going to go ahead and
send it away.
Riftbound has been unleashed in Hartford
and it all comes down to this one last
regional qualifier in the unleashed
season. I'm Josh Schneider. I'm joined
by Charmer and this weekend is going to
be a thrilling weekend of Riftbound.
>> Absolutely. This is, I think, going to
be one of the most exciting events in
the history of the game for many of the
reasons that Gretton and Barrett were
talking about. We are three sets in. We
have a wide card pool now. Players are
finding their footing. We have a number
of players that are kind of becoming the
favorites in the field. But obviously,
there are still new teams rising. There
are people trying to make their name for
themselves. But we are at the end of the
unleashed season, which means that this
is the most tuned that these decks with
this card pool should be. And yet, the
meta is far from solved. We have a lot
of representation still showing up in
our tournaments. That's such a great
point and they talked about it in the
pre-show last weekend. A huge diverse
top eight in Utrect. It was eight
different legends. The first time we've
ever seen that in Riftbound and that is
just crazy the odds of that happening.
You love to see it. I'd love to see some
more new legends get into the top cut
this weekend. Well, there's a pretty
strong chance that we will see uh some
new legends as well as some returning
legends because even with the unique
eight that we had in Utrect in
Vancouver, there were three other
legends that made that top eight that
were not in the top eight in Utrect. So
really, if you go back to the past two
events, uh the 16 available, we still
had 11 unique legends there. And that's
not counting your pick to win it,
Kha'Zix. That's not counting Gretton's
pick to win it, Lux. So again, a lot of
opportunities for other legends to maybe
crack the top eight for their first
time. Uh it is just a wide openen
format, which is so crazy when you
consider that this is the last big event
for the Unleash season.
>> Yeah. No, I'm super excited about it. I
think it's going to be a fun weekend.
And hey, maybe Kha'Zix and Lux can get
their first top eight appearance. That
would bode well for myself and for
Grinton. I think we've got some
community picks to take a look at though
to see what the community is thinking
we're going to be looking at this
weekend.
All right, so these are live choices for
our community to vote on which match
they want to see. You can see Dewali
taking on Alen ZQ or Sketchy Man taking
on Gonkra.
I I'm a little bit torn here, if only
because on the one side uh you have some
amazing players and on the other side we
have uh some diverse options. But I'm
now being told that that was just, you
know, a a a test run, a little
switcheroo on you. We're actually going
to be ambushing you with the correct
matchups here shortly. And uh don't
worry, there's still some good options.
But that was uh our our fun little prank
on you, the viewers.
>> There you go. We were talking about
>> we're not seeing Alen versus Dewali
round one. That is not
>> right. Fireworks already main event
round one. Absolutely. But no, you were
talking about the diversity and the
different unique legends that we've seen
over the last couple events and that's
so great and I think the diversity right
now in Riftbound is just unmatched. It's
so cool to see the diversity in the top
decks over the last couple regionals.
Master Yi has been the most represented,
but only around 10%. That is a really
good healthy number. You love to see it.
>> Yeah. And the thing that I like about
the diversity that's within Riftbound is
it's not just diversity for diversity
sake. All of these decks have the
ability to perform well. It is a format
that is rewarding specialists. If you
are somebody who loves a specific legend
or if you're trying to pick your
favorite champion from League of Legends
and then run with that in Riftbound, you
can do so and then still perform very
well at these tournaments. Obviously,
the best of prizing helps as far as
incentivizing and not every legend is
100% likely to make a top eight. I'm
sorry, Garen, but for the most part, out
of the wide range of options, there are
very few where if it made a top eight, I
would be surprised because at the end of
the day, it is a card game and sometimes
uh I like to say I'd rather be lucky
than good. You can go on a streak, you
can catch your right matchups, you can
draw the right stuff at the right time,
make those critical plays when it
matters. I like to say that luck is when
preparation meets opportunity. And if
you just do that across 13 rounds of
Swiss, you could find yourself in the
top eight on somebody like a Rumble
perhaps.
>> Yeah, absolutely. No, we would love to
see that. But you talked about the
specialists and it's so interesting
because we see players like Colin and
Prismaticism and Villionaire just
racking up the best ofves, right? I
think they have what, at least four for
each of them. There's five Annies for
Prismaticism. He was wearing them. I
tell you, it's just crazy. Squirtle now
with a couple Azir. I believe Rocklo has
four Azir. So, you just love to see
these specialists that it really is
tough coming into an event when you're
going for the best of. If you're on one
of those legends, you've got your work
cut out for you. Well, that path starts
in round one. So, we have our real
matchups for you to vote on live. Again,
these are live. This one is not the
joke. We are not ambushing you. This is
the correct uh listings here. So, if you
want to see Filth on Rengar take on Jun
on Kha'Zix, the the literal like foes
matchup, the storied league rivalry, uh
you can vote for them or we have uh
Tater Mau taking on Tron is Bad from
Merc. And so that would be Ari. I'm a
bit biased, I'll be honest. Uh and that
would be taking on Civer. So get those
votes in. Again, if you want to see
match A or match B, let your voice be
heard.
>> Well, hey, we've got Kha'Zix up there,
so I'm torn and I would be voting for
Kha'Zix. Let's see Kha'Zix right out of
the gate. So, our picks showing up here
early. Charmer should be exciting. I
think this Kha'Zix versus Rengar match,
that is going to be a very quick match.
There's going to be a lot of aggression.
Two decks that can play very quickly.
It'll be interesting. Then of course
Ahri, a deck that wants to hold versus
Civer. And if this is an Aurora deck, we
know that in the late game there is some
major inevitability for Aurora.
>> Well, it's looking like the people have
spoken and we are going to be going with
match A here. Though there is a bit of a
late push to see that Ari. The good news
is is depending on, you know, our
availability in terms of time on the
broadcast, we might still catch the end
of match B. But we're going to be going
with the rivalry itself. Kha'Zix versus
Rengar, jungler versus jungler. Uh, body
legend versus body legend. Uh, these are
are two just from unleashed, right? So,
they're new legends as well. Uh, one,
Rengar's made a top eight. There's been
a lot of discussion about Kha'Zix
potentially doing it and it's your pick.
So, I'm excited to see how this plays
out right away in round one.
>> Yeah, absolutely. This is the weekend of
void assault. I think this is one of the
best signature spells in the game. just
love what it does. And but like you
mentioned, Ringgar, that was a finalist
deck by Sam D. Sherman in Vancouver. So
that was a crazy run. I think still one
of the great feats that we've seen so
far because no one expected Rengar. So
being able to put it in the top eight
and then run it all the way to the
finals was really, really cool to see.
So we'll see uh how it looks here in
round one.
>> Well, I mean, you mentioned it. Let's
take a look at that Rengar deck list and
see if anything jumps out. if there's uh
differences from the Sam D. Sherman
version uh or other things that we want
to highlight. For me, of course, I want
to talk about irresistible faolk. That
is a card that I am absolutely in love
with. It is fantastic for forcing your
opponent's best units into combat. And
then you can follow it up with some of
these key ambush units or sometimes if
you've already played other units as
well, you can kind of pick things off,
win those combats. Uh, another card that
personally I want to highlight because
it continues to surprise me is that red
pike. The ability to hide it or to
potentially play it as a four accelerate
for just three energy and of course that
one fury power means that uh you can get
a lot of early pressure by playing it
over the top of somebody's uh two drop
right when you are on what a lot of
people say the draw I like to say on the
rune. So essentially when you're on
those three runes, what it allows you to
do is uh if they've played something,
you can easily go over the top of it or
if you're playing against sneaky deck
hands, then you can actually just
outright win that combat. Yeah, that's
absolutely right. This deck wants to go
fast. You can actually see that there
are a total of 12 different units that
can be played on turn one. So there's a
lot of options for this deck. And then
also we've got punch first. Of course,
one of the best pump spells in the game
to get over your opponent in combat. And
then that signature spell, Thrill of the
Hunt, can absolutely surprise your
opponent out of nowhere, putting your
unit on one of those battlefields and
potentially scoring when your opponent
did not expect it. Yeah, absolutely. And
because Thrill of the Hunt actually
allows you to play the unit again, you
can trigger any of those enter play
effects like that red pike that I was
just talking about. So, uh, there's a
lot of synergy in this list. Uh, I'm
glad you mentioned punch first. That's
also one of my favorite plays to make.
You do usually don't want to do it too
early because of the intense power cost,
but putting punch first on an is
irresistible faolk is so much fun uh
when you're the person doing it, not so
fun when you're the person receiving it.
And of course, we see the other staples
here, right? Sabotage. Uh this is a card
that is incredibly popular in the meta
for a number of reasons. being able to
uh take from your opponent a spell that
they might really want to use against
your units or in other matchups, an
important gear, whether you're against
Azir or Aurora, being able to pick those
out of the hand is incredible. Uh set
one staples like Kai'Sa and Darius
provide a lot of might. But it's not
just about the Rengar. Let's take a look
at the bug man himself, Kha'Zix.
>> Yeah, absolutely. This was the best of
last weekend in Utre. So very excited to
see this one from Jun. And we've got
that irresistible faith folk. These body
decks, they are really leaning on that
irresistible faith folk in the early
game. And this deck wants to generate XP
early, and it can do that with things
like Mr. Root. Mr. Root can actually go
into a battlefield early, get that 2XP,
and then with your legend ability, you
can use that 2XP to move it back out.
So, I love the ability with Kha'Zix to
go in, conquer a battlefield, and then
use that XP to back out. I really like
that adaptability.
>> All right. And as I'm looking at this
list, there's some other things that
jump out to me. I do see the one main
deck action. I think that that's a
fantastic play in the current meta. Of
course, Aurora is usually your uh
windmill slam. I want to take that from
you play. But again, if after Squirtle's
run back with Azir, we see more decks
with equipment, even just taking
something early to kind of slow them
down can be really beneficial. Uh,
another card that I kind of want to
highlight here is Gust. Yes, it's just a
one of, but because your chosen champion
Kha'Zix wants to get in on uh opposing
units that are alone, if they try to
buddy up, right, put something small
next to the unit they're trying to
protect, you can use Gus to kind of free
it up, make it alone, and then hit it
with the Kha'Zix. Or uh another really
key strategy that I like is the
inclusion in the battlefield section of
forbidding waste. This is something that
pairs incredibly well with the purple
Kha'Zix, but also with irresistible
faolk. If you are on the play and you
play that turn one, your opponent almost
can't develop because you can drag
whatever they play into the waste and
you will likely just win that combat
without any tricks at all.
>> Yeah, it is so brutal if you have that
happen early. So, love to see what
Kha'Zix can do. And I believe we are
ready to get into our first feature
match of Hartford.
Again, last regional qualifier of the
unleashed season.
Looking forward to seeing how this one
plays out. Looks like game one. Filth on
the left with Ringgar will be on
Emperor's Deis
and then Kha'Zix
June with Zan Warren to start things out
in game one. Filth is going to kick
things off here in round one with a pit
rookie.
>> Yep. Just trying to develop some board
presence early. Both of these are decks
that care a lot about board presence.
They're not necessarily what I would
consider true aggro or an aggressive
deck where you need to go all out every
turn, but you are trying to get presence
and then maximize it as much as
possible. And when I say maximize, it
could be with the might that you're
developing or with the tricks. Kha'Zix
being a Chaos Domain legend does have
quite a bit more tricks. We'll see if
that is a difference maker. And
>> we do see that Mr. Route coming out for
June. We talked about that. The XP that
it can gain as we go back over to Filth
Conquering with the pit rookie at
Emperor's Deis does use that conquer
ability, paying the one energy, bouncing
back the pit rookie to hand and getting
a sand soldier on Emperor's Deis. And
the pit rookie will be replayed to buff
that sand soldier. That's a three might
unit at that northern battlefield as we
go back over to June.
>> Yeah, and this is a nice development
because it's essentially drawing a card
for filth because you are uh developing
that sand soldier, getting the pit
rookie back, and then replaying it. And
in doing so, you're getting an
additional unit from the pit rookie.
It's like if you developed a three might
unit that you just drew off the top. Uh,
yes, it's kind of just on average rate,
you essentially spent three energy to
get three might, but if your hand is
clunky, this is a solid play to kind of
continue developing that might like I
talked about.
>> Speaking of clunky hands, if June has
one, going into Zan Warren here,
conquering up to one point. All right,
channel
>> and we'll be able to use that Zon Warren
trigger
>> pipe to cycle through the hand.
All right. And
maybe had a slight glitch, but we will
consider this just an an an amazing uh
replay opportunity. Yeah, we we'll see
the uh the great pit rookie play once
again here.
>> Yeah,
>> and keep in mind with that Rengar Pride
Stalker, every time that Filth plays a
unit, be able to give another unit plus
one might
>> for the turn,
>> a unit plus one might for the turn. And
and that is something that it might not
seem like a big deal early on, but when
you are using the signature spell, for
example, again, because that plays the
unit, it does also trigger the static
legend ability. There are also a number
of uh ambush options. And so when you
play an ambush unit in this list, that
also is going to trigger it. So uh you
can get a lot of mileage from the text
on the Pride Stalker Legend.
So take number two here,
June with the Mr. Route in the backline.
Again, Mr. Route whenever it moves to a
battlefield, you gain two XP, which
again, we want to get as much experience
as we can with this Kha'Zix legend.
You spend one XP to buff a unit. You
spend two XP to move an exhausted
friendly unit at a battlefield back to
base. That's what allows you to go in,
conquer, and then move back. All good.
>> As June does score his first point of
the game.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh the Z warns trigger is going to
happen here as well. And we see a
discard of a star crossed, which is
interesting. If I'm filth and I see
that, I might then uh potentially assume
that there is a Fizz in the hand of June
because that's a really powerful card in
a matchup like this. But if June is okay
with getting rid of it, either their
hand is incredibly flooded or clunky or
they have ways to get it back like Fizz.
>> That's absolutely right. Fizz plus
Starcross so good together. 2XP spent
with the Kha'Zix legend to move Mr.
Route back to base and Vex Apathetic
developed for June as Filth holding up
to two points
in the opening game continuing to
currently hold on to point tempo. Now we
see the Kinko initiate and this will
draw a card
draw
>> as there is five might or at least five
might between the other units for filth
and also does get that buff as well. So,
exactly what you want to be doing if
you're filth, you want to develop might,
keep your hand full of options. On the
other side, when the showdown begins,
filth going to the zone. Warrens, June
has the option to uh play a stacked deck
at action speed. Even though there are
no units there, it is still a showdown.
So, just getting some hand filtering in.
>> Son Warren's allowing some good hand
filtering for both players as Filth does
conquer up to three. Kai'Sa discarded
drawing another card and that sand
soldier will move back into base.
Filth passing back over to June. Yeah,
and the Kai'Sa discard here makes sense.
Even though that's an incredibly
powerful card, Filth has been doing a
good job of maintaining the hand
resources between the bounce with the
deis earlier, the draw off the kinku.
So, uh, this is a situation where the
Kai'Sa is just kind of like win more.
And unless you really thought you needed
that accelerate play from hand later,
getting rid of one here is fine.
Now, we'll see how June pushes forward.
Mr. Routt on the back line still able to
generate that XP. We're going to start
with Sabotage. June will take a look at
Filth's hand.
>> See what we find. Double punch first.
Yeah, this is quite the hand here.
>> Yeah, this is this is quite the hand. Uh
there is also a thrill of the hunt in
there.
>> Yeah,
>> this is kind of tough because on the one
hand you obviously want to get rid of
punch first. They're an incredibly
powerful card, but since there is two of
them as well, if you get rid of one,
they're still going to have the other
one. And the likelihood of them playing
two in a short period is pretty low
because of the intense power costs. Uh,
in fact, Filth can't even do it right
now, though, you have to assume at some
point in the future going to channel an
additional body rune to get the four
that would be required. However, Thrill
of the Hunt, uh, again, it triggers so
much for your deck. It provides
mobility. It can save units. It does so
much. So, I feel like, if I'm in June's
shoes, I'm taking a long look at that
signature spell.
>> Could not agree more. I think that is
extremely scary.
Now, the choice here could also be
dependent on what is in June's hand
because if you have something like an
additional star cross, we saw the one be
discarded. Perhaps that was bait and
there is another one. Oh, we got to see
a little bit of it there. I saw a void
assault and uh some other options. But
if you have a situation where you are
expecting your opponent
>> uh to like double up on a punch first,
then you could
>> get a blowout play. but uh does actually
decide to take one of the punch bursts.
>> Okay, so getting rid of one of the pump
spells
as June looks to move in with Vex to
Emperor's Deis and that will score June
a second point 3 to2 in favor of Filth
currently.
Yeah, and the Vex being on a battlefield
is a very big deal into Rengar because
that means the ambush units are now
stunned. Uh, this also could be another
reason why you opted to get rid of a
punch first because the thrill of the
hunt, as good as it is, when you replay
the unit from it, if that Vex is on a
battlefield, that would also enter
stunned. Uh, that being said, you have
to assume that filth knows Vex is
coming. This uh Vex has been a staple
since the release of Unleashed in the
meta. Uh, if you're not expecting to run
into it, you're going to have problems.
You need to have answers. So, we'll
we'll see what the proposed answer is
here.
>> And now we see June running in with the
Mr. Route, getting that 2 XP
and ambushing out the chosen champion,
the mutating hard, getting that
additional two might and another two XP.
And when you win a combat,
the legend gives you another XP. So,
that's 5 XP now as June conquers up to
three. And on the filter earlier I had
mentioned, hey, maybe they discarded the
star cross because they had another.
Well, it turns out they did and now
they've discarded that to the zone
warren's trigger as well.
>> Definitely playing into the fizz here.
>> Yeah, the makes sense. uh production has
given me some fantastic mathematical
notes. And the one that jumps out to me
for June in particular is that Fizz
overperforms
by 13.4% with your match wins. Meaning
when you see it, when you find it, you
are 13% more likely to win a game. And
it's exactly for reasons like this. Look
at the plethora of options that are in
June's trash between the starcross and
the stack deck. if you want to hand
filter it. It's just such a versatile
card while also developing the might.
But uh here we're going to see Kha'Zix
activate and save the Kha'Zix champion
unit so that it can live to fight
another day. Yeah, keeping Vex apathetic
on the battlefield to keep that ability
turned on.
And all of these units that Filth plays
while Vex is at that battlefield will be
stunned.
as Phil starts the turn. Still has the
buffed up sand soldier, the Kinko
initiate in the backline.
Two runes open for June.
>> Sentry Rengar triggered sand soldier.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Got to hear the players talk
about it there.
>> Playing the sentry
>> to use that legend ability. Get the one
might trigger from Rengar Pride Stalker.
putting those on the sand soldier. And
now walking this in
again. June knows that there's a punch
first on the other side.
>> Plus what?
>> Now here comes grim resolve from June.
Plus three might for Vex.
So seven to five. Now the might totals
in favor of June first.
>> But there comes the punch first that we
did know about.
>> Dramping a couple runes here.
And that is going to go over the top for
Phil. Filth conquering Emperor's Deis.
Vex killed in combat. And FH up to four.
>> Yeah. And I feel like June's thought
process here is that you got rid of one
punch first with the sabotage. You know
they have the second. The faster you can
force them to use it, then you just
don't have to worry about it as much
going forward. Only one likely left in
the deck at that point. Uh some lists
are not even on the full three, but you
kind of have to play around them having
the three. Uh that being said, it is
nice to see two out of the way and kind
of forcing those resources gone. Now the
downside to that is uh filth is now
popped up to five after that conquer
with the kinku on the zon warren. So
they have five points. They have a
superior battlefield presence and just a
superior board presence overall. Uh just
the Kha'Zix chosen champion unit in the
base for June. So, uh, June's going to
have to figure out a way to, uh, not
just keep pace with points, but also
start to deal with some of this board
presence de developed by Filth because
you're behind a bit. Now, we did see the
void assault earlier. That might be on
the mind because you could go in, win
one combat uh, against the Kinku
potentially and then also use that to
pull a unit and try to win another
combat or just move your unit over
there. Uh but to kick things off here,
we're just going to see some might
stacking before any sort of skirmish
begins.
>> So that Kha'Zix five might going into
the battlefield, but that trigger
Kha'Zix attacks or defends if there's an
enemy unit alone there, you get that
additional plus two might and the two
XP.
So Kha'Zix
taking care of the unit at Zan Warren's.
June conquering up to four. 54 point
tempo still in favor of Filth.
June trying to figure out how to swing
the momentum.
Keep in mind we do have a hidden card
now at that Emperor's Deis for Filth.
And we we know that the Pike could be
looming here. And there is a void
assault.
>> Yeah. And the pike discarded.
>> The pike has a pretty big deal here
because the Kha'Zix wants to find units
that are alone. And the pike can mess up
that math because of the reaction speed
because it is hidden. It can pop out in
response to the trigger and kind of mess
things up. So instead, it looks like
June is just going to develop this Vex
and maybe play some defense.
Uh oh, interesting. Okay, so we're going
to actually play that void assault. I
did not realize a second one had been
picked up. I saw the one discarded from
the zone warren trigger, but uh we're
going to play the void assault. This
moves a unit and then allows you to move
one of your opponent's units as well.
>> Move my moving here.
>> That void assault so good.
>> Very similar to charm and ride the wind
in one card. So,
>> trying to move a sentry here.
>> Oh, interesting. I was going to say
there there was a an opportunity
>> to
potentially
send the sand soldier over to the Vex
and essentially start two combats at
once. Uh, we're still going to be
starting two combats, but trying to get
rid of the sentry.
>> So, we're starting here.
>> Yeah.
>> The Kha'Zix at Emperor's Deis. There is
the pike.
But Kha'Zix at nine might currently.
>> Thank you.
>> So this and Rengar trigger just make it
simple.
>> So five, six, seven, eight versus nine.
>> Yeah, June still has the advantage here
by one might at this battlefield. Now,
there is an option here to ambush in a
unit from the hand of filth, but the
problem is that Vex on the other side.
>> Yeah. So, this
what this will do.
>> Yeah, I was going to say uh what this
will do, however, is it should trigger
the Pride Stalker, which would allow for
one more might to go on the other units.
So, even though Inferna would be
stunned, there should still be
enough
to force this trade and repel the
Kha'Zix.
>> D2.
>> Yeah. All right.
>> Yeah. Very strong play here.
>> I scored a five. Got an XP.
>> And then this recall.
>> Why' you score a five?
>> Uh, everything is stunned.
>> Stunned. Okay. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the the pike the the pike and
the inferna should have both been
stunned because of the vex.
>> So but I was going to say
>> and she got stunned by vex.
>> Oh no no you're right actually.
>> Yeah I was going to there again I was
going to say this should result in a
repelled Kha'Zix.
>> Right. Not enough might for Kha'Zix to
get over.
>> I'm at four yard five. Right. Uh how big
was Kha'Zix?
>> Nine.
>> Nine. I had uh 10. One of them was like
a lot of a lot of stuff was stunned
because of the facts.
>> Oh, true. The uh the pike came in stunt.
That's right.
>> All right. They got there.
>> We got it. We got it figured out.
>> Yeah.
>> We got there.
>> Vex showing up here.
>> Sentry will be killed in combat with
Vex.
Cleans up the board a little bit. And
even with June still being behind in
point tempo, the board
>> looking
pretty favorable for June now.
>> Yeah, going into this turn, like I said,
June needed to catch up with what was
developed on the board and try to keep
pace on points. I would say even though
you didn't match the points,
you still accomplished a lot because now
your board presence is significantly
better.
>> You know that two punch firsts are gone.
uh you have your Vex on a battlefield.
So unless they have a third punch first,
that is likely going to be able to
survive an attack from the sentry.
>> So Wow, Filth does go up to six here,
which is a very important number because
that allows for a potential future
double conquer, etc. It was still
overall, I think, a quality turn from
June to try to claw back into this.
Yeah, the Inferna coming back for Filth.
Potentially trying to set up a possible
double conquer on the following turn.
Filth at six points now. And keep in
mind that chosen champion Rengar trophy
hunter
>> yet to be deployed here for Filth.
Interesting.
>> Holding to. So you I mean you are
correct. I do think that that Rengar
does likely need to be developed at some
point, but by not playing it during your
turn, if that Vex is still on a
battlefield, even if you play it as an
ambush, it's going to get stunned. So, I
would have liked from Phil there to see
some additional might developed in base
and then go over the top with uh tricks
of some sort in the future. This again
might signal a bit of a clunky hand. got
to see a lot of it earlier from the
sabotage, but since then there's been
quite a few cards drawn, so some unknown
information.
>> Now June holding up to five and we see
some of that adaptability from Kha'Zix
here. The XP spent to buff Vex and here
comes Void Assault.
>> Now this is kind of brutal because
Inferno will not get the assault trigger
with Void Assault. Even though you're
moving uh your unit and theirs, theirs
technically arrives first and they get
designated as the defender. So Kha'Zix
gets the plus two for attacking in and
the inferna does not trigger the
assault.
More XP generated for June here. Up to
six points.
We are all tied up and now it's just the
determined sentry in the backline for
Phil.
>> Can you ignore the trigger here?
>> Yeah. Can I respond to it because I
didn't know that? Uh, I don't think I
can choose not to finalize it, right?
>> Choose not to finalize because it's an
optional.
>> You can choose to.
>> So, asking the judge about the emperor's
day is trigger
>> and filth wanted an opportunity to
respond. You have to assume that the uh
desire was to respond by uh again maybe
trying to play that Rengar. even though
it was going to be stunned if it
survives and then recalls, you'd then
still have a unit besides the sentry to
start this turn. But, uh, unfortunately,
Filth just has the sentry. And with that
Vex on the battlefield, this is going to
be a tall order to get into either
location and you have to get into at
least one because this is a threatening
win with a double hold from June at the
moment.
>> Yeah, very tough spot. Great turn for
June. Filth essentially burning all the
runes there. Just did not use any of
those runes on the last turn. Didn't
have the window to potentially play the
Rengar. Now we see the Rengar trophy
hunter coming out.
>> But June holds to eight.
>> And Phil did not realize the score here.
>> Oh, so that
>> there we go. That explains why Phil has
the previous turn. He had June at five
points instead of six. So did not
realize the urgency
was just double thrill of the hunt in
the hand. So we were talking earlier
about you know more cards had been drawn
since we had that unknown information.
Turns out other than the chosen champion
there was nothing else to develop anyway
and the thrill of the hunt is
>> basically useless with that purple Vex
on a battlefield. We really saw the
power of Vex apathetic right there and
it's just so good against the ambush
units and against Rengar in particular
because Rengar one of the best units to
come out of unleashed but if Vex is
parked at the battlefield and you don't
have a way to get her off it is tough.
>> Yeah, this is you know again it's one of
those things you expect since Unleashed
came out. You have to have some sort of
game plan for Vex. Apathetic.
That being said, I think the big story
there was that Filth just had the wrong,
you know, point count in mind because
there was uh far less sense of urgency.
Now, uh here this is interesting. This
is exactly uh where June wants to be
playing with the lead, but also you've
got that forbidding waste. So, if you
can get something like an irresistible
fay folk early, if Filth uh has played a
unit like they have, Yep, there's the
Fay Folk. So, now you either have to
answer it somehow in the backline or
just kind of understand that you're
likely losing a unit because that
combines so well with the waste.
>> Incredibly good here.
Filth once again starting things out.
Starring and Forbidding Waste, the two
battlefields
in game number two here in the round one
feature match of our Hartford regional
qualifier. Inferna moving into Star
Spring and we will see a stacked deck
from June in response here.
So, Inferno will get to conquer on the
Star Spring. There's no other effects
that June will have here with zero
energy available. Stack deck choices
made. But again, because Folk can move
units,
>> unless Filth leaves up some energy, up
some resources for a trick, whether
that's, you know, a punch first or even
just like a thrill of the hunt, etc.,
uh, that's likely going to be eaten. And
we're going to see a sabotage now and uh
a healthy number of options for filth to
choose from.
>> Yeah, you've got the signature spell,
that void assault, grim resolve, and
gust for June paired with the Vex unit
once again.
>> Just noting the cards here. What are
your thoughts on this one, Charmer?
>> So, this one is interesting. I think it
kind of depends on the rest of Filth's
hand. Gust can certainly be annoying.
Like I said before, you can use that to
set up the scenarios where if you're
trying to protect a unit by pairing it
with another uh for the purple Kha'Zix,
Gust can set that up. Uh yeah, and I was
going to say and so if you've got a
number of units in your hand that are
targetable by Gust, I think that's like
the go-to option. Uh if you are not
worried about the Gust, I think Void
Assault is the next best one. uh unless
you're trying to deny the XP. But
Kha'Zix is so good at generating
experience points anyway that uh I feel
like just playing around the plus three
might from hand is fine whereas the void
assault creates additional problems
because if you are trying to hide
something in the backline it can draw it
in like we saw in game one. Uh but in
this case it does look like Gust was
determined to be uh the most
problematic. But also notably here Phil
did leave up that energy for potentially
an answer to the FA folk.
>> Yeah, we could see some interaction
here.
The Fay Folk will certainly look to try
and take down Inferna
at the forbidding waste. That Fault
quite irresistible. It absolutely is.
Now, if you're June, you have to say to
yourself, what am I potentially playing
around here? Punch first is not an
option because there's only one body
rune and the forbidding waste with the
faolk is still enough to take out this
inferna because again the way that the
movement stuff works the fa folk if it
pulled over to the waist would still
trigger inferna as the defender but
instead just going to go to the star
spring instead and play the chosen
champion Kha'Zix. I I personally feel
like unless you are going to pull one of
these back to your base, sending both of
these to the waist would have been fine
because that would prevent a trade into
your fault. The negative might mean you
wouldn't be able to assign any damage.
Um, but if you're already planning on
pulling something back with Kha'Zix, you
don't want to leave a unit by itself.
Uh, and it does look like that's that's
the case. We're going to pull something
back with the Starring.
>> Yeah, I like this play. Love the Kha'Zix
chosen champion and the flexibility it
gives. Great combination. What a duo.
Faithfolk and Kha'Zix pairing up here.
And Starring playing into June's favor
as Faithful goes back to base and can be
used again
at a future time in this game. Inferna
goes down
>> and June will conquer.
Yeah, I was just about to say this also
signals that they're not uh likely going
for a hold point. Uh June,
once you pull back the irresistible
faolk, you likely also want to pull back
the Kha'Zix. It just gives you the most
flexibility. Uh again, if they had went
to the waist and pulled to the wayside,
then I think you leave both there so
that you're not defending alone and you
have to force your opponent to deal with
things. But uh this is the safer path
because now you don't have to worry
about accelerate options. Uh, for
example, we see this Kai'Sa played. It
could have been accelerated if there was
a uh tasty trade to be made, but it's
just going to be develop and pass from
Filth to try to set some up for the
future.
>> Yeah, at this point that Kai'Sa would
have been a sitting duck for that
Kha'Zix mutating hard. Back over to
June, moving into Starring with Kha'Zix
>> scoring up to two. Two to one now in
favor of June.
See if there's any tricks for June here
with that fateful to potentially try and
grab the Kai'Sa.
>> This and this should have been
>> Oh, even worse. You don't need the FA
folk when you have void assault. So,
this is going to pull the Kai'Sa over.
Kha'Zix will get the trigger for
attacking into a solo unit. Uh
meanwhile, because she is defending
alone, Kaisa gets the minus two from the
forbidding waste. And so this means that
even if there is a punch first in the
hand of Filth, it is not enough to go
over the top. Filth does that math and
says, "Okay, so June will now win uh
this combat, get more experience points
as well as go up to three points. Uh and
again, keeping the board of filth
empty."
>> June conquering up to three. That is
great using that Kha'Zix legend ability
to bring Kha'Zix back to base. Develop
Vex Apathetic as well. Filth's board has
been cleared. We're behind on point
Tippo. This is a very tough spot for
Filth.
Yeah, Kha'Zix is definitely one of the
legends that has intrigued me a lot from
Unleashed, and we're seeing why. The use
of experience points as a secondary
resource is really pivotal. uh you're
kind of getting a combination of the
legend effects of Lein in the ability to
buff stuff and like half of the legend
ability of Yasua with the ability to
move your units back and protect them.
But the fact that you can do it without
spending energy means that you can have
plays like we just saw from June while
also still having enough energy left
over to develop cards like Vex. So you
can clear things out, buff your units,
move things back, and then also still
develop on top of it. And I think that
this is really where Kha'Zix shines. Uh
that being said, we're going to see the
Darius played here. And this is going to
get uh I was I was just going to say
that trigger should have happened. Um
but they they beat me to it. I It's uh
plus three because of Criedstalker as
well as the second card being played.
>> It's a super strong play there getting
Darius into the challenge to take out
June's Kha'Zix in the back line.
and Darius being ready as Filth played
the second card. Conquering Starring
three to two now.
>> But keep in mind that Filth all of those
runes are exhausted. So no energy to
play with.
Now the good news for Filth is you got
to score a point. You got to get rid of
the Kha'Zix on the opposing side.
However,
you have now kind of left your Darius
out to dry because you have no energy
open and available. It's just the base
five might. So, it's a simple math
problem for June. Can they go over the
top? The other really rough thing to
consider here is if that Vex apathetic
does get to kind of camp on that
Starring in the near future, you don't
want to be forced into situations where
you have to attack into the forbidding
waste unless you can pull your units
back. And so that means that either
June
or
unfavorable battlefield for the rest of
the game. So we are going to see a big
buff go onto the Folk.
>> Wow, what a play. That is a four might
fa folk pulling the Darius down into
forbidding waste. Darius goes down to
three might. Darius falls in June
conquering a massive play there once
again clearing out Filtha's board as Vex
will score as well at the northern
battlefield. Massive turn for June.
>> Yeah, Vex will end up on that star
spring as I had mentioned.
>> Uh we do also have the Fa Folk at the
waist, but I would not be surprised if
we see the Kha'Zix legend ability pull
it back and that is exactly uh what
we're seeing now. So, oh, we're instead
buffing. My apologies. I thought we were
going to see it come back, but perhaps
with the development of the second FA
folk, you're fine with letting that one
go.
>> Um, you are also kind of enticing Filth
to go to the waist anyway.
This could also just be a gambit where
you're saying, I want to guarantee I get
at least one hold point. So, Vex already
makes it difficult because it's going to
stun anything entering play. Uh but also
on the other side,
>> if you can't get rid of it, you get a
free hold point out of it as well. And
so June is very likely going to be going
to seven here because of the presence of
the Vex and not a lot of like direct
removal. Uh we don't know what the
sideboards are. Maybe Filth has
sideboarded in something like Falling
Star, but uh the downside with Falling
Star is if you use that to take out the
Vex, like yes, it gets the job done, but
you also have to recycle four runes to
do so because of paying for the deflect.
Yeah, that would be quite expensive. And
we just continue to see Vex absolutely
shutting down the Rengar unable to
ambush in and take out these units. So,
Rengar just developed on the backline
for Filth passing back over to June.
Will hold
>> up to seven.
Yeah, this is a a hold up to seven and
we could see uh like a a bit of a
retreat back at least from the fay folk
side
and just try to hold with the Vex side.
The other units available to June are
not necessarily might intensive, right?
We have two fa folk and a Lucian.
But if June has more combat tricks,
right, perhaps more grim resolves or uh
their own punch firsts, etc., they might
just try to turbo stack on the star
spring and say, "Uh, come at me, bro."
But we also could see a situation where
uh if you are confident in your ability
to retake, you could pull both units
back, just develop more might because
you're not in danger of uh you know,
filth stealing this from you with only
two points. Uh and then just set
yourself up to kind of pick and choose
where you want to double conquer in the
future. So, a lot of options available
to June right now for how to try to
close this out.
And you definitely have to be careful
about potentially trying to go after
that Rengar here just because punch
first certainly an option at this point
for Filth.
>> So Lucian moving into Starring.
>> One Faithful going back. The other
Faithful coming in.
>> So this is actually a fantastic play
from June. June puts the Lucian on the
Vex,
right? But then June used one of the
irresistible FA folk to force the Rengar
into the forbidding waste just gives
Filth a point. But because June has
amassed such a huge point lead, doesn't
really matter, but it does strand that
Rengar on the forbidding waste. So
unless Filth has a way to force the
Rengar over to the other location, it
can no longer attack into the spot that
you're trying to hold. And because of
Vex apathetic sitting there, Filth can't
accelerate or ambush over there. And it
turns off Thrill of the Hunt. So you
can't even Thrill of the Hunt your
Rengar to the Starring. So June is
essentially saying, I'm removing any of
the ways that you might have
>> to force this trigger. Thrill of the
hunt.
>> Yeah. So, Thrill of the Hunt now.
>> Okay. Sounds back. Yeah.
>> Did you pay your power for that?
>> Thank you.
>> Yep. There. Thrill the Hunt now will at
least force a recall to allow Filth to
maybe set something up for the future.
But that was still such a heads up play
from June to force this here
out of Filth.
>> Yeah, very heads up play for June. But
Rengar in the backline once again. So
Filth will be able to
>> pass on that
>> crack back here on this next turn.
>> Oh yes.
>> Okay.
>> We'll have to break that Vex.
>> Well, June still has potential plays. We
do see the one card in hand. A lot of
runes available. I think the concern now
is because the Rengar did make it back
to base, June might consider pulling the
Vex back just to be safe.
>> But no, we're just going to see a void
assault and try to
>> force
>> Yeah, force the Rengar to be stranded.
>> Yeah, just send it back to the
forbidding ways. Vex still at the Star
Spring and Filth has to figure out a way
to get around Vex
Jun 7 threatening game.
>> Go to four.
>> So this really just comes down to is
there a removal option? So it could be
something like a challenge. Uh again,
you're going to have to pay the deflect.
So it's kind of power intensive. Uh,
Falling Star might be an option, though.
That's going to eat most of your runes.
But you have to have some answer for the
Vex or else June just wins off of the
hold to eight.
The biggest issue for Filth is that even
if you do have an answer, you then have
to also worry about the double conquer
that follows immediately after. So you
could spend a number of resources to get
rid of
this bump. June is going to take it two
games to zero with Kha'Zix.
>> I was like, "Okay, now I got to move."
>> Oh, you love to hear players talk about
their plays right when the game ends and
uh be so happy about it, right? Just
excited about some of the plays. So
going with I wanted to keep him in base
and then I already moved him here and I
was like okay now I got to move him and
then you had to throw
>> fantastic match that was a lot of fun.
>> Yeah I was like
>> Kha'Zix
Vex that duo and then throwing the faith
folk in there that was just too much to
overcome. Oh, absolutely. And uh again,
I think that the real story is in that
game one, there was the kind of like
miscommunic I'm not going to say
miscommunication, just like a
misunderstanding of the points. And so,
Filth was very passive on a turn where
they really needed to develop their
chosen champion to even have a shot of
going over top of the Vex. Uh we know
from the hand it probably wouldn't have
mattered because it was double thrill
the hunt, so there weren't many other
options available. But, uh, that is not
what you want to see to kick, you know,
things off for your round one of the
day. Um, sometimes that can kind of get
in your head a bit. I hope that filth
just shakes it off and continues to play
well for the rest of the day.
>> Absolutely. And the other thing there
was void assault. And you and I talked a
little bit about Kha'Zix and void
assault and what that does for the deck.
And you described it perfectly and it's
what we've been talking about is the
adaptability that Kha'Zix has to the
situation and that void assault is just
used very very well and June was able to
take a great advantage of it in that
match. Yeah, one of the reasons that the
chaos domain has been so popular in
Riftbound's history, yes, we're just
three resets in, but uh is because it's
a ability to create plays through
movement is one of the big attractions,
right? Historically, it's been cards
like Ride the Wind or the now banned
Fighter Flight, but Void Assault allows
for some of that movement and then the
Kha'Zix Legend does so as well. So June
was really able to use the combination
of those two to avoid fights y and then
pick the fights when you want them and
where you want them. And then when you
combine that with irresistible fa folk,
you have so many ways to just force your
opponent into combats that you want to
take. Right?
>> Then also pull back and say, "Okay, I
don't want to get into any uh additional
combats, additional fights unless I'm
ready for it." So, it's a a wonderful
master class on deciding how you want to
pick your fights, how you want to pick
your skirmishes and get the wins when
you have the most favorable situation
for yourself.
>> Yeah. Well, June the best of last
weekend on Kha'Zix in Utre and showing
why I chose Kha'Zix to take it down this
weekend. So, hopefully June will
continue this great run. But speaking of
the great start for June, let's send it
over to an interview now.
Thank you so much for that excellent
cast here. And for our round one here in
Hartford at the RQ, I have the pleasure
to be joined with our round one winner,
June, who is also our best of Kha'Zix
player from Utre. So, congratulations
first off.
>> Thank you so much.
>> And now you're playing Kha'Zix again.
And you know, I love this deck because
it is one of the only body decks I feel
like in the format that people aren't
playing Dazzling Aurora in. But be it's
because of the amount of movement and
that the deck does and pulling your
opponent into combats and showdowns that
they don't want to be in. Why do you
think the deck is so good? Because
you've obviously already had great
performance with it.
>> Uh it's all about combat in my turn.
That's the part about Kha'Zix that I
love so much. I choose just like you
said when I have combats and my opponent
is almost never allowed to have combats
in their turn. I always try to pull
back. That's where the illusions are so
great for and of course the legend
ability. I try to just always keep the
battlefields open. So that means our
opponent needs to hold it, needs to
protect it, and I can then just yeah,
kill them at the battlefield in my turn
and then retreat again.
>> No, it's so it's so powerful and like
the fact that you like incrementally
gain the XP, it is in my opinion one of
the best XP decks that exists out there.
But on the on that same boat, you're
coming into this new this new regional
qualifier. It's the last one of the
unleash season. So, you know, the game
is going to change.
>> Did you change your Kha'Zix list in any
center capacity? You don't you don't got
to talk about like sideboard if you
don't want it, but like are there
specific things you learned last weekend
and is there a world where you could
maybe make a top eight appearance this
time?
>> Yeah, so uh actually the master matchup,
the origins master, the proven ground
one, that one was a lot harder at track
than I expected, the master deck also
evolved. And just like Kazix needs to
evolve as well. I also uh this weekend
have some more goodies in the sideboard.
Um yeah, mostly set brawler which is
hopefully going to be showing uh what
it's good for having like insane amounts
of might and uh trying to even though
they get the plus two get over them
quite easily.
>> Absolutely. And I'm glad we even got to
start today with the canonic battle of
Rengar and Kha'Zix. But Kha'Zix taking
the true path of evolution and taking
down the trophy hunter. June,
congratulations on that round one win. I
know you got seven more rounds to play
today. So we're going to go ahead and
send it back.
What a fantastic interview. June
evolving with Kha'Zix learning from last
weekend prepared this weekend and I am
off to a pretty good start. Charmer.
>> Yeah, so far your pick is undefeated on
the broadcast and
>> uh I just really liked that interview
because uh Barrett asking about the
iterations, the evolution and
>> June was h happy enough, kind enough to
give us a little bit of an a peak into
the sideboard and the inclusion of set
brawler is phenomenal because of the
legend's ability to spend experience
points to give it a buff and then you
can use that buff to make it even
bigger. If you're trying to go over the
top of some of these Master Yis, that's
how you get there is through inclusions
like that.
>> And this weekend, once again, Master Y
has been so represented. I believe it is
the most represented deck in the field
today. It was most represented yesterday
in the pre-regional RQ. So, look, this
is a deck you have to be prepared for,
and June is, and I love to see it. Well,
you also have to be prepared for our
analysis and replay segments. So, we're
going to be sending it over to Gretton
so that we can take a look at some of
the iconic moments from this first
round.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Charmer. Yeah, we saw
phenomenal round one here at the
regional qualifier in Hartford, and that
was kind of a masterclass on how I think
Kha'Zix should be played. And there's a
couple moments that I really want to
dive into in game number two where this
irresistible fa folk has become an
absolute behemoth of a card. And if you
can see here, the current score is, you
know, 3-2 in favor of June. But right
now, there is a big Darius on the side
of uh Filth. And we have to find a way
to score two points to kind maybe get
rid of that Darius. And what is going to
be interesting here is we're going to
start with, you know, giving our FA folk
that grim resolve when we start this uh
footage here and then moving it into
this battlefield, the foroding waste.
And for those of you who don't remember,
this forboding waste will give the
defending unit a negative two. And
because you are applying contested
status with this faolk, it allows you to
kind of have that swing in might where
now your faolk is going to get that plus
three. you're going to be four might and
then oh all of a sudden here comes our
friend Darius where he's going to now be
at a negative uh two and we're going to
win this combat which is going to free
up the star spring so we can move our
Vex over there and lock down that
battlefield. Everybody knows Rengar
likes to play surprise units. So, if you
can establish your Vex on a battlefield
where their base is clear, you have a
very, very safe sort of next turn where
you're going to be able to kind of net
yourself two points here on this turn,
but four points overall because they
won't be able to really push you off
this battlefield. So, this was actually
really good and creative use of the
irresistible faith folk. And when we
actually go into our second uh segment
here in this game number two, we see
another version of this, which was in my
opinion very creative. So right now we
have the Vex who's on this battlefield.
So all units that get played are going
to be stunned, right? We have an
irresistible faithful here. We're at
seven points. All we got to do is hold
this battlefield to win the game. So
what is the plan here? We got to figure
out how do we get this Rengar locked
into a battlefield. So, what's going to
be very cool here is we're going to see
June rotate. Whoops. Rotate the
Fay Folk back to the base, try to bring
the other Fay Folk in, and then the
Rengar will sit on that battlefield. So,
we're essentially sacrificing one of our
Fay Folks to lock that Rengar on that
battlefield. So, that on our following
turn, there is nothing really our
opponent can do because that Vex
apathetic is still sitting at the star
spring. So, if we go ahead and actually
roll the footage here, we'll be able to
kind of see that in action where we're
just, you know, bringing our faith folk
back, kind of thinking of what we want
to do here. You know, bring our Lucian
up, bring our Lucian back. What exactly
are we trying to do? And we're going to
bring that faith folk in to the for uh
forbidding waste. This time, we're just
kind of sacrificing it. We just want to
lock in that Rengar. And Phil, he knows
what's we know he knows what's
happening. So actually later on in this
turn, he's going to try to thrill of the
hunt his unit over to the other
battlefield to force a combat where he's
stunned so he can recall. So if we go to
the second part of this turn now, we'll
actually see how we end up with this
board state where because as we see in
the trash here, uh there's a thrill of
the hunt. This was just played by Filth
to bounce his unit off of the star
spring. a really creative use of the
signature spell from Rengar to be able
to set up an opportunity to clear that
Vex off the battlefield on the following
turn. But June playing Kha'Zix has
access to a spell called void assault.
So we're actually going to see the void
assault get played, move one of the
faolk in, move the Rengar back, and
we're going to have the exact same board
state that we had previously. And then
all June has to do is pass the turn. So,
we'll go ahead and play that footage
here, and you'll take a look that when
June is actually playing the void
assault, he's kind of thinking of, oh,
do I want to bring my Vex back? Oh, and
then he finds the line where he's he's
actually like, oh, we're going to bring
that uh Rengar into the forbidding
waste. He's going to be like, I'm
actually going to bring my fa folk in as
well from the void assault. Uh so this
is again a master class on how we see
the signature spells of these both these
legends used to the you know their best
of their ability. Uh I am particularly
interested in seeing how Kha'Zix
continues to evolve pun intended
throughout this tournament. But if this
is you know any example of how we're
going to see Kha'Zix play today Josh I'm
going to be honest I'm not surprised why
you picked it. So thank you for this.
I'll pass it back to you guys at the
desk.
Appreciate the shout out, Gritten. Great
analysis and really such a clever line,
the getting that ringard trapped at that
southern battlefield. That's exactly
what you needed to do to close out the
game and was something a line that a lot
of players may not even see, but that
was quite clever.
>> Yeah, that's really understanding the
power of Vex apathetic because uh again,
it's going to shut down any Accelerate
plays. it's going to shut down any
ambush plays. And so knowing that your
opponent has no other ways to play units
and get to that other battlefield, if
you can strand it in one location,
you're kind of limiting their options to
just having enough spell removal to deal
with the threats. And so ultimately,
June used that to close out the match.
>> Yeah, absolutely. But that is not all we
have for you here in round one. We've
got a second feature match and I believe
we might have an Aurora, but we're going
to check out the deck list first and it
looks like Ari is going to be first up.
Ari is one that a lot of players love to
try to get this best of. This is a deck
that wants to try and hold and it has
some very defensive units here on the
top end. Charmer with that Alpha
Wildclaw and Val.
>> Yeah, Ari is obviously my favorite
League of Legends character. There's a
reason I'm called Charmer and it's
because of Ari. So, I love re deck
lists. Uh there are usually two schools
of thoughts, at least in the current
meta. Uh this one is the blue sentinel
hold version. So, what this deck is
trying to do is play an early two drop.
That's why we see the scuttle crabs, we
see the stalwart poros, we see the
mouser, and then use that to get on a
battlefield and slam down the blue
sentinel. The reason the blue sentinel
is important is twofold. One, it's a
really big defending unit. It has uh
shield two, so defending it goes up to
six might. Then with your legend
trigger, you're essentially defending at
seven might, which is massive. But also,
when you hold, you get a power, but hold
effects trigger an additional time. So,
it's going to generate a couple of power
for you. It's going to generate
additional draws from things like Grove
of the Godwillow. uh it gives you an
attempt an attempt at maybe a double
additional points off something like
power nexus but on top of that we have
cards like vile maw so using that power
that you're getting from the holds means
developing additional things without
dramping yourself uh again the
additional power generated from blue
sentinel also leads into the alpha wild
claw that you mentioned it leads into
thousand tailed watcher uh this is just
a fun list overall
>> yeah absolutely looks super super cool
love to see that this is going going to
be featured in round one. I think we've
got one other deck to show here. We've
got a Civer list and Civer was your pick
for the weekend. So, this is your
classic Aurora Civer, but it looks like
this one's a little bit different,
Charber. Uh yes. Uh the big thing that
jumps out is instead of the traditional
three elder dragon, one mind spplitter
for the units you're hunting for, uh
Tron is bad is running three Baron
Nasher and a single Elder Dragon. So,
this is all about playing the Baron,
getting those additional hold points,
and getting uh just a hard to deal with
presence on the board. I'm very excited
to see this particular matchup. I think
Ahri uh unfortunately has a rough
matchup into Aurora to begin with, and
when you do win, it's usually some
combination of using charm to get their
big units off of battlefields and then
time warp to close things out. But
because you cannot target the Baron, you
won't be able to charm it off of the
Baron pit. So, this is going to be extra
difficult for Tater Mau. I'm kind of
curious to see how they navigate this.
>> Yeah, it's going to be really, really
tough. Baron Nasher can't be chosen by
enemy spells and abilities. So, love to
see this new iteration of the Dazzling
Aurora. Pretty sure we are ready to get
into this match.
>> So, another bad and tater mouth. Another
fun thing I noticed about uh Tron's bads
list, there were three copies of Ride
the Wind. So once those Barons come
down, you are riding the wind all over
the place with Baron Nasher, which just
thematically makes me so happy to think
about. That is some wild stuff, Charmer.
Very innovative Aurora list here.
Getting ready for game number one.
>> Civer versus Ari.
>> Paying attention to the battlefields
here. On Trana's bad side, we have Sigil
of the Storm. Uh on the other side
though, I'm very intrigued by
Tatermount, including Power Nexus as the
neutral battlefield. So, uh using that
when you don't know, uh what your
opponent is going to be doing. That is
interesting because it tells me that
they're trying to take advantage of this
blue sentinel surprise and use again
that power generated from blue sentinel
to pay for the power nexus costs and you
kind of want to do it before your
opponent can adapt to what your game
plan actually is.
>> Rotator Miles starting out with the
stalwart porro's
bad was able to mobilize on that opening
turn getting the early ramp.
Yeah, taking advantage of the fact that
if you're going first, your opponent
cannot defy your mobilize, but also just
in general always want to be ramping
when you can to get to your dazzling
Aurora.
>> Scrier's Bloom there coming out. So,
we'll have some draw capabilities here
starting next turn for Tron's bad as the
stalwart Porro moving into the northern
battlefield.
And uh here comes the attempt of a gust
and the defy is in the hand for
tatermau. Uh this is an incredibly
important moment. I know we're very
early in the game, but that gust if it
slows things down for the Ari almost
wins the game on the spot because Ari
being a hold ccentric deck uh can
sometimes struggle to race in points and
then Tron is bad if they find the Aurora
would have the ability to stabilize. So
being able to stick this early conquer
and start threatening the hold points is
critical
>> and developing further on the backline
with tater mau. Another stalwart porro
and that mutated mouser.
Tron is bad will
use that activated ability on the bloom
predicting two
and will then draw one
>> and seeing two ramp options there. There
is both the mobilize and the catalyst.
on the bottom.
>> And looks like I was going to say going
to keep the catalyst of Aons so that
they can continue their ramping
>> up this turn with uh Tater Mau if fully
exhausted on runes. You don't have to
worry about defy. So you want to take
advantage of this window and ramp up. Uh
Tater Mau unfortunately with the double
two drop development the previous turn
did not have the blue Sentinel. Uh that
is potentially problematic because if
you could have played the blue sentinel
on the power nexus, you might uh again
start using that trigger as weird as it
sounds this early just to ramp up the
point pressure because Tron is bad is uh
essentially in dazzling Aurora range now
and you only have two points. That is
not where you want to be if you are the
AR player.
>> Tater Mau going to move into sigil of
the storm. conquer up to three, but does
have to recycle one
>> rune.
>> And they're going to float that one
energy before the uh recycle and then
use that energy
to help develop a ZA's hourglass.
>> Display that. Now, the interesting bit
here is if you're expecting your Aurora
player, your opponent to be on Elder,
you might have considered also moving
the mouser up to a location. Because
right now, Elder could target all three
cuz it's one in each spot. Whereas, if
you move the mouser onto one or the
other of these locations, only one would
be targeted. So, I don't know if this
means that Tater Mau uh is familiar with
Tron's bads list or not, but uh in the
current setup, you would have all three
targeted and you would save one with the
hourglass, whereas if you had uh put the
mouser on another location, then only
two could be targeted and one would be
saved from the hourglass. So, uh,
perhaps either a missed window or
perhaps just inside knowledge to Tron is
bad's list.
>> And here comes the dazzling Aurora.
>> Thanks so much.
>> Civer able to generate the gold for
Tron's Bad.
>> Yeah. And so,
>> Cyclone, you generate that gold.
>> The Civer
>> likely outcome is Baron, which is
exciting. We get to see
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> There it is. We get to see the Baron
pit.
Um, so once again, Tater Mau, if this
was the Elder Wood's potentially going
to be punished, but is actually going to
be heavily rewarded for this setup now.
>> Start show
>> going to conquer there at the Baron Pit
with Baron Nasher getting on the board.
And now we have three battlefields in
play. Tron's bad passing back over.
Tater Mau will hold
>> two here up to five.
>> Yeah. And this hold to five, believe it
or not, is very important because if
Tron is bad doesn't have a way to stop a
hold on that power nexus, there could be
a situation where Tater Mau with holding
at two locations, but one being the
power nexus could go from 5 to eight.
So, this is already threatening a
game-winning hold scenario. Now, Tron is
bad will have plenty of options to maybe
try to interrupt that. Like I said
before, I saw three ride the winds in
the list. So, Baron Nasher could kind of
go all over the place, clean up some of
these porros. Uh you do also have the
Aurora trigger potentially hitting the
one Elder Dragon in the list, but uh
this is still a situation where Tater
Mau could benefit from using this Power
Nexus as their neutral battlefield.
>> Power Nexus not something we see a lot
of, but could be utilized beautifully
here.
>> Tater Mau going to bring out the chosen
champion Ariing. Now you're threatening
to score additional points on hold at
two different battlefields
as Tater Mau
looking to try and close out this
opening game going to hide a card at the
Northern Battlefield.
>> So there's a very strong likelihood that
that is something like a back off
>> but unfortunately back off cannot target
Baron Masher. Again, it cannot be chosen
from uh enemy spells or abilities. That
being said, if it is
a ride the wind here, we do also have
two energy up for tater mau. There could
be another defy. We've only seen one
played so far this game.
Tron is bad does go up to the two points
after holding that Baron pit, but really
is more concerned with getting rid of uh
these two hold options
because otherwise Tater Mau will be able
to just win the game on the spot.
Do or die turn here for Tron is bad in
game one of round one in the Hartford
regional qualifier.
And I know it seems silly, but I really
do want to highlight what we saw at the
start of this, which again was having
that first defy for the gust. That is
what has allowed Tater Mau to kind of
maintain this points momentum
and really start to ramp up with the
holds. If that early gust was
successfully
cast, Tater Mau would only be at three
points at the moment and this would be a
much different game.
>> Absolutely. Now we
>> have Tron's bad with the ride the wind.
So Baron Nasher
>> would be riding the wind to the southern
battlefield. It's going through
>> taking out both Ari and the Porro. Now
Zona's hourglass will trigger saving
Aria's
Bad up to three points.
Now this is
important for Tron's Bad just because if
Dazzling Aurora does grab another Baron
that's always going to go to the Baron
pit for the text on the card. So having
this Baron Nasher in another location
>> uh means that you're still going to be
threatening multiple holds going
forward. uh may have a gold.
>> Thanks,
>> Tater. Not having the defy there for
that ride the wind
means that even if they were to use the
power nexus, they could only go to seven
now.
And as I said before, missing that blue
Sentinel, which is typically what this
version of Ahri is looking to do on turn
two, is get that blue Sinel up and
active does mean that Tater Mau uh does
not have the ability to use the Power
Nexus twice.
Tron's bad. Leaning over for the chosen
champion.
>> Civer mercenary.
>> Accelerate. Civer.
>> So, recycle. Another
>> civer is ready.
>> Accelerated out going into the northern
battlefield.
A total of eight might getting plus two
from her own ability, plus two from
Baron. And there is the back off.
>> Civer getting stunned and we'll push
back to Tron's bad space.
>> All right. And moving to the endstep now
means we are looking for another unit.
Now it's two more barons and one elder
dragon. Elder dragon. the ideal pull
right now for Tron is Bad. Uh
>> they're all in hand.
>> They're all in hand.
>> Brutal stuff here for Tron is bad.
>> The other Baron Nashers and Elder Dragon
in hand and I believe we're only looking
at what four or five cards in hand.
That's tough.
>> Yeah, that is brutal for Tron's Bad. I
said going into this that Ari
traditionally has a very bad matchup uh
in two dazzling Aurora lists and usually
what I say is the only way that you win
is if you get a fast start or their deck
bricks. Uh that is part two of the plan,
right? Their deck bricking. Uh Trana's
bad is unfortunately
stuck with all of the cards that you
don't want to draw in. Yeah, now we can
see it. There's another dazzling Aurora.
And there is the Elder Dragon and two
Barons.
>> That is brutal.
>> And Tater Mau scoring an additional
point off of the power nexus. Paid that
power cost.
>> Sure.
>> Mouser going into the Baron pit.
And
>> this is
>> uh I was going to say mostly about the
draw if that mouser's going in because
right now double stacking the Baron
doesn't really do a lot. Uh again, if
you're not familiar, Baron pits text
says that you can move there from
anywhere. So that Baron Nasher can go
from the sigil right into the pit. Um,
maybe this is just an unfamiliarity with
the text on Baron pit, but I'm very
surprised to see two mousers from
Tatermau go into the pit like that. Tron
is bad holding up to four
once again in a position where he has to
clear out now both of these
battlefields.
Yeah, thi this is an interesting
position to be in if you're tater
because Baron can by itself clear out
the mousers and then you do also have uh
Civer getting that passive buff from
Baron Nasher, right? Remember, it gives
a plus two might to the friends.
>> And I think we're going to see
>> another
>> another Baron Nasher.
>> Civer getting an additional plus two
might.
>> Yeah, another Baron comes down which
will give that Civer an additional plus
two might. Um
>> Yep.
>> Wow. Baron pit conquered
>> by that first copy of Baron Nasher
>> up to five is Tron and Tron is bad now.
Civer moves into the power nexus. It is
a massive Civer Aurora trigger. You saw
there's something in my deck.
>> Yeah. Interesting thing here. Um unless
there was an additional might. I I
didn't see the D go on it from uh like a
civer trigger. That should have been a
trade. If Tater Mau remembers the Ahri
trigger, Ari should have made Civer go
down one might from the legend ability
to seven and then the shield on the
Porro would have taken that up to three.
So, uh, instead of that Civer outright
winning that combat, that should have
been a trade there. Perhaps a missed
legend trigger from Tater Mau uh between
that and the double mousers in the pit
knowing that uh units can move to the
pit from anywhere. maybe uh a bit of uh
a mental misstep, but we'll have to see
if they can recover for game two.
>> Yeah, a lot riding now in game two for
Tater Mau. Those Baron Nashers really
doing some good work. The ability, like
you said, to move those Nashers back
into the Baron pit is crucial. So, we'll
see if there's some adaptability here in
game two. And I am also curious, we have
the three Baron Nasher in the main deck,
the one Elder Dragon. I'm curious if
there's some more Elder Dragon in the
sideboard if the numbers change moving
forward.
>> Yeah, I personally feel like there's got
to be some number of additional Elder
Dragons. Maybe this is one of those
situations where if everybody is teching
for your Elder Dragons to always come
out running Mim Deck uh Emperor's
Divides or whatever, you're just trying
to subvert their expectations. Use the
Baronss to win game one and then you
bring them in if it's not one of those
bad matchups. We'll have to wait and
see. Uh we don't know what the
sideboards are. But uh also uh Tater Mau
like I said has a hard time into Aurora
but had an opportunity to win that. We
really just got to remember the AI
triggers and close things out. Uh
remember the text on Baron pit because
you saw it game one, you saw multiple
Barons, you know that they're coming. So
we'll see if that improves in game two.
>> It also was tough that Tater Mau was
unable to find that blue sentinel on the
power nexus game because you talked
about that synergy of being able to hold
there and then trigger that power nex.
So unfortunately not able to find that
and now the power nexus has been used.
>> Yeah. So going into game two if you are
going first as the re player I would
imagine your battlefield of choice will
be grove of the god Willow. You're
likely looking to develop one of your
two drops. Get on it early and then
continue to get your points for holding
from there. But we will see if that is
the case. If that is the battlefield
they are choosing cuz we are going into
game number two now. And uh as I was
saying, Grove of the God Willow is the
choice. Stalwart Porro is going to look
to land on that. And again, this is
important because it really defends at
four if you count the re Legend trigger,
but you do have to remember to do your
triggers when doing so.
>> Tron is bad going to start with
Mobilize. So getting the early ramp once
again here in game two. Want to ramp up
to Aurora as quickly as possible
as Tater Mau will park on Grove of the
God Willow with that Star War. going to
see a gust yet again. Do we have the
defy? We do. Tater Mau will be able to
keep that early point tempo with the
Defy countering the Gust.
>> And on the board is Tater Mau developing
the Sunlit Guardian
>> in the back line.
>> And it looks like Tron's bad wants to
read it. If you're not familiar, this is
something that uh has tank and shield.
So, uh, some reasons that this has run
in Ariel is the fact that it's just a
three might that does not cost power,
but it defends at five and also has
tank. It defends at five because of the
plus one from the shield. And then
again, you count that minus one from the
re legend ability. And now Tron's bad is
asking to read that as well. probably
doing that mental math won't matter for
a while because Tron is bad is likely
not developing a lot of units before
dazzling Aurora,
>> but we we'll wait and see.
>> Now we'll find out if Tron is bad has
some more ramp to potentially get Aurora
out next turn. We do find immobilize. So
here it is up to seven total runes. So
next turn we could see the Dazzling
Aurora
>> and with one more energy now we see the
Lunar Bloom which
>> it's going to be drawing a couple cards
here after discarding one for Tron's
bad.
Now continue digging. Uh unless I'm
missing something. I think that the
discard should have happened before the
stack deck from the lunar boon because
stack deck is action speed.
So it cannot be used as a reaction to
the boon.
But perhaps it was the last race that
was discarded and then the lunar boon
was just placed on top. I am now
catching up. Okay, so last was
discarded. Lunar Boon
is a phenomenal card for helping you
filter along with the stack deck. That's
why so many of these dazzling Auroraists
are gravitating to Civer or Misfortune
sometimes as well cuz the card draw and
card filter options in the chaos domain
pairs very well with what you're trying
to do.
>> But importantly, Tron is bad getting up
to the seven runes able to dig through
the deck. Tater Mau holding up to two.
>> Sunlit Guardian
>> going to conquer the southern
battlefield. The Forgotten Monument
>> going up to three points for Tater Mau.
>> Forgotten Monument does say you cannot
score points there uh until the third
turn, but it is the third turn. Tater
Mau went first, Tron second, and then
we're back to Tater Mau as the third.
And uh I have to point out once again,
no blue Sentinel for Tater Mau. Instead,
just jamming their chosen champion,
which is uh the alluring version of Ari.
>> Here comes the dazzling Aurora. What do
we find off the top
>> Mau threatening multiple points and it's
the Elder Dragon that is massive because
you can take out two units here. the
champion unit.
>> Ari is taken out. Very strong pickup for
Tron's Bad
>> as Tater Mau holds up to four.
>> And this might be exactly why Tron is
bad is running this version of the list.
Game one, Tater Mau saw multiple Barons.
So this time around, Tater Mau might
have been thinking, okay, well, if the
Aurora is going to hit a Baron and it's
going to go to the Baron pit, I'll just
put my chosen champion out now and try
to get that extra point from holding.
But instead, Elder Dragon comes down,
likely more from the sideboard. We don't
know for sure,
>> but that then means that you surprise
your opponent. You get to kill a choice
unit and you get to do so when they did
not have the uh energy available for
Emperor's Divide.
>> What a play here. Emperor's Divide
bringing that Sunlight Guardian back,
allowing Tater Mau to go and conquer
Grove of the Godo, which is where he
wants to be, and disarming Rake will
disarm Tron's bad and take out the
dazzling Aurora. But still an Elder
Dragon in play.
Yeah, the movement for the guardian, uh,
yes, it gets you on the grove, but let's
be honest, the
the guardian there is just not long for
this world. There is an elder dragon on
the board. It's really more about
getting that conquer point, getting
yourself up to five. Uh, as the re
player, you want to be in a position
where uh with the combination of the
rake, you're slowing your opponent down
so that they can't develop more units,
and you can hopefully keep conquering
and set up maybe a time warp win. though
there's been a lot of recycled runes. So
instead, it might also be something
where you charm their units off of a
location and then you go for a double
conquer.
>> And we see the gold being used and
another gold generated from Civer as the
chosen champion for Tron is bad is
brought out
>> accelerated.
And so this time here we get the trigger
from Ari,
>> but Civer was still large enough to win
the combat.
>> Elder Dragon will score the second
point.
>> Trron is bad. Scrier's Bloom coming out
as well. So we'll get some filtering
next turn.
>> Uh from the opposing
>> trigger. So it's up to you. If you want
to
>> some good sportsmanship there from Tater
Mau was a missed civer trigger but
>> allowing it to be readied back up
and now
>> Tron is bad is
>> going to challenge the disarming rake.
One of the things that I find
interesting about the play pattern here
is that Tron, even though they have the
Elder Dragon, opted to use Civer for
both the combat and the challenge. And I
think that this is just a conservative
play pattern where the goal is if my
opponent has any sort of surprise that
I'm not expecting. I would rather lose
the Civer over the Elder Dragon because
I don't have Dazzling Aurora on the
board, I want to kind of be protective
of that unit. And so it's still enough
to get the job done. We're going to see
two crabs
and a guardian come down on the side of
Tater Mau.
>> The delicious little scuttle crabs there
in the backline. But over to Tron is bad
holding
two battlefields up to four points.
Closing the point gap. And this board
heavily favors Tron is bad.
We find another dazzling Aurora in the
near future. Things could go from bad to
worse for Tater Mau. Here comes
Sabotage.
>> Oh, we see the two blue Sentinels in the
hand of Tater Mau.
>> Unfortunately, not really helpful at
this stage in the game. They are the
sorts of things that you want to be
playing on turn two,
>> but last turn I think was playing the
scuttle crabs mostly just to draw into
stuff. Entirely possible those crabs
also just drew the the two blue
sentinels, but
>> not what you wanted to see.
>> I'll draw from
>> and even though Tron is bad is only at
four points.
It's looking very dire for Takermount at
the moment. There's not a lot of ways to
get rid of that Elder Dragon. Perhaps
with a, you know, drawn combat trick or
something, you might be able to go over
top of this civer and retake the grove.
>> Then of course draw as bad as those ride
the winds.
>> Yes, could come into play if
>> Tater Mau can take that northern
battlefield.
>> Sticky spot for Tater Mau without a
doubt.
All right. So,
>> scuttle crab moving in looking for
information is tater mount with that
death nail.
>> Yeah, the scuttle crab going into the
elder dragon and reveals a gust, a
flurry, and a baron nasher.
So, in terms of things that you're
concerned about, the flurry is the real
big one in this particular instance
because with that elder dragon, it will
uh kill any units that you're sending to
a battlefield. Uh the gust currently
answers everything that's on the board
side of tater mau as well because shield
is a defensive trigger. So Gust does
still work on the guardian
and as a result we're going to see a
charm go on the civer to try to push it
off of the grove of the god Willow.
>> You have focus.
>> I'll pass focus.
>> Uh I'll gust it.
>> Oh, and the gust
>> coming out looking to return the
guardian.
>> Or no,
>> it's legal to play it.
>> It's not. It's not. Yeah, I was going to
say, so there's a judge question here.
Term is asking if they can play Jana,
but unfortunately Jana says you have to
play it to a battlefield that you
control. So this is a showdown starting
to establish control. So Jana would not
be allowed to save it. Um,
>> Jana different than ambush. Yeah, Jana
is an interesting inclusion as uh a
sideboard option into Elder Dragon lists
because it's the sort of thing where if
they try to target one of your units,
you can play Jana there and um maybe
still maintain your presence, right?
Because a lot of times you want to just
make sure you're still getting those
hold points when the Elder Dragon comes
down. It's a similar concept to the
Emperor's Divide, but uh again, you have
to control the battlefield. That was not
the case. And Tron is bad is going to
just play from hand. This Baron Nasher
>> Chaos
>> going to the Baron pit.
>> We'll bring Tron as bad up an additional
point. Controlling all three of these
battlefields.
>> Focus. I'll go to seven.
>> Going up to seven. Just needs to hold
one of these battlefields. And that is a
lot of might that Tater Mau has to
>> dig his way through.
And the scuttle crabs not doing a lot in
that department.
>> All right, Tater Mau I think is just
going to think through the options
before scooping because there is yeah
nothing that can be done against this
field. uh not enough might on the board
and because you also cannot target that
Baron Nasher with spells or abilities,
even if it was like a charm that was top
decked, uh you you have no way to get
over the Baron. The Baron was the
absolute best way to close that out if
your Tron is bad because uh as you had
pointed out, you're at seven and there
are three battlefields being held and
you have to get units off of all of
them.
>> Yeah. And and we had two scuttle crabs
back there, right? So the zero might
unit's not going to do much to help.
That was tough, but very cool to see the
Baron Nasher iteration there in Aurora.
I thought that was a really interesting
take and it'll be interesting to see how
that list does into some of the more
meta decks of the field and and how that
shift from the three copies of Elder to
the three copies of Baron Nasher impacts
those other matchups. Yeah, the
interesting thing there was uh we did
see a situation where Tater Mau could
have been punished if it was traditional
Elder Dragon actually reaped the
benefits from the fact that it was Baron
Asher, but still did not have enough to
fully close out the game. Though game
one was incredibly close. Uh but again,
I'm very curious to see as the day goes
on cuz we have heard rumblings that uh
our good friend Swag Yellow 420 Yeah.
has made some changes to their list as
well. Maybe we're seeing a new era or a
new version of these dazzling Aurora
lists rise.
>> Well, they didn't have the success they
really wanted last weekend, right? It
was the first time since unleash
unleashed released that we didn't have
an Aurora deck in the top cut. So, now
we're seeing some changes to try and
overcome the meta that they're expecting
and maybe we'll get Aurora back there.
And that's why you were believing that
it's going to make a strong run this
weekend.
>> All right. Well, I also am believing in
the rest of the day. This was just round
one of eight here in day one. So, with
that in mind, we are going to be taking
a short break, but don't go far because
we're going to be back very shortly with
round two of this regional qualifier
here in Hartford, Connecticut.
All right, things are continuing to heat
up. I've got another set of hot takes
here. What is the most slept on legend?
I'm going to go with Annie. Annie's my
goat. Uh I think Pris is going to take
this one down and uh I think people are
scared to play it because they know he's
going to get the best of, but I think
deck's really good.
>> Honestly, the one that excites me the
most is Teemo recently. I feel like it's
a really fun one and it catches people
by surprise a lot.
Teemo. It's gotten a little better, but
it it's it makes people can't play.
>> Slept on legend. It's got to be Ivvern.
Uh we've got the best of Ivvern standing
over here. He's going to future best of
Ivvern. Uh currently doing really well
in the pre-regional, so people don't
expect the Ivvern tech, but it's good.
I'm telling you, it's good.
>> I'm going to have to go with Ivvern. Um
I'm a big Ivvern fan. Uh I think not
many people know how to deal with it.
The his mechanics are kind of funky. Um,
and if somebody's not ready for the
Ivvern tech, uh, they can, uh, they can
get bushed up. So, yeah, Ivvern is
definitely my favorite.
>> Oh, I mean, before the last regionals, I
would have said my favorite Lux, but now
with Lux combo, it's a little bit
different, but uh, I think control Lux
will make a comeback. I will say that's
that's my hot take there. You know what?
I'm going to give it up to my boy Yasuo.
He can do a little maneuver that people
don't expect with the three moves and
everything like that. So, I think Yasuo
is underrated. I think Yaso can be
explored a little more.
>> That was a hard one. It's probably Azir.
I know Azir just won the like recent
regional, but no one else has been close
to like the top way so far. But I think
it's going to pick up, you know,
momentum very soon. Maybe even in this
event.
>> That's going to do it for this set of
hot takes. We'll send it back.
>> All right, we have had some hot takes so
far. We've got another round of hot
takes now though with Jerry. Have you
been enjoying your experience so far
here in Hartford? Is it your first time
in the area?
>> Yeah, it's my first time at like an
official event like this kind of at all.
So, it's been really exciting. Yeah,
it's cool to see all the decorations,
all the people. It's really cool.
>> Hartford's amazing. More East Coast
events, please, so I can drive to them.
Um, but no, the the like it's ecstatic
year. The the energy is electric. like
people are dressed up and playing and
just like getting games in the line,
getting games in the hotel. Like it's
everywhere. It is. Riftbound has invaded
Hartford and it is dope.
>> Uh this is my first time in Hartford and
yeah, it's fun. It's a lot of fun. I
love regionals.
>> Yeah, this is my first regional in
general for any card game. So, I'm
loving it so far. Having a great time.
>> My first time in Hartford, Connecticut.
Yes. First time at a Rift Mound event.
Yes. Experience has been pretty cool.
Coming through those doors and going
through the portal is not a hot take.
I'm from Rhode Island, so like coming
out here, the bu the city's nice and I'm
just loving the the whole atmosphere.
Thank you so much for your time. That's
going to do it for our hot take segment.
Let's send it back.
>> It's getting a little warm in the room.
It's time for some hot takes. Quinton,
what right now is the most overrated
legend or deck in the format?
>> Um, I think I'm going to have to go with
Leblanc. I'm going to go with Master Ye.
I think that his 58% win rate is going
to be proven fraudulent this weekend.
I'm going to have to go with Victor. Um,
not because I don't think that it's a
pretty solid deck. I think in order to
convert with it though, you have to be a
pretty skilled player. And I'm not sure
how many people can pilot it to a degree
that I'm like, "Wow, that I'm I'm
worried sitting across from that."
Overrated. I would have to say Master
Yik.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Oo, overrated.
I might have to go maybe LeBlanc right
now. I mean, Baited Hook is scary, but
it's not seeing as many good results as
like everyone thought it was going to or
seems to think it will.
>> I'm going to say Leblanc.
>> Probably Aurelia. I That's a hard one.
Is it Aurelia or Leblanc?
>> Uh, Azair.
Can I tell you why?
>> Yeah, sure. Go ahead.
>> I play Azair. overrated.
I'd probably have to give something like
uh Misfortune or Civer. I feel like it's
coasting a lot on Aurora. So, without
it, I don't think they're doing too
much.
>> All right. Well, Jerry, we appreciate
it. That's going to do it for this round
of hot takes. We'll send it back.
>> We are back live from Hartford and those
were some hot takes there, Charmer.
Round one, the story was all about Civer
and Kha'Zix taking down the feature
match area. And now we move on to round
two where I've heard some ramblings
about some exciting possibilities here
in round two at the feature table.
>> Yeah, there are going to be great
matchups all day long. Uh, worth
pointing out that both Civer and Kha'Zix
are of the chaos and body combination.
So maybe we're seeing an early trend
here at the events. But the other thing
that's trending is of course the energy.
During that hottake segment, somebody
said that the energy in the room is uh
palpable and it's definitely something
that I've been feeling. I have been to a
couple of these regionals and they're
all fantastic, but it feels like every
time it gets better. There's more and
more excitement. Uh the number of
players that I see playing games in
hotel lobbies or in the case of last
night even outdoors has been growing at
every event and it really feels like
this one is a true celebration of
Riftbound and a lot of people are just
very excited about it.
>> Absolutely. And when I was talking to
people yesterday, there was so many
people that said, "Hey, this was our
first time at a regional qualifier and
they were so excited about it. They just
loved the energy in the room and
everything they have to offer here at
the regional qualifiers. Even if you're
not competing in the main event, right?
There's so much going on with all the
side events and just a lot of great
stuff. And if you can get yourself to
one of these regional qualifiers, you
definitely want to. But I think we've
got a match coming up and I believe
we've got some deck list to show off.
Charmer,
>> well, possibly.
>> Oh, not yet.
>> It's going to depend on what our match
is.
>> So, we have some great choices. As we
were talking about the energy in the
room, well, there's some definite energy
with these choices. We could either see
uh peon gogg.
There we go. Pian's go zug. I'll get
there eventually on set taking on none
other than Jim Davis on Jinx. Or the
other option is Captain Tight Pants on
Leona against Powers Fire on Vex. So we
have two lists that are very hold
ccentric potentially facing off and
Leona is usually a crowd favorite or we
could see set taking on Jinx and again
none other than Jim Davis himself as
that uh is a potential option as well.
So if you're watching this is live you
can help influence the match that we're
going to see on the broadcast. So get
your votes in now. uh you can do so in
the chat. Obviously, it says so on the
screen, but uh let us know which one you
want to see. And with that in mind, I'm
going to ask you, Josh, is there one
that you are leaning toward?
Personally, I love Set. And it was so
much fun watching the run that Colin had
with Set and making the top eight last
weekend. Love that deck. So, I think I
think Set would be really really cool to
see early and see what someone else does
with that deck. Maybe they have a
different iteration.
Yeah, I think I want to see the same
match personally.
>> Okay.
>> But more so because of the Jinx. I think
that Jinx is one of those legends that
is perhaps underrated. You were talking
about the hot takes, right? Uh we know
that the Chaos Domain has historically
been good. Obviously during the big
heyday of Draven, Chaos and Fury were
fantastic together, but I think
sometimes people underrate how strong
the Jinx list is. And so with that in
mind, I'm really hoping that that's the
one that we dive into.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And it sounds like I
think you're going to get your wish
here. I think we are going to be able to
see some Jinx. Jim Davis on Jinx and
then the peons go Zugzug, I believe, is
the the name of our other players. So
very interesting name there. Have some
fun with that as we get down to our
feature area for round two.
Set the boss versus Jinx Loose Cannon
game one. Looks like we are looking at a
Bandal tree in Monastery of Ferana. But
the Bandal tree maybe a question mark on
that one. Charmer. Well, it's definitely
an interesting choice. That tells me
that there might be some additional
hidden options that you might want to
stack. So what's available in chaos and
fury being able to put something
underneath like an edge of knight paired
with a pike would be a dangerous duo if
you're trying to attack into it. So
because Jim Davis is also on Jinx where
you're going to get that benefit. You're
going to get that reward for having less
cards in your hand. Having something
like Bandal tree where you can, you
know, maybe conquer it early and then
just using power, put two cards
underneath gets you that much faster to
your legend activation as well. Well,
here we go. Jim Davis starting things
out with a traveling merchant.
And the merchant of course helping with
those early hand filters. Then on the
other side, uh, we have a first mate.
So, Jim
going up to the four runes here. Going
to be making some decisions
uh maybe beforehand, but I would not be
surprised if we see the merchant uh
filter ahead of time just to give
yourself more information. You know,
again, talking about potential cards on
that Bandal tree as well. I did see a
switcheroo in the hand of Jim Davis. So,
another fantastic option when you're
looking at cards to potentially hide.
>> Going to move the traveling merchant
into the monastery, discarding
>> and drawing a card. Jim Davis will get
on the board first
and notably also going over to the
monastery where uh you kind of want to
defend that. That that is the other nice
thing about Bandal tree, right? It's not
usually a battlefield that your
opponents want to utilize. So, you can
potentially contest the one that they
want. Still hide something there. Then
go to the Bandal tree cuz we're seeing
that sneaky deck hand come down and
conquer the other spot. And then uh you
could theoretically, if your hand
allowed for it, hide as many as three
cards this turn and kind of guarantee a
Jinx trigger on the following turn.
We are going to see two cards hidden,
one at each battlefield.
So, not quite there at the Jinx trigger.
Two cards in hand currently for Jim
Davis. As we pass back over to Peons Go
Zug Zug, first mate in the backline.
Does have that set kingpin as the chosen
champion, which seems to be the way to
go as of late with this set. The boss
deck.
>> Yeah. And again, two cards hidden. So,
just kind of taking a look at the list
that was provided to us as far as the
main deck goes for Jim Davis. Uh, there
are Teeos available. So, uh, Teemo Scout
represents a plus4 might. There are
switcheroos, and we did see one of those
in hand. There is also the Pike Docside
Butcher, which could represent as much
as four might as well if you want to pay
the power cost. Uh, there's also Evelyn,
which is a fantastic option if they
don't attack into you to maybe force a
combat on the following turn. So, I can
see why Jim decided to run Bandalree in
this list because if you're running so
many hidden cards anyway, being able to
double up and make your hand that much
smaller, get to where you're triggering
your Jinx makes a lot of sense.
>> Sug moving into the northern
battlefield. It is the Teemo, the Teemo
scout coming out.
Nothing nothing makes me happier as
somebody who's played a lot of Teemo. Um
just in general when you flip a hidden
card and your opponent leans over to
look at it like wait what?
Yeah, that form might out of nowhere.
The first mate going down. Sneaky deck
hand falls in the process, but Jim Davis
retaining control of that battlefield as
Fiora victorious being played in base
for Zug.
>> Let's play showstopper. And now here
comes the showstopper that will buff
Fiora and allow Zug to move back into
that northern battlefield.
>> Yeah, and this should then make the
Fiora mighty triggering all of the other
keywords as well. Does go over the top
of the Teemo. So that will allow peons
go Zug Zug to score their first point.
but more importantly also interrupts the
double hold that Jim Davis had set up
before because they were on a cadence to
go straight 2468 all the way to victory
and instead now there needs to be a
reconquer attempt.
>> Uh Jim Davis's deck list does look like
one that benefits heavily from holding.
We'll have to see what kind of retake
capabilities it has.
>> Yeah, Jim Davis going up to three
up to four runes. It is worth noting did
damp two runes last turn with the two
hidden cards.
Yeah, the D- ramp I don't think is very
relevant as I look at the list because
uh again there are so many hidden cards
and almost everything that isn't hidden
costs three or less. There is not a lot
of actual energy needed for this list.
Uh one of the cards that costs two, for
example, is Falling Star. And I did see
one in the hand of Jim Davis. Now that
would uh once again recycle multiple
runes, but could be an answer for the
Fiora
is exhausting two runes. Looks like it's
going to be Inferna
>> reinforcing at the monastery.
>> Leaves Jim with two ready runes.
Traveling merchant moving back. We'll
get that move trigger.
>> Discard and draw one.
Now, this is a really heads up play
because if your hand isn't something you
like, you get this move trigger, but
also it's heads up because I believe
it's a switcheroo that is underneath
that Monastery of Herana. And so,
putting the inferno there almost
guarantees you get maximum switcheroo
value for it being a one might unit
going up to whatever is going into it.
This might be a situation where because
the Fiora is mighty and has ganking, uh,
Jim Davis is playing around. Peons go
Zug Zug going Zug Zug over to the
Monastery of Herana and then, uh, kind
of getting him with a gotcha of a
switcheroo.
>> Yeah, the Fiora so good when buffed with
that ganking, being able to go down, but
that switcheroo could be quite clutch
here. Cyri of Cloudfield coming out for
Pons. Go Zug Zug.
leaves four ready runes set. Still in
the champion zone.
Three to2 the score. Jim Davis has the
point tempo. So it is up to Peons go Zug
Zug to try and get a hold of this
southern battlefield.
And we're seeing all of the runes turn
sideways here. And I think this might be
another Yeah, I was going to say another
Fiora that's coming down. So just a
might development in the base. You also
trigger that buff on the Cyri of
Cloudfield. This could be a situation
where Pans go Zug just passes, doesn't
take the bait, and is comfortable with
setting up for a future play.
>> Okay,
>> is going does take the bait.
>> Okay, let's see. It's 5 to one if it is
a switcheroo for Jim Davis. It is. And
that will swap the might of both of
those units.
>> Yep. Does have to recycle one to pay for
the deflect, but still entirely worth it
for a blowout victory.
>> Absolutely.
>> We'll hold that battlefield.
>> Set is used.
>> Yep. I was about to say the Fiora is
going to be saved by the set legend
ability.
Back over to Jim Davis holding up to
four.
Bandal tree remains open now with Fiora
having moved away to Fiora. Victorious
in the back line for Peons. Go Zug Zug.
And looking now at the hand of Jim
Davis. I see an Evelyn. I believe I saw
another sneaky deck hand. Uh but I was
about to say I think we're going to see
the traveling merchant get rid of that
cuz that's not what you want to see in
this situation. So you get the conquer
point, but you also get the very
important hand filter. And that leaves
us with the falling star, the Avalon,
and the newly drawn card. So this is
actually a spot where it's a bit of a
tough decision. You might be enticed to
use the falling star now just because
all of the runes are tapped for pianos
zug, but also importantly, your set
legend ability is now turned off because
it was used. Now, the downside though is
that the uh Falling Start by itself
still only cleans up one unit. Both
Fioras are at four and then the Sith 3
is at two and unfortunately it's three
and three, not six any way you want. So,
uh it is the play but it just gets rid
of one of the Fioras.
>> Yeah, Jim continuing to invest the runes
taking out one of the threats.
Ferna can be brought back here to set up
for an offensive push. She is much
better on offense
with that assault.
>> Yeah, and I I like this move back just
because uh without the switcheroo
presence, you want Inferna to be the one
attacking to trigger that assault. Uh we
also just see the development of an
Evelyn instead of hiding it. So if I'm
peeons go Zugzug, what that signals to
me is that this traveling merchant is
undefended because they did not have the
confidence of hiding the Evelyn and then
having some sort of combat trick back to
ensure that it makes it to the next
round. So Pon go Zug is likely looking
at a double conquer this turn pretty
uncontested
and that Jim Davis is just trying to
develop might for a retake on the
following turn. And that would be my
read if I was peeons right now.
>> And it is also worth noting that Jim
Davis going down to just one card in
hand there. So we'll get that Jinx
trigger for the first time on his next
turn. Peons go Zug Zug thinking this one
through. Down five to2
in game number one of round two here in
Hartford.
>> Going to use sabotage. Take a look. And
it is a cleave. and Cleave will be
recycled. And I think that is a massive
sabotage here.
>> Yeah, it's interesting because when your
opponent only has one card in hand, you
might think to yourself, well, is it
really worth it to use this sabotage
now? I might whiff. I'm only getting
very limited information. But in a
situation where your opponent just
backed off and they have these low might
units, you might also correctly identify
perhaps it's something like a cleave. So
it does get rid of it. Uh Jim will still
get the bonus draw. So we'll have a
couple of options next turn. But that
was a pretty big rip from Pon Go Zugzug.
>> Definitely Pian's Go Zug able to double
conquer here up to four points. Also
taking advantage of the Monastery of
Herana trigger
popping that buff on Cyria to get an
extra card.
Now depending on what the hand looks
like for peons, I would not be surprised
if we see the set kingpin finally
developed on this turn. It represents
not only a lot of might but also tank on
top of it.
Uh however, it does look like we're
going to see a pit rookie come down
that's going to buff the Fiora to make
her mighty once again. Playing the unit
also triggers Cyria of Cloudfield.
And so now it just is a question of do
you have combat tricks that you want to
sit on or do you want to also jam this
kingpin so you've got a big tank unit.
That is the question.
>> Yeah, the kingpin would get a nice
little bonus here. It's five might but
gets an additional one might for each
buffed friendly unit at its battlefield.
So would get that additional might on
either of these battlefields for Pons.
And it would be very tough
top decking for Jim Davis here to break
into the battlefield that the Kingpin
landed on.
>> Yeah. One reason why you might consider
not playing it now though is if you
don't have a way to buff it, it is
susceptible to cards like Falling Star.
We've already seen one from Jim Davis.
So, if you don't have a way to save it,
and that's an important part of this set
game plan is you want to save that
kingpin because it protects your other
units with it having tank and then
you're just getting maximum value from
your legend activation. Uh, so here I
like the call of uh whether you have it
or not, just figning combat tricks
because you don't have a way to buff the
kingpin when it comes down.
And now Jim Davis drawing two cards. One
off of that Jinx trigger.
>> Does have some options here.
>> Yeah, a Gust.
>> Do you have the Gust? Gust is all right
on the Cyria because not a lot unless
they have uh some sort of reaction speed
buff that Pons would have available to
stop it and that could get rid of the
Cyria and allow at least a conquer. You
don't want to just throw a unit away,
but getting to at least six on this
turn, I think, is kind of important for
Jim because you want to be in a position
where you can set up that double conquer
for a win. Uh we also could see a
situation where uh if you can play both
of these cards and then also play your
legend, your your chosen champion,
excuse me. Um, Jinx of course has the
additional cost of like discarding the
two cards, but if you don't have the
cards to discard, then you're just kind
of netting value.
>> Absolutely. And she can be accelerated
and has assault, too. So, we do have the
gust bouncing Cyria back to Pon's hand,
opening up the southern battlefield. And
Jim Davis will move there with Evelyn
going up to that important six.
Six to four in favor of Jim Davis.
And here comes the Jinx accelerated like
we were just talking about.
>> So discarded.
>> Th this list has such low energy costs
that all of these recycles kind of don't
matter for Jim Davis. I love maximizing
your resources like this. This does come
down as a form might unit. Has assault
too as well. So it is currently larger
than the Fiora
trade.
>> Oh, it's a six to six because of the
shield, the buff plus the shield
keyword. And this is going to be a
trade.
And we see the set boss legend ability
used to save Fiora. So Jim loses his
chosen champion and Fiora sticks around.
>> Yeah. And that's very unfortunate for
Jim. If only because the Fiora sticks
around if you were cleaning that up and
then opening up a situation where next
turn with another accelerator or
something that you could go for the
double conquer. Um, and we know that
they're in the list, right? We see the
inferna uh that has ambush, we see the
sneaky deck hands earlier, etc. Then
that would have been a fantastic
outcome. But being faced with a
situation where the Fiora sticks around
and the kingpin is still available, you
have to assume that you're back into a
situation where both of these
battlefields will be occupied and thus
making it very difficult for a double
conquer. Jim will get to draw two cards
once again from the legend ability,
but we'll only have that inferna in all
likelihood going into the next round to
start with.
You could tell in Jim's facial
expressions, not the turn he wanted.
We see pit rookie moving into Bandal
tree. Up to five points goes peeons.
And now will reinforce there with the
Cyria.
And another copy of Cyria going to buff
the other one.
when you play another unit. Cyri of
Cloudfield gets buffed
and Fiora moving into the southern
battlefield taking out Evelyn and it's
all tied up. Peons has clawed his way
back into game one
>> and then we're going to see that
Monastery of Herana used. This is uh
peons go zug zug likely digging for
additional combat tricks hoping to maybe
find something like a punch first so
that even if Jim Davis does have uh
fantastic draw of two cards this next
turn you would have additional defensive
measures. Uh you are in a situation
where if you can double hold you win the
game.
The other reason that the draw from the
monastery is incredibly helpful is that
even if you don't double hold, if Jim
only has a single conquer, then you're
still in a position where you could
either hold plus conquer or double
conquer yourself on the following turn.
So maximizing your options when you get
there makes an awful lot of sense. Uh
here we do see a first mate come down.
So, uh, this will buff both of the
Cytheras again as well as put additional
might on the monastery. There is the
option with the first mate coming down
that you could theoretically ready that
Cyria and base and push that up if you
wanted to as well, but uh did pass that.
>> Yeah, it is a great point and that extra
might with the buff is important on
Cyria at that northern battlefield
because that is four and it is not
enough for Inferno to get through. So
Jim picking up the two cards here thanks
to that Jinx ability. Let's see what he
found. We've got stack deck. Go digging
here. Need some help.
All right. Looked like the options were
an Evelyn, a Noxus hopeful.
And I just missed what the third one
was.
And that's just going to be a scoop. Did
not find what they were looking for. Jim
Davis after a blazing fast start does
lose game one. But uh I will admit I
still liked what I saw from this jinx
list.
>> Um there were
a lot of opportunities where I think Jim
Davis could have potentially closed it
out. I do think that that uh sabotage
was critically timed to get rid of the
cleave because it was very clear that
Jim Davis was trying to to set up a a
double conquer.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Great comeback there from Peons
and interestingly enough was able to put
that together without playing his chosen
champion. But here we go. Game two
underway. Hey, Jim Davis starting things
out with the overzealous fan.
>> Yeah, we are diving right into game two
and this is an arena's greatest start.
So, both players already at one point
and that valley of idols on the side of
peons go zug zug.
>> Going to be a quick game here with that
arena's greatest valley of idols of
course giving peons the ability to buff
his units when he plays them there. We
know how critical that is for this set
deck.
Great new battlefield picked up from
Unleashed for Set.
And so I think Jim Davis now is trying
to figure out how the development of
this turn wants to go. You know that the
fan is likely going to go to the valley.
You want to prevent peeons from being
able to conquer that and then play
there. So I would expect the fan to move
into the location to at a minimum force
a situation where you push this back. Uh
that is the play. But then looking at
the rest of the hand, you also want to
be able to play a card and then play
this hopeful to just uh get the maximum
amount of might on the board. But I
don't think that there were many clean
options. Yeah. Everything else looked
like it was combat tricks or hidden
cards. Hiding a card doesn't count as
playing it. It doesn't uh trigger till
you actually play it from being hidden.
So, uh this is just a four energy Noxis
hopeful and it's not exactly what you're
looking for.
>> Jim Davis did go up to two points hiding
there at that northern battlefield with
the overzealous fan.
See what Pons has in response. Cythria
in the backline can quickly become a two
might unit as soon as another unit hits
the board for peons.
Cyria just going to move down to the
arena's greatest
evening the score at two
and it's going to be first mate readying
Cyria. Cyria buffed in the process and
coming back to base.
So,
one of the potential
fun things about having so many hidden
cards here, but specifically also having
access to overzealous fan is Pens Go Zug
Zug is not going to go into Valley of
Idols this turn because not only do you
have the fan trigger, but you have
whatever the hidden card is, but if that
happens to be like an Evelyn, well, then
you can use that to force a combat,
force a trade when it comes back to you.
So the specific pairing of overzealous
fan with the potential of Evelyn gives
Jim Davis a lot of options uh in the
hand. I do also see two switcheroos.
Yeah, definitely has some options here.
Plenty of hidden cards. Knox is hopeful
moving into Arena's greatest. Jim Davis
up to three and four after holding with
the overzealous fan.
Now, the one downside to having two
switcheroos is uh in the current state
of things, you don't want to hide that
where the hopeful is because it is
larger than the other units. We see the
development of a traveling merchant. So,
that must have been just picked up
because if it was there last turn, we
would have seen that plus the Noxis
hopeful. Um, but we're seeing now a
second Knox hopeful. So, that was the
play that Jim would have liked to have
made last turn.
Yeah, able to get that value here.
Playing Knox is hopeful for only two
Legion effect
>> activated there and will hide at that
southern battlefield.
>> So, here's the fun part.
>> It is a switcheroo. We know it because
there was two in hand. There was only
those cards available. But hiding that
there is potentially going to scare
Pon's go zug off from that location with
the two hopefuls plus a hidden card that
you're not expecting to be Switcheroo.
But you also don't have to play the
switcheroo. And at the end of the day,
this is the same as cycling it because
you're going down to one card and that's
going to put it on the board and
activate your legend ability for having
uh just the one card in hand next turn.
So, um it essentially goes the entire
life cycle of uh from hand to
potentially trash just to get you
another card. Uh here we do have Teemo
being played at reaction speed and it
also is going to get the buff from the
valley.
Love to see that. Getting plus three for
the turn and Jim Davis spending that
energy to buff up Teemo. So that's a
five might unit currently. Seven might
at that battlefield. Cyria just two. So
Pon's going to have to put something
together if he wants to contest.
>> Yeah, Cyria just falls.
>> Seven is critical because that means a
punch first only trades. You will not
win that fight. You could still give it
up if you want to clear out all of the
units there on the side of Jim Davis,
but it's not going to feel great to do
so.
Pon's really thinking this one through.
has six runes to play with.
Does he have a way to contest here?
>> So, uh, looking I do not see the punch
first. It looks like we have two
challenges.
So, there could be a situation where
maybe you are playing challenge on your
first mate to try to pick off the
overzealous fan.
Uh that unfortunately means your Cyria
still loses to the Teemo though. Uh the
challenges don't work on either of the
hopefuls on the other side either. Um
there is the call to glory which
represents some additional might. So
that could help you out if you paired
that with a challenge,
but the options are are not looking good
with no punch first here.
Yeah, challenge to take out the fan.
Call to glory on Siththeria would be
five to five. So it' be once again a
trading situation.
>> Yeah, I mean we could see a situation
where it's call. Oh, all right. It's
going to be call on the Cyria. Um, I was
going to say you could see a situation
where it's also call on the first mate
and then challenge from the first mate
onto the Teemo, but then your Sithria
still only would have traded with the
fan at that point. Um, you could have
maybe done call and then double
challenge, but then you're spending a
lot of resources on this one combat.
Looks like he is going to be reaching
for a challenge
>> and it's going to be a challenge on the
fan.
>> So again, just trying to set up for this
trade and clear out this northern
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And I think that what's happening
here is because you have that first mate
in the backline, if you just force this
Cyria to trade with everything, you keep
a challenge in your hand and first mate
can still go to the valley as long as
you clear everything out.
So like I said before, you could have
put call and then double challenge, but
that would have been a massive amount of
resources spent just to win that combat.
Whereas now, if you want, first mate,
could still get in there.
There is some danger in doing so though
because you are out of units on the
board at this point if that is
overtaken. There is the merchant in the
base on the side of Jim Davis but Pian
go Zugzug decides that keeping the point
tempo is more important. So we see first
mate still go and a Cyri of Cloudfield
developed in base.
>> Jim Davis will hold to five. Still has
the merchant in the backline. We'll see
if Jim can threaten the valley
and potentially go up to that sixpoint
total.
This is such an interesting deck from
Jim Davis because it is a Jinx deck that
even though it plays very aggressively,
the core gameplay pattern is built
around holding.
When you think about it, you want to get
on a battlefield and hide as many cards
as possible. And what a rip off the top.
If we get the traveling merchant to
trigger that finds a long sword which
then is played at reaction speed and
that allows the merchant to survive
against that first mate and still take
the valley. That was a great rip off the
top
>> and up to six points. So now Pon's in a
bit of trouble. Only Cyria in that
backline will be forced into an awkward
situation on his next turn. Jim in a
great spot right now.
still has a couple cards to play with.
Has another long sword in hand with four
runes open.
Peons has to break one of these
battlefields or we go to a game three in
round two of the regional qualifier in
Hartford.
>> Yeah, and seeing the second long sword
makes a lot more sense on why the
merchant went in to begin with. So, uh
you did find the one off the top, but it
was already there. Uh game ends does
show the switcheroo
>> that was hidden.
>> Yeah, showed the switcheroo. Not doing
much with the Nox's hopefuls there. But
we are going to game number three
between Peons go Zugzug and Jim Davis.
Set versus Jinx. Been pretty explosive
so far. One thing for sure is with this
Jinx deck, Jim gets going real fast.
Yeah, the Jinx deck is interesting to me
because it plays very similar to the
hide versions of Teemo. Uh Teemo
typically has a similar play pattern.
You want to get on site, you want to
hide as many cards as possible. Uh a lot
of times you're using strategist and not
turn to then turn those into holds. Here
you are less worried about the synergies
of the hidden cards specifically, but
more so just with emptying your hand.
So, the deck list itself, uh, very few
cards that even cost three energy. The
vast majority cost two or one, so that
you can empty your hand as vast as
possible, get the additional draws from
your legend ability. But it's also just
kind of maximizing what you can do each
turn. If you're somebody at home and
you're watching this game and you just
like doing game actions, you kind of
don't care what they do, you just like
putting cards on the table, this might
be the list for you cuz you get to play
a lot of stuff. That is absolutely
right. Options of plenty as we see the
sabotage come down for peons and we have
the gust and the stacked deck. That gust
will be recycled
as we note there are some hidden options
there with the Evelyn and Teemo.
Yeah, this might be the most valuable
sabotage has ever been because you want
to know exactly what your opponent is
hiding and then what you need to play
around
and so here we
>> irresistible faithful so good with the
forbidding waste dragging the fan in.
>> All right, so I was wondering if Jim was
going to do this. Uh the interesting
interaction here is that with
irresistible fay folk when it pulls the
unit in, it makes that unit become the
defender. And so because it's the
defender, there's then a trigger window
for the overzealous fan. Uh Jim Davis
knows that he's going to lose the unit
anyway. So it decides to take the
trigger, sacrifice it to move the fault
back to base just to prevent the points
being gained from peons. You're going to
lose the unit anyway. So there's no
point in giving away a free point to
peeons. Go Zug Zug. Uh that's a heads up
play from Jim Davis to maximize the
value you are getting from the unit
before it's too late.
>> Yeah, trying to minimize the point tempo
for Peons. We see that pit rookie come
out. Now the faithful will get just a
bit tougher up to two might with the
buff. And now Jim will have to
reestablish a board.
Steering down a couple threats here. And
that fa folk with the forbidding waste
in play just so valuable.
>> Yeah, we do know that Jim Davis has
tools to deal with a board like this uh
in the deck. We've seen cards like
Falling Star already. The downside
though is now that that Fay folk has a
buff on it. It can be saved from the set
legend ability. So instead, Jim Davis
says, I'm just gonna play two Evelyn
straight to the board. uh just paying
two for two might a piece might lose one
to the fa folk but that would leave me
with one left over and maybe I can do
something at that stage
>> now peons go zug zug has the
battlefields open
fay folk moving into the forbidding
waste evelyn dragged in what's the
response here we've got a gust to bounce
back that fa folk
>> so a second gust found after the one was
sabotaged and
huge for Jim because that also means
he's going to get a conquer point now
cuz the Evelyn was dragged there
and if the pit rookie doesn't come in
and then clean that Evelyn up would also
get a hold point but pit rookie could
still attack in now uh it would be
winning the combat because of the tax on
forbidding waste giving that Evelyn
minus two for defending alone.
Yeah, I think you've got to clean that
up. Certainly don't want to give Jim an
extra point there
as the gust
coming in clutch. Pons already recycling
one earlier with sabotage, but Jim Davis
finding yet another and getting that
opening point.
>> Yeah, I think there I think there was a
pause there before the point was scored
because perhaps Pons was considering
doing something at reaction speed just
to deny even the conquer point.
um instead opted to just let that
resolve and go in with the pit rookie.
And as we try to take a look a little
bit at the hand of peons there, I do see
some fantastic options.
Uh and I was going to say we have the
fay folk that we know is there from the
gust
>> and the first mate.
>> I was going to say and the first mate.
So, the first mate here allows you to
ready the pit rookie and then move it
back to base so that it's not left on
the forbidding waste. Uh, which is
problematic. You don't want to be there
when your opponent has a unit in their
base because they could be able to just
like walk in.
>> And it looks like
>> the whole
might just do it here.
>> Uh, no. Well, it looks like what has
accidentally happened is a roll back to
when they were sideboarding cuz he is
talking about uh how loud the static was
and if we noticed in game three they did
not have the headsets on likely was
granted an exception due to the uh
volume. So perhaps whatever tech issue
was plaguing the headsets is also now
plaguing our feed. But
does look like we had a bit of a game
roll back.
All right. So, now
just bear with us a little bit here.
We'll try to get some information
on our feed.
Try to get back to the action. Here it
is. We're back to where we were. Back
over to Jim Davis's turn. He's got the
Evelyn in the back line.
Little bit of a different game here for
Jim. He hasn't had to expend those
runes, but the board advantage
big favor for Peons right now.
>> Yeah, and I think you've really hit the
nail on the head here. This is the most
runes we've seen Jim Davis have in this
entire series,
which is also why he only has one point,
right? We know that he's not playing the
cards that he normally would be playing
uh and expending those runes to get the
points. So, uh, does go up to two with
his conqueror, but uh, it's interesting
the correlation that we see between the
number of runes on Jim Davis's side of
the board and the points that he's
gained.
So, Evelyn conquering at Grove of the
Godwillow, Jim Davis going up to two.
Seeing the cleave come out.
Yeah, the cleave, even though it wasn't
needed for the combat, I think is to set
up this Legion play for the Knox
hopeful, as well as get Jim Davis's hand
that much lower to trigger the Jinx
Legend ability. Also, if you know that
you're going to be playing your uh Jinx
chosen champion and accelerate it, and
that's what happened over there to the
forbidding waste, uh then you want to
just play that cleave to make the
hopeful hit the board before you're
forced to discard it. Uh so again, very
heads up sequencing here from Jim Davis
because uh this has allowed the maximum
use of resources on the turn even if
that cleave was not used to win a
combat.
>> And now we do have that one card hidden
there with Evelyn.
>> So Peons has to work through
what that could possibly be.
>> Down three to one.
First mate going to move down into the
forbidden waste. Minus two might for
Jinx while defending will be killed in
combat and Pon scoring up to two.
But how does he piece through the puzzle
of that northern battlefield? Faith
Fulen pit rookie
in base.
Yeah, it does look like there are some
options in the hand of Pian's Go Zugzug
if they want to contest this grove. Uh
it does instead look like we're going to
develop set Kingpin as Jim Davis takes a
look. Again, this is a five might unit
with tank and it gets an additional
might for each friendly buffed unit at
that battlefield. no buffed units to
pair with it at the moment, but
potentially options because I do see a
showstopper in the hand.
The question is, of course, what is the
hidden card if you're peons? Because uh
something like a switcheroo could be
problematic though with the buff being
added from the showstopper, you could
use your uh the boss legend ability to
save this kingpin.
So set moving in with the showstopper.
It is a Teemo,
but it's not enough might and it falls.
The Northern Battlefield loss for Jim
Davis. Set the first time we've seen the
chosen champion come out in this match.
And now the Faithfolk will drag in the
Noxis Hopeful. But Tank is going to shut
down the Hopeful, taking out the
Faithfolk. And Jim Davis's board has
been obliterated.
Yeah, now the Jinx Legend ability is
triggering. So Jim is going to get two
cards per turn likely for the rest of
this game. But the downside is we have
the Kingpin fa folk combo online on the
side of peons. So uh kingpin
specifically with tank of course winning
those combats protecting the fay folk
but also importantly has the buff so it
can be saved from the boss. uh Jim
Davis, unless it's come in from the
sideboard, uh doesn't have many good
ways to deal with that set. We've seen
cards like Gust, uh Falling Star, etc.
But Falling Star, the boss legend
ability can save it from Gust, not going
to get the job done. Uh there might be
something like Starcross or Rebukes in
the sideboard of Jim Davis. Uh that
could temporarily get rid of it, but of
course, it's just going to hit the table
again. So, uh, Jim Davis a bit behind on
point tempo compared to games one and
two here. Uh, and we do see a falling
star, but instead of trying to get rid
of the kingpin, wisely targets units
that don't have buffs to kind of slow
peons down.
>> That does clear out that southern
battlefield. First mate and the faithful
killed. hopeful developed in the
backline for Jim Davis as peons holding
up to four with set
>> and we'll get that additional card
holding at Grove of the Godwillow.
>> So,
interestingly enough, the judge is
reminding peons that we have to have
that plus one might there because uh set
kingpin counts. There's the challenge
taking out the hopeful. And you could
see the look on Jim's face.
>> He's not liking what he's seeing.
Charmer.
>> No, not at all. You really needed that
hopeful to live for a turn so that you
could pair it with whatever you're
drawing and try to uh get some sort of
action going. But right now, unless you
are top decking into cards like sneaky
deck hand, you don't have a way to
continue to score points.
Uh peons here also maintaining this hold
specifically on Grove of the God Willow
which is uh problematic for Jim Davis
because even though he's getting the
extra card from his Jinx Legend ability,
Pons is now keeping pace drawing two
cards a turn. So you can't even try to
attrition
battle your way back into this. You're
just going to have to match it might
for. And as I said before, this is a
list that in many ways, even though it's
got aggressive starts, is built for
holding. And so the retakes are that
much more difficult.
>> Overzealous fan. The only development
for Jim Davis as Pons holds to seven.
Jim has his work cut out for him here on
this next turn. Let's see how Peons can
further develop.
Has the arena bar.
Yeah, this arena bar at this stage in
the game might just be the nail in the
coffin because Jim Davis needed a window
to get rid of some of these units, but
being able to put buffs on essentially
everything and kind of pick and choose
what you want to use your legend ability
on makes it that much more difficult for
Jim Davis to get back into it. Uh the
the beauty of Jim Davis's list is that
it's so fast and it's so economical with
the way it uses its resources. shows his
hand, extends it. Oh, that's brutal.
>> The downside is is when it gets to the
late game, if they've got big stuff, you
don't have a lot of ways to deal with
it. And it's even worse when your hand
is double seals. So,
>> wow.
>> Uh big win for Pon's go zug there. Uh
and that was I think a lot of fun to
watch.
>> How thematic was it? We go to game three
and we finally see the chosen champion.
We see the kingpin come out and he just
slammed the door shut.
>> Yeah, he did exactly what he was
supposed to do. He just sits on a
battlefield. Makes it impossible for
your opponent to go into it. We did see
the combo with the fa folk as well. Uh
Jim did have an answer at least for the
fa folk portion of that. But ultimately
no good way to get rid of that big set
kingpin just camping on a grove of the
god Willow. Sometimes that tank
keyword's just so sneaky. You know, we
even saw Jim like, "Okay, I'm going to
take out that Faithful." Wait, wait one
second. That tank keyword is so crucial
in a deck like this. And I think one of
the big reasons that it's in that chosen
champ slot, not only does it get that
additional might with those buff units,
but that tank keyword, being able to
protect things like your Fioras and like
your irresistible faith folks, those
other important pieces is just very good
each and every game.
>> Yeah. And even though Pons got the
victory, and we're going to get that
flowers over to them with an interview
in just a moment, I want to take a
moment to give Jim Davis his flowers
because that was a very innovative take
on Jinx. I loved the use of the hidden
cards as an additional way to empty your
hand. I think a lot of times when folks
are looking at building Jinx, they're
focused on any of the cards that say
discard on them as a way to get cards
out. But it turns out just playing a
bunch of stuff for power and having a
low curve is another great way to empty
your hand. So even though uh ultimately
did lose the series, I was very
impressed with what I saw in that jinx
list.
>> Yeah, it was very innovative. When the
Bandal tree came out in that opening
game, I was like, wait a second here.
That is not what I was expecting. But
hey, I love that kind of that kind of
cook and he was so close to a 20 start.
Great match there, but unfortunately
fell a little bit short.
>> All right. Well, uh, the winner, Peon's
Go Zug Zug, uh, is standing by for an
interview, so we're going to go hear
from them now.
>> Excellent cast there on the desk. And I
am joined by the wonderful peons go Zug
Zug taking down Jim Davis on Jinx who's
been playing since set one. But speaking
of set one, set the boss. How does it
feel now being 2 and 0 going into this
regional qualifier here?
>> Uh feels really good. Uh it's uh uh
can't wait to see what else I can bring.
>> No, me too. I mean I I think set is such
an exciting day and so we have to kind
of talk about it, right? We know Colin
Kaiser is in the room playing Set. So,
are you trying to kind of combat against
him for a best of maybe or a top cut
appearance?
>> Uh, yeah, definitely. Uh, if my first
goal is to get to day two and then if I
can make there, then maybe we can see
about uh trying to uh get that best of.
>> But, but it is really cool to see
because we know that set can be very
good. I actually also play set. I play a
brawler version, but not as good as the
kingpin as I'm every time I see the deck
on stream and it does well. So, um,
can't really complain there. But, you
know, just like the FA folks and, you
know, with the kingpin, with the tank
ability, it it just it flows so well.
But I kind of wanted to pick your brain
because I know a lot of people,
including Colin, play the deck where
there's just not a lot of main board
draw effects and you have to basically
rely on a lot of your battlefields to do
so. But now with the introduction to
Valley of Idols and what we kind of saw
in game two, it kind of almost went
against you when the Teemo got played
from the hidden card. Game two was a
little rough.
But you know, do you think that's kind
of like the recipe for success because
set is so good at like making your
opponent use their own cards to remove
your units, but as long as they're
buffed, you get to get to keep them
around.
>> Yeah, I think that's what I like about
set is that you can uh kind of uh trade
uh and as long as you have the buff, you
can get it back and then uh go ahead and
rebuff and then retake back and
everything. So, you never feel like
you're in a terrible situation unless
like game two where I had like
absolutely no draw.
>> No. And that's and it's great to still
see, you know, like the deck has its
flaws. You can still, you know, lose to
these sort of like hyperaggressive
decks, but at the end of the day, you
know, sometimes if your opponent lets
you run wild with like the Fioras, you
really can just take advantage of any
sort of situation. So, I'm just going to
ask you kind of on a vibe check, how are
you feeling so far? you know, do you is
there a matchup that you're maybe not
looking to run into this weekend in your
own testing? I know you you haven't
really we talked a little bit off air,
you haven't really played card games for
about 20 years now, and now Riftbound is
the one you've gotten into, but coming
into your prep for the event, what are
you looking to avoid?
>> Uh, I think uh Azir is just a tough
matchup. I think uh he has so many ways
to uh exchange the might over to a
different sand soldier and it's just a
tough matchup, I feel.
>> No, absolutely. And the equipment stick
around. Meanwhile, the tokens keep
coming, of course. But Pons, excellent
job there in round two. I know you have
more rounds to get through, so I'm going
to let you take a break since you had a
pretty dominating performance there, at
least fairly quickly. So, we're going to
go ahead and send it back.
>> Thank you.
>> Absolutely loved that interview. There's
two things that really stood out to me
there. Barrett mentioned that it had
been 20 years since he's played card
games, but guess what? Riftbound is the
one that drew him back in. So, that was
super cool to hear. And also, he's going
for that best of. He He believes he
believes that look, we got to get the
game today, too, but he's coming for
Colin. Going to be interesting to see
the run between these two.
>> Yeah, I'm looking forward to seeing what
the rest of the event looks like for
PN's Go Zug because it would be nice to
have uh some rivalries on these legends.
I think I know that there are definitely
some legends that we associate with
certain players right now like Colin or
like Prismat with Annie, but it would be
kind of nice to have these stories
within a story like we sometimes have
with Dewali and Alen for example
competing both on Diana. So I'm really
looking forward to seeing a run
potentially from Peon's Go Zug.
>> Yeah, I think it's going to be a lot of
fun to watch. We'll have to keep track
of peons throughout the rest of the day.
But I think for now, we're actually
going to send it over to Kangas. He's
going to take us through a little bit of
analysis on this match.
>> I don't hear anything.
Oh, we're back.
>> Are we back?
I saw Kangas.
>> Yep, we had Kangas there for a second.
Not sure. The voices in my head have
have disappeared currently. So, uh, just
kind of on standby here. But
what is the big thing for you? We we
heard that interview. He was concerned
about Azir.
>> Didn't want to face Azir. Is there
anything else that you believe could
stand in the way of set making another
deep run to a top cut?
>> Yeah, I think that's a fair question.
When I think about these set lists, they
are great at surviving combat outright,
but they can sometimes struggle with
effects that are returning to hand. So,
uh, something like the Ireelists that
are combining Starcross with Scuttle
Crab, for example, could be problematic
because they have very effective ways of
getting those units back to hand and
then that kind of invalidates the set
legend ability. Whereas if set it gets
good matchups, they want to go into
either these kind of uh fury based decks
where it's direct damage based removal
or even some of the order lists where if
they're trying to hit with call the week
but you have the buff, you can save the
unit that way as well. So uh I think for
me it's really the decks that can
utilize starcross the most effectively
that could also give set some problems.
Yeah, I think that's an excellent point
and it will be interesting to see how
well represented things are like Diana.
We know that Diana is kind of the big
chaos deck of the format right now. It's
been between Master Yi and Diana is
generally the two most represented decks
in the format. So, if you can dodge
those Diana, right, dodge some of that
other chaos stuff. Of course, we saw the
star cross with Kha'Zix as well, right?
the star cross with Kha'Zix and the fizz
loop that you can get going. So
definitely going to need to try and
dodge some of those matchups. But just
love the buff mechanic and the ability
that set the boss that he gives
to just get extra value out of all of
your units because your opponent just
has to expend so many of their
resources, cards in hand, some of their
units on board, and you're just able to
quickly save it by spending that buff
and for one power. And it feels like
that cost is very much
covered with how many resources your
opponent has to spend.
>> Yeah, it can very often be covered. One
of the things you do have to watch out
for though is uh if you overspend on
your power, right? I know uh many times
we've heard Colin, for example, talk
about how that's the hardest part of
playing set sometimes because you have a
lot of power intensive plays. Cards like
challenge char cards like uh punch
first, they're eating your power. And
then if your legend is also eating
power, if you're using it to save every
last unit, well then sometimes you just
run out of the ability to play anything
relevant. So uh it is a balance, but you
you are correct. A lot of times it is
worth it when you are looking at the
investment of something like a kingpin
for example or even the faolk just
because it's such a powerful card. Yes,
paying a power and getting rid of the
buff is just as good as if you drew
another card and then played it, right?
So, uh that's I think the real key is
measuring is the recycle and the buff
worth the same as if I had drawn the
card and played it right now.
>> So, definitely something you have to
time and use it conservatively at those
proper times, but if you do it, it
certainly pays off. I think we are going
to send it over to Kangas to bring up
some analysis on this previous match.
Thank you very much. Uh, sorry to keep
you waiting. We were just building the
anticipation of this one cuz I want to
break down one of my favorite decks and
that is Jinx and a very unique build of
it, but then also highlight how Pon go
Zugzug was able to play through it. Now,
what I want to highlight here
specifically, I haven't seen a lot of
Jinx decks go for this strategy, but we
are going for a heavy hidden Jinx. The
idea of Jinx in general is you want to
keep your hand size low because then you
can actually utilize your legend ability
up here that says uh when you start your
turn with one or fewer cards, you can
draw an extra card. So, let's uh start
the clip from here because really
there's one option when you're against a
hidden deck and Pon goes Zugzug is just
going to take that option, keep punching
them. you got to figure out what those
hidden cards are eventually and uh
sometimes they're not ones that you're
happy with. So, uh this suddenly uh
increases the might and this is the
issue of punching into hiddens, but
again, you got to figure out what they
are. When you're playing an orange
yellow deck, you don't really have the
luxury of things like defy, things like
not so fast that can help you get
through hidden cards and even a hidden
unit as uh Jim is playing a lot of in
this list is going to be able to stick
there anyway. So, uh, I like this
because again, it's keeping your hand
size low, but the strength of it is you
can hold better with hidden, but you're
not able to punch as hard. And we're
gonna see that actually come back to
bite gym later on here. Um, as I believe
we can actually jump over to the next
clip here because I don't think we see
this hidden card flipped yet. Yep. So,
here I want to highlight the next one.
The merchant goes back. We still have
this hidden. Eventually, the Fiora gets
buffed. And what do you think Pon goes
Zugzug's going to do? If you said punch,
you're right. Let's play it from here
because as we start the clip, the Fior
is going to gank over. You got to keep
punching into the hidden cards. And this
one, one of my favorites. Sometimes it's
just a one-up, sometimes you got a lot
of them. This is going to be the
switcheroo.
Ooh, that's not good for the Fiora
player. You have to pay the deflect
cost, but still you're able to clear
that unit. Now, Pon go Zugzug in game
one. Just keeps punching, is able to
take it. Let's jump ahead to the next
clip here, cuz that should start in game
two. And again, Jim Davis is able to get
onto two points with two hiddens. This
is kind of the dream of a hidden base
deck. But as we start the clip from
here, we can see that as long as you
just keep punching, you can clear them
out. This one goes better for the Jinx
pilot. Jim is able to actually take game
number two. I love the Teemo in the Jinx
list. I was playing this back in Origins
in Jinx because again, when you hide
cards, you just get essentially a free
placement. Get your hand size low. You
maximize your legend ability. Uh, and it
makes it really tough cuz as we actually
fast forward here, uh, Pan Go Zugzug is
feeling the pressure of playing against
a hidden deck, especially when you go in
second, you want to spend a lot of
resources. We're actually going to pay
the full cost for a call to glory, I
believe, in this play just to clear out
the battlefield and then go in to score
a point. But we see Jim Davis is still
able to hold on from that position and
close out. So, it's a tough spot for
Pyongo Zug to be in, but he still the
one strategy set has is punch, punch,
punch through the hiddens. Let's jump to
the next clip here because this should
go into game number three. And this one,
Jim Davis kind of starts off in an okay
spot, but we can see Pon goes Zugs
already doing the same strategy,
punching in. Let's see what this hidden
card is. So far, we've had two Teeos.
We've had a switcheroo and it's another
Teemo. Uh Jim Davis is on a very heavy
unit list. We saw Evelyn's as well. We
didn't actually get any of those hidden
that then uh revealed themselves, but
the Teemo's not enough to hold that
point. If you just keep punching,
eventually you'll punch through. And I
just want to highlight the weakness of
this version of Jinx. If we jump to the
next uh still here, this is essentially
the point that you don't want to be at
as Jinx. If you see this, you know,
let's uh let's get a nice little draw in
here. You might notice something. No
units on the board of Jim Davis. And
when you're playing the hidden Jinx,
you're not playing a lot of accelerate
units. You're not playing a lot of ways
to get onto the field. already used our
uh chosen champion Jinx. So, you're not
really going to be able to win from this
position. So, Pango Zug just punched his
way to victory and punched through all
the hidden cards of Jim Davis. So, fun
to see this version of Jinx. Was not
able to get the win, but I'm still happy
to have Jinx's highlighted on stream.
Congrats out to Pano Zugzug for getting
the victory regardless. That's all I got
here. We're going to throw to a short
break before we're back with our round
three future match.
All right, we've got another round of
hot takes. At this point, I am sweating.
We have heard the hot takes at the end
of the weekend.
>> Okay,
>> who is going to be claiming the trophy
and becoming a regional qualifier
champion?
>> Oo, if Allan's here, I would love to see
Allan take another uh regional.
>> Definitely not me, unfortunately. Um,
>> hopefully me.
>> I mean, that's I'm here for it.
>> I don't know. I mean, I've got a friend
in the tournament, so I feel like I have
to root for them. I feel bad if my uh my
friend didn't win. And a legend, it'd be
cool to see Teemo sneak it.
>> Squirtle.
>> Squirtle. Yeah.
>> Is he?
>> I don't know. I don't think he's coming
this week.
>> Okay. Prismaticism.
>> I hope somebody like uh that hasn't won
yet with a champ that hasn't won yet.
I'm hoping that something comes out of
the woodwork a little bit.
>> Honestly, I think it'll be someone new.
Uh we brought a lot of really good
players from uh the Mid-Atlantic region,
from Southern Virginia, um central
Virginia. I think there's a lot of
players who have not played in a
regional yet that are going to show up
big. Uh as much as I'd like to say, uh
me and Ivvern, uh sadly, I'm not sure
that's the reality for this weekend. Um
I think my buddies got a good chance. Uh
and uh yeah, I I'd say look out for the
Master Y Frogwatch community. We're
we're coming out with a bunch of Y decks
this weekend and uh looking strong. All
right. So, I'm going to walk it back a
sec because I did say I think Pris is
going to win it. And I I think he's in
the running. But I think that uh man, if
it's not Pris, I'm going to go with my
boy Anton on Volibear. Just, you know,
redemption arc sweeping the top eight.
It's going to be like Diana's and Anton
in the top eight. He's going to take it
down.
>> There you go. We're rocking and rolling.
That is this set of hot takes. We'll
send it back to you.
>> Hello everybody. Kang is here with
Villionaire, everyone's favorite best of
volley player. You've won so many times
on the volley bear best of, but you're
still eluding that top eight. So, I got
to ask here, is this the dime? Is it is
Hartford the tournament for you? Uh,
it's the last chance. So, I really hope
it's a tournament for me. Uh I was super
devastated in uh Utre going 11 and one
and then getting the being the only X1
to to not be able to draw in and I got
the pair down into a bad matchup and uh
ended up losing and coming in 14th. I
was so close. Uh I would love to do it.
This is the last chance where I can win
a best of volley. So this is probably
the last chance you'll see me playing
volley unless something changes. So I do
think I'm positioned well. I looked at
the pre-regional like stats and stuff
for what is in the event. Civer is down,
which is good for me. And Yi and and
Diana are both up, which are great
matchups for Voloy. So theoretically, I
could have a very strong bracket all the
way as long as I keep winning and make
top eight.
>> You said Yei and Diana are both good
matchups.
>> I feel like a lot of people are afraid
of the Diana. So why do you think that's
a good matchup for Volibear in
particular?
>> I think Diana's actually really weak
into red decks, especially falling star
decks. And um there's just not a lot of
red at the top of the format right now
ever since, you know, the fall of
Draven. So, uh, but Volo is still really
well positioned. Uh, Falling Star just
wrecks that deck. And they also just
like don't really they have a ways to
deal with like your Rengar and your
Forrunner in the mid game very well. Um,
I mean, they do have shrinks and stuff
like that, but it's just uh you run them
out of creatures very quickly. You have
a lot of efficient removal and your guys
are just way too big.
>> Okay. Yeah. I love hearing people that
know their decks so well talk about
these, especially the top matchups
because a lot of people are still afraid
of Diana. I'm going to put you on the
spot, billionaire, because I'm going to
give you credit for having dragons in
your list. The gem dragon. One of my
favorite cards.
>> Love Jimmy D.
>> Oh, is that the the nickname Jimmy Dick
Jimmy D?
>> Jimmy D. You got the Jimmy D's in the
deck. I'm going to take some points off
>> for the Aurora. I'm an Aurora hater. I
still I still don't like that card. But
I love the dragons in the deck. I'm
playing dragon volley bear myself. Um,
so talk to me about why you made certain
choices in your deck because it was a
very unique one. A lot of people think
Aurora, they think, "Oh, just the elder
dragon, just the big things,
>> right? Just big dudes.
>> Yeah, you had a lot of little guy. Well,
medium guys in there, right?
>> Decent amount of medium guys. Yeah. So,
I play the three Rengars and the three
Forerunners, which gives you a lot of
play in the middle game. Um, Rengar is
just the craziest thing you can do on
turn two going seconds. Uh, especially
when he costs no power. That's the
biggest thing is like you could play
both of these units and Volo refunds you
the power that you spend. So, it lets
you just get deeper into the ruins and
uh play bigger and bigger guys every
turn.
going second for instance, you can
literally go like Rengar on two, kill
their guy. Uh the next turn you play
Forerunner for no power and then the
next turn you could just play your
Aurora like and you could just curve
like that without going down in power at
all which is really strong. And even
when you play your Aurora you get to
refund one as well cuz you play a guy
off of the Aurora.
>> Exactly. Right. It's it's less of like
the crazy high-end Aurora plays cuz you
might hit a Ferris 4Runner off of it.
Not the Elder Dragon, but you're playing
the game earlier than a lot of Aurora
decks cuz most Aurora decks don't even
like play the first couple. You don't
get to play till like nine runes. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, um, how confident were you in
that list being able to get you there?
Cuz you were you were that close and
like have you been tweaking it at all?
Or do you think that like nope, you you
were like right on the money?
>> I think I was mostly on the money with
the main deck. I think the side deck
I've been tweaking a little bit. I I'm
trying a different side deck today. Uh,
it's been going okay. We'll see if I
switch it up a little bit for tomorrow,
but mostly the main deck feels really
locked. It's just kind of very meta
dependent. Like I did see a lot less
civers. So I thought maybe I would play
less sabotage in the main cuz I was on
three. Like I've been on three for the
longest, but um maybe I could like go
down to two and play another interaction
piece for like more aggressive decks
because I'm seeing a lot less civer. But
other than that, I think the list is
pretty much uh almost perfect.
>> Okay. Uh what's what are you worried
about playing against? What what's the
deck you don't want to match up against?
>> Uh Civer. I don't want to I don't want
to match up against Civer. I don't want
to play against Last Rights. that that's
miserable. And the the yellow decks are
also good. Like you guys saw me lose to
Azir last week or no, sorry, to uh
Rexai, but also I did lose to Azir and
that was the the one loss that I had in
the in Swiss until that final round. So,
>> okay. Well, a lot of people are going to
be cheering you on. A lot of Volbear
enthusiasts. Do you have a message for
any of your fans out there?
>> Uh yeah, Volibbear is really good and
you don't need Aurora to win. So, stop
telling me that uh that I'm just an
Aurora player because this deck plays
without it just fine.
>> All right. Thank you so much for the
interview.
>> Hey everyone, my name is Brenton and I'm
here to show you a deck that's been
putting up consistent results from all
the way back in Origins. I have the
pleasure of showcasing set from Colin
from Challenger TCG. And this deck list
has some spice in it, that's for sure.
It's actually built around set kingpin,
which is a bit different than most set
decks. And this deck is built around the
fact of sitting on a battlefield, making
it very difficult for your opponent to
break it, and having set protect your
other units, and then using your legend
to pull back Set when he ultimately does
get killed through a combat. There's
some very key cards in this deck list
that are very important to its strategy.
And the first one is Call to Glory. Call
to Glory is a staple in every set deck.
And this kind of allows you to just
fully tap out, get some tempo, develop
some of your board presence, but also
have a three might swing or two might
swing if you do have to spend a buff to
kind of throw off your opponent's math.
Additionally, other cards that help you
to do that are cards like punch first.
Punch first is a staple in most body
decks because of the fact it's pretty
undercosted, right? It's only one and
two power to play. And if you can save a
unit with this, it's technically only
one in a power because your set actually
doesn't have to get used to save that
specific unit. And with cards like
irresistible faolk, who with unleashed
gives set another method of control is
you can have a really really big
battlefield and move that fa folk in,
bring one of your opponent's key units
to that battlefield and then your set
kingpin because of the tank keyword
allows you to protect that fa folk and
keep it updated. This is a deck that has
a lot of nuance, has been changed a lot
since Origins, and I know we are very
excited to see how it does here at the
Hartford Regional, but that's all I have
for you today. Thank you, and I'll see
you.
>> That guy knows what he's talking about.
>> Who was that?
>> I don't know. He's handsome, though.
>> Nah, you're you look better.
>> Oh, thanks. I appreciate you.
>> How's it going, Is that our intro? Is
that our official intro? Is that where
we're starting this one off? Let's go.
>> That's how we're starting it off. We got
Kangas and Grenon here. Okay. So, when
people were out there, you're a popular
guy, Grenon. I got to give you some
flowers cuz when we were walking through
the the crowd amongst the uh the people,
you know, players were stopping left and
right to shake your hand, ask you
questions. Are are you're a bit of a big
deal, aren't you? Uh I wouldn't say a
big deal necessarily, but I'm usually in
different attire. I'm usually, you know,
wearing judge clothing and running up
and down and, you know, making sure
people have a good time, which is
naturally then people will gravitate
towards that because, okay, you know,
events go well, people are happy,
everyone goes home.
>> I thought players were supposed to not
get along with the judges. Wow.
>> Is turning a new leaf.
>> Yeah. Breaking through barriers. Let's
go, Greg. Well, happy to be on the cast
with you. It's going to be a lot of fun.
Um, your first time, you know, casting
for one of these uh regional qualifiers,
correct?
>> Yeah, I'm super excited. First time
behind the desk. I got to watch you guys
kind of have some fun uh in the previous
RQs and you know for the last one of
Unleashed, I couldn't have picked a
better one to uh to have an opportunity
to cast on.
>> Now you get to have fun. There we go.
Yeah, you get to see what it's like on
this side with the bright lights on us.
Exactly. Well, we're going into round
three here. Uh it's going to be a very
fun time. And this is my first time on
our original qualifier where chat
actually gets to vote on the the
matchups that we see. So, I'm very
excited for that. And I made the mistake
cuz we were backstage uh helping like
kind of say, "Oh, these are cool match
ups to look for rounds one and two." And
then I was like, "Wait a minute. I was
given all the decks that I wanted to
cast." Uh, and now I'm on desk and these
are the matchups. I am very excited for
all of these still though. So, I think
we got some great options ahead of us
regardless. Yeah, we have obviously uh
Diden rightight on LeBlanc. Very well
known for the deck kind of popularized a
little bit. I'm a huge Poppy fan and I
think that's a very interesting matchup
to see. But on the other side, Vi, one
of another unleashed legends where, you
know, very unique play style with
dealing excess damage and trying to go
over the top of things. And then
obviously Master Yi is, you know, the
fan favorite of this tournament. So, two
very good matches and the votes are
exactly echoing that, right? It's a very
close vote between these two matches.
>> Okay. So, I just want to if it skews
anybody's opinion, I'm expecting the
Poppy match to be an Aurora deck,
>> but Lump plays good into Aurora.
>> Okay. Okay. But I'm just saying I think
people should be educated. they should
know before voting. And now it's getting
more percentages. So, it seems like
people are really into it.
>> Yeah, I guess they want to see the Poppy
Aurora. It is a unique Aurora, right?
It's not like the Chaos uh body aurora
that we usually see.
>> Yeah, I mean, you're still going to be
expecting things like Elder Dragon in
there, but then you know, Rift Herald,
that's a fun one to to come out. And uh
you know, your Poppy Chosen champion as
well. Uh five energy comes in ready once
your opponent's ahead, which you kind of
expect to happen when Aurora, but okay,
it looks like things are equalizing.
Maybe my message got through.
>> Yeah,
>> maybe it caught up. Yeah,
>> I'm just saying everybody I Vi would be
kind of cool. I'm not biased.
>> I'm not like Vi, don't get me wrong.
Yeah,
>> I'm a simple guy. If it has order in it,
I want to watch it.
>> Okay, so order is your favorite domain
then?
>> And there it is. We're going to see a
double order game,
>> which is super fun.
>> Double order game. Uh Leblanc is one of
the most exciting decks uh that that
I've kind of gotten to see in Unleashed
release. I think it's one of the most
competitive for sure out of that and
Diana are kind of like the top two right
now. But I I was surprised along with
many that Leblanc wasn't getting as many
top eights. Hasn't really been pushing
for uh you know a championship or
anything like that. So I think that
Leblanc still has a lot to prove right
now when you look at the landscape of
the meta.
>> Yeah. And there's going to be a it's
it's a big bad, right? But they're going
to be going up against the Poppy. And
let's take a look at what this Poppy
deck list actually looks like. Right. We
were kind of speculating a little bit of
what it's going to be. And obviously, as
we see, it's a Poppy deck that is
running Aurora, but notably one of
Vanguard Armory in the deck. So, you do
have that kind of early game pressure.
And when you don't have an opportunity
to really like ping units through your
elder dragon, this kind of acts as a
heat-seeking missile, right? When you
have an Elder Dragon in play, you make
some recruits and you just send them in
to as removal on the battlefield. And
like you mentioned, right, the Rift
Heralds, the Harness Dragons are there
as well. And one main deck ruination,
which I find phenomenal. Yeah, I do like
that a lot. So, there's going to be a
lot of opportunity to just wipe the
board, whether it's Elder Dragon,
whether it's Ruination, Elder Dragon
Plus, all these units you're playing.
It's just interesting to see something
like Vanguard's Armory in a uh Aurora
deck simply because when you play it,
you typically want to be on that 9
energy ramp, right? And this will put
you back to an eight energy on your next
turn if you don't have a gold gear. do
see things um you know they can generate
gold gears. So maybe they are able to
still get there regardless or if you're
on you know if you're going first you're
going to be on that uh you know that
nine anyway cuz you'd be at eight on the
turn you play the vanguard's armory but
it's still a cool secondary option. It's
just surprising to see. Yeah, blood
money is kind of a card here that's
going to allow you to uh it's the order
version of gust so to speak, right? So
you'll kind of just hold up two runes
and then when your opponent moves into
the battlefield, you'll play it and
assuming they don't pump it over too
might, you do get a gold token. So it
allows you to kind of play out that
vanguard armory or get a bit more
aggressive with an early sabotage to see
if you can clearly play your Aurora on
the next turn. So it allows you to kind
of play a bit safer. But the name of the
game here, like most Aurora decks, is we
have cards like Confront, we have cards
like Rally the Troops. We're just trying
to draw into Aurora, find the Aurora,
and play it. And cards like Vanguard
Armory, Rift Herald, and Harness Dragon
are cards that we don't mind, you know,
playing from hand necessarily because
even if we have the Elder Dragon in our
hand, which for Chaos Aurora decks is
kind of the worst case scenario
>> with this one, surprise sacrifice, here
comes the Elder Dragon into play and the
opponent has to kind of really focus and
play around that.
>> Exactly. And just with the wealth of
removal options cuz typical, you know,
uh the chaos aurora decks will still run
the flurry of blades, but now with
harness dragon to boot, you just have
extra extra removal options. Cold the
weak as well for early game if you're
against like an aggro deck. That's one
of the weaknesses of the chaos builds
because you can't really deal with a lot
of the bodies on the field outside of
things like Gust, but Cold of the Week
is a great tool to just say, "No, you're
not going to score two every turn until
I get the Aurora set up."
>> Yeah. And and I do want to talk about
the ruination a little bit. Uh some
populists I've seen are running a divine
judgment. Other ones are running
ruination. And it's kind of your reset
button, right? In this case, if you have
a vanguard armory out or you have an
Aurora out, you don't care about kind
of, you know, wiping the board because
you can wipe the board,
>> exhaust your vanguard armory, create
three recruits or, you know, move to
your the end of turn, trigger your
Aurora, and do that divine judgement
out. I mean, you get the death nail
anyway, so it doesn't even really hurt
that much if you ruination on your own
Rift Herald. So, very unique take on the
deck. I like a lot of these tools. Is it
time to talk about the competition,
though?
>> Yeah, Leblanc. It's the deck that I
actually play. I play two decks in this
uh format. I play my pet deck, which is
Lux, and then I play this version of
Luke Leblanc.
>> You are the villain. I I have heard
that.
you are on the Limitless Lux as we're
calling it. But we're not talking about
that right now. It's Leblanc's time.
Another Rift Herald. This is a baited
hook build of Leblanc. Um we got to see
uh some some baited hook uh in recent,
you know, top eight. So there was like a
Darius top eight in Utre. That was
really cool to see. Uh which is a low
bridge baited hook. This is a
traditional highbridge baited hook.
You're trying to turn your one mites
into two mites into three mites into
four mites into five mites and keep
going. Um, notably of course no formites
in the list, but still you can turn
something like a glass into the ruined
Rex uh or even like a harnessed dragon
and then eventually you'll get to that
rift herald as well.
>> Yeah. And what's notable here is this
list has changed over time, right?
Challenger TCG uh is very public about
what they do and the tech and the
reasons why and they, you know, help the
community through through coaching and
stuff like that. And the we have two
watchers now in this in this deck,
right? Previously, they tried one, they
tried zero, but these thousand tailed
Watchers, especially if you see them off
a hook where you can just accelerate it
in, it's a complete tempo swing
sometimes. And you have such good
targets to kind of do that stepping
ladder of hook stuff where you'll hook a
glass into a harness dragon or a Rex,
then hook that Rex into a Watcher, and
then if you need to hook the reflection
of the Watcher that you make, then you
can find your Rift Herald to insulate
yourself. So, it kind of lets you have
your cake and eat it too. And I really
like this list specifically, uh,
especially running Aspurn's Climb to
kind of push into the end game.
>> I am noticing though that we're only on
three Sorian Scout, three Watchful
Sentry, and those are the only two
energy units. So, you're kind of
accepting that there will be games you
go first and you don't see a turn one
play. And a lot of players don't like
that type of math. They prefer, no, I'm
just going to maximize the chances of
having that turn one play. Seems like
Diden's going to go for more of a
patient play. Like obviously you still
have the opportunity to open these and
then that feels great, but um you're
kind of accepting that you won't always.
>> Yeah, this is very much a late game deck
as you can see by the the list and the
stopping power, but I think the uh the
players here are just about ready.
>> All right. Well, we had our vote. You
decided you wanted Leblanc versus Poppy,
so we're going to give it to you. And
it's a baited hook versus an Aurora. So
gearheavy matchup here. two of the
strongest gears in Riftbound competitive
play.
>> Yeah,
>> got a chance to actually speak with the
Ziden in an interview uh just earlier
today. Don't know if we'll have a chance
to to listen in on that, but very very
fun character, very very fun personality
and uh he gave a lot of his thoughts on
Leblanc. He was saying that he changed
up a couple of things. Um but he's on a
very unit heavy list and he admitted
that himself and of course with the
baited hook, no surprise there. Yeah,
and Lebla is it's a deck where your your
game play, your style, your approach
changes based on where you are, right?
You play the Starring game very
differently than you play the wind game
and you the aspirants game is kind of
like, okay,
>> you're usually up uh 10 or at the very
least you're in game three with this
aspirants uh with this aspirin game and
you can kind of sit back a little bit
and play the end game.
>> However, the issue with when you're
playing into an Aurora deck is playing
the end game not doesn't necessarily
>> Yeah. What if what if it's double
aspirants? You know, we're going to 10
points potentially.
>> Yeah, usually Aspirin players will play
it when they're going second, but we'll
take a look here as we jump into game
one. And he does find his two drop. He
gets that watchful sentry. He's going to
pass it back over to the Poppy
channeling three runes. The ideal here
is to find that mobilize and we do. So,
Jesse's going to go up to four and we'll
couple turns off Aurora here.
>> So, I always like to highlight when
people get an ideal start. I would argue
that this is the ideal start for both.
Maybe you could argue Saurin scouts a
little better for Leblanc cuz then you
can ramp up your your runes. Uh but uh
you know the watchful sentry is still
fantastic but of course the Aurora deck
will always want to see that mobilize.
>> Yeah and we're going to go into the star
spring there. Obviously no runes up for
blood money. So we're going to create
that reflection of that watchful sentry.
Try to get a unit probably played down
to that star spring to try to get point
tempo going. We want to stay on even
points, right? It's an eight point game.
If we can score two a turn and make it a
little bit awkward for our poppy player
to uh
>> come back into the game, we can close
out the first one pretty quickly here if
we're DIY and that's exactly what we can
do. another watchful sentry actually and
we're going to trigger that star spring
and go right back over to the sigil.
>> This is actually kind of notable for
Leblon because you are a pretty power
hungry deck. So kind of conquering that
sigil is going to be a little bit more
difficult. But on the bright side,
you're scoring points fast. That is the
uh what you kind of really need to focus
on against a list. Maybe with baited
hook and things like thousand tail and
your own rift heralds, you are able to
deal with some of the bigger bodies, but
you can also just win before they get to
their, you know, big sweeps. So, I like
this play from Diden overall. Let's see
what Jesse's answer is as it's just
going to be establishing a Poppy.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And what's interesting with Poppy
is if you do have a sacrifice, it acts
as ramp, right?
>> So, you can play your chosen champion,
sacrifice her, and then you'll channel
that one rune, draw two cards. So, it
helps you dig for Aurora. It also helps
you get on Aurora runes cuz
>> now what we're going to do is there's
going to be a window of priority
probably at one point in this uh in this
next turn from the uh Leblon player. So
perhaps Jesse's just waiting to see what
happens in case, you know, we need to
sacrifice. Could maybe bait out a mirror
image here and sacrifice in reaction to
that mirror image.
>> Did you see the sacrifice in hand? Cuz I
know there were two in the deck list,
but I I didn't spot if there was one in
hand.
>> I think I might have seen one after
Jesse played the Poppy, but I'm not 100%
sure. So, we're going to have to kind of
sit in the tank here at the Dide and see
uh pilots this uh third turn here.
>> So, we're in the start of the beginning
step here where uh the temporary token
has died and drawn a card. And now we
can choose to use the Leblanc passive,
the deceiver. I like calling it a I play
a lot of League, so I always call it the
passive, but I know it's the legend.
>> Yeah, we're going to make another
watchful sentry. We actually pitch a
harness dragon, which again, in this
matchup, you'll probably need it later
anyway, so it's kind of, you know, not a
great card to have in your hand this
early on. And now this allows us to, if
we really need to, we can play our
chosen champion to the Star Spring if we
don't want to give them more
information. Uh, but we want to make
sure that we're insulated against this
Poppy next turn. Uh because if we lose
that star spring and we're forced to
kind of reconquer and that's exactly
what's going to happen here. We're going
to put a big unit on this star spring to
bring back that reflection or actually
looks like we're going to bring back the
real one. And this is really smart by
Diden because we don't want that
reflection to just die next turn. And
there's the sacrifice to ramp us into
Aurora runes for next turn. And this is
a really heads up play because Diden
pretty much is now tapped out. Played
their entire turn
>> assuming they weren't going to be on
Aurora runes next turn and now they are.
Yeah, it's a really cool deck there. I
had not seen a Poppy actually pull that
off. I played against a couple poppies
in my locals, but I haven't tested
against the deck truly. So, that's my
first time seeing that pulled off. Uh,
and that means that now if Jesse has the
Aurora, that is going to come down on
this turn. This is the entire goal of
the deck and off the top
>> deck.
>> Off the top. You can't script it like
that.
>> Oh, that's
>> that is cinema. Remember,
uh, chat voted for this. So, Aurora has
hit the field and will now at the end of
every turn reveal from the top of the
deck until you get a unit and then play
that unit. Uh, let's see what the first
one is. And it's a dragon.
>> It's always a dragon. It's always a
dragon.
>> Could be. It could be a Herald
technically.
>> That is true. It could be a dragon.
>> It always is a dragon, it seems. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And we do get the information
though. I believe the that Jesse's
running. We know he's running one
repulse. So design saw that on the flip,
so he knows it's at the bottom of the
deck. So if there is a mirror image in
hand, uh, and there's a way to kind of
deal with that elder dragon, it could be
a good time to use it. However, we're
only going to be on five runes uh, next
turn here because we had to recycle one
last turn for conquering and we recycled
one for Vi. So this is where the sigil
tax, so to speak, comes into play a lot
because yes, we're at five points,
>> but this is an ideal spot for an Aurora
player, right? We just want to be
>> below six for our opponent. Our Aurora
is established. We're ready to go. We
have a a full grip of cards in our hands
and we can protect our units that we're
playing and then start maybe we'll see
Poppy triggered. I I would say that like
the ideal outs right now for these item
would be things like hold a week if you
have something like that. If you can
deal with the elder dragon or I honestly
salvage maybe both like if you can get
both of those. Salvage is highest
priority to just deal with the Aurora
and a lot of Leblancs are main unit. I
believe there's one in Daiden's main
deck. I think we saw at least one. Some
people are on two. No,
>> no salvage in the main.
>> No salvage.
>> Oh, and I'm looking at the sideboard.
Looks like no salvage in there either in
this.
>> I guess I kind of assumed that there
were salvages in there.
>> Yeah, it's a very tight 40 when it comes
to Leblanc, I believe. And this list is
kind of made to play into the field,
right? We're not really tech for some
stuff. The sideboard has, you know, some
of the the stuff that we're used to
seeing uh in order sideboards that can
deal with Aurora, can deal with, you
know, single unit or double unit kind of
play styles, but we're actually going to
throw away our thousand tail watcher.
Again, kind of useless here. We can go
uh, you know, up here to lethal range in
terms of closing out this game one. Game
two and three becomes a lot better uh
for the Leblon player cuz you do have
access to that sideboard. The game one's
the awkward one. So, we're actually
going to jump up here and go to six. And
now this is kind of where the vice grip
of Aurora decks come into play.
>> Yeah, because again you're always having
to recycle one of your runes whenever
you conquer a sigil and that is now what
three times the Diden has had to dramp
plus the power cost of a lot of their
cards. So really painful for a Diden has
the Carthus on board. So with a Saurin
Scout uh dying presumably that will
channel then two runes plus the two at
the start of your turn. So we can expect
Diden to have seven. Um, barring maybe
like a challenge from Jesse, like if you
have that, you probably hit the carus.
>> Yeah, this is really good here.
Obviously take that mir away from
>> from designed.
>> Um, Glass can sacrifice here. I think
this is going to be a really tough one
to come back into. However, we do have a
Carthus in play, so we're able to draw a
bunch of cards next turn with the
watchful is going to die from the
reflection. And most likely, we're going
to probably move this Elder Dragon into
the Starring to try to take it over. Uh,
blood money is obviously good, too. And
we're going to be able to kind of
establish ourselves on a battlefield.
>> We're making a gold here as well from
the side of Poppy. Interesting that um
that's was the sequence chosen cuz
looking at the hand of Jesse from what
I've seen, I don't think there's really
much else that you're going to be doing.
So like you could blood money first and
then use the um sabotage to see the
additional cards. But now there's two
cards that Diden has that Jessi's
unaware of.
>> Yeah, it's technically now we're at four
cards, right? Cuz we have two watchfuls
that died. So yeah, maybe a bit of a
missed sequence. However, uh you know,
we're established now on Starring. We're
going to trigger this Aurora. I did see
a flurry of blades in hand. I did see a
uh Elder Dragon in hand. So if we do get
a Rift Herald, we can kind of slap it on
the battlefield with the uh with the
Elder Dragon and feel pretty safe here.
>> Yeah,
>> catalyst to make sure that
>> Jesse's just full ramp. There are still
two more runes available. So at the
start of Jesse's turn, that will be a
full 12. that elder could also just come
down as a natural elder dragon, an
ethical elder dragon,
>> some might say. And there's the harness
dragon to get rid of Carus. And this is
kind of picture perfect
>> uh for the Poppy player. This is the run
out that you would like, but it also
just goes to show how fast the Leblon
deck can go. Uh and this is not on their
windswept game, right? So, their
windswept game, they usually go much
faster than this. Uh and it's a post
sideboard game for them.
>> I usually call the windswept game the
auto win for Leblanc. It's just like so
hard to stop that. Uh but here's the
glass of misologist coming out and we
know that there's the sacrifice in hand.
Uh a lot of other cards were drawn from
Diden though.
>> Yeah. And the sacrifice in hand would
have been obviously much more impactful
if the carus was still in play. Right
now there's just a couple watchful
centuries and a soaring scout and a
carus in the trash for Diden. So the
target here if we do kill our glass
mixologist is obviously going to be the
Carthus. I would expect him to start uh
to develop his fragmented Leblon uh next
turn. Obviously, he doesn't have enough
room to do it this turn, but he just has
to kind of sit there and, you know, hang
out.
>> You know, when you said yesterday to my
face that you don't say LeBlanc, you say
LeBlanc, I didn't I didn't believe you.
And then you just in that moment I
noticed did not say the C. That's how
it's pronounced.
>> Leblanc. LeBlanc.
>> LeBlanc. LeBlanc.
>> Leblanc. Okay, I'll work on that. All
right. Well, Dragons going into the
Sigil of the Storm. Going to conquer a
point there. And now is when the Aurora
deck uh just keeps tightening that grip.
There's that elder dragon coming down.
Ethically,
>> that's an ethically played Elder Dragon.
>> Yep. Ethically played Elder Dragon. That
is the official industry term.
>> Yeah. And we're going to have to
sacrifice here. Obviously, our Glask is
going to die regardless. We want to kind
of get some card econoy and get some
runes back from the brutal early game
that we had of just recycling over and
over again. And I think Diden's trying
to think now what he's
>> looking to bring back with that glass
mixologist trigger. Notably, because
sacrifice you're killing is a cost.
>> You don't get to draw your cards before
you resolve your glass mixologist. You
have to resolve that glass mixologist
first.
>> Sure. Yeah. The the death nail will add
to the chain. So, um cost paid now.
Glass mixologist we assume would be
Carthus. The only other decision would
be watchful sentry if Diden's digging
for something very specific that he
doesn't have yet. But I still just Oh,
okay. And that is so
>> it's a tough spot to be in for Diden.
And in moments like this, you just kind
of assume the Aurora player has taken
control of the game. Yeah, I don't I
don't see an angle that a Leblanc Oh,
sorry, Al Leblanc can uh take this one.
>> Yeah, there's a world where I mean now
with Rift Herald, we did see the Elder
Dragon played from hands, I don't think
there's any legal targets in the hand of
Jesse,
>> but there is a world where we can
perhaps mirror image, if we can to find
it, an elder dragon, move it into Sigil
of the Storm, and then move our Watchful
Sentry into Starring to kill the other
Elder Dragon with our Elder Dragon
passive. Yeah,
>> but you still
a hook
so we can hook one of our elder dragons
and perhaps find you know ruined Rex or
a harness dragon of our own to try to
clear that back line as well.
>> I'm feeling like the only one of the
only outs that Diden's going to have
truly outside of like reestablishing
like a carus with multiple ruined racks
is to try and snipe a lot of stuff.
Mirror image which we've already lost
one of. So
>> we do see one in the hand.
>> Oh, there is one in hand for D. He did
draw four on that one turn plus now a
couple off of sacrifice. So these does
have a lot of cards in hand. Will
require multiple mirror images
plus potential things like I don't know
V peacekeeper. Maybe something like that
can uh get you in. It's going to be
easier to score one point than two
though for Diden at this point.
>> Yeah, I actually don't hate the uh the
idea of we do have a VI as well. So,
that is probably the line that we're
trying to figure out here is how we want
to try to clear obviously both
battlefields, but we want to try to
disrupt that back line as well if we
can. If we can't, then we just set up
Elder Dragons on our battlefield and
then they can't really push in either
because we're just all going to die
together.
>> Yeah, but we at least know Diden has the
ability to deal with that harness dragon
with watchful sentry. VI peacekeeper
will stun and then six will trade with
six. So, the Zidon has at least one line
that I've identified. I haven't seen the
rest of the hand though outside of the
mirror image which of course mirror
image could just like take the elder
crash into the harness dragon as well
make a copy
>> like you had been highlighting before
won't help you hold necessarily but it
will make it difficult for Jesse to uh
to score additional points but I mean
Jesse if you hold for one here and then
you're at four you're probably fine
you're on the even number at that point
because you're at the odd number so if
you're ever denied one point it's not
like that detrimental to
uh pace of play.
>> Yeah, you do have a couple more turns
here, right? Jesse's on three. So, even
if you just take this turn to develop,
which is a very real option as well. Uh
you can kind of develop. They'll go to
five. You have two more turns after
that, right? They'll go to seven, then
they'll go to eight. Uh if they hold
again, uh there's no way that I believe
that we saw on the Poppy deck list that
you can kind of cheat points. So, you're
pretty safe here if you're design. And I
think maybe the decision point we're
seeing here before he takes his uh his
action is he's trying to decide if we're
going to develop or if we're going to
try to push. If you're developing, it's
about getting as many bodies as possible
cuz that mirror image will eventually
take the Elder Dragon and then can uh
you can just send all your like little
bodies in, but it's going to be a big
development here with
>> one big dude.
>> One big one.
>> Yep. And it's not the altar.
>> Nope. I mean, we're getting a nice
showcase of different, you know, card
arts and rift through this uh the game.
We have the regular Rift Herald on the
right. We have the uh the Altart on the
left.
>> Mhm.
>> And we have the regular Elder Dragons,
it looks like, as well on the side of
Jesse. So Jesse now has we finally
triggered Poppy the legend which is now
we're going to get two XP.
>> Yeah,
>> we get one XP per hold and then we can
spend 3 XP to draw a card which is super
fun sometimes. So we're at 2 XP now on
the side of Jesse. So one more hold and
we can you know draw one card which is
obviously going to be pretty fun. But
now I'm curious what we're Oh, we're
tapping. Looks like a Rift Herald if I
had to guess.
>> That is eight with one recycle. That
feels like a Rift Herald and it is.
>> Yep. And this is where it gets very very
difficult if you're DIY, right? These
battlefields are getting massive. We do
have a mirror image in hand, so we don't
care. We just need one damage per unit
that's there when we have the mirror
imaged elder dragon. So that's totally
fine. Also, Rift Herald stipulates that
you do have to play the unit to base. So
you don't have to worry about like a
surprise from the hand into that
battlefield to start another showdown.
>> Uh but this is where RO Jesse wants to
be. Yeah, I whiff a little bit and we go
next. the rift herald movement not
getting the value there but in Aurora
list it's not always expected to um the
bigger value is getting something out of
your hand and now the Aurora trigger in
the endstep another harness dragon
>> yeah so you're either giving them a card
or you're letting them play a unit I
probably going to see I don't know a
glass maybe get played
>> we're going to sacrifice our again just
getting value from stuff that's already
going to die is uh very optimal
>> the reason I feel like that's a very
impactful hit though is because ideally
uh Diden would like on their turn be
able to crash the Herald in and then
play something like a Thousand Tail
accelerated getting everything lower.
That's no longer going to be a play. Uh
but the Rex is a nice alternative I will
say.
>> Yeah. And we're going to have uh quite
enough runes here to do multiple things,
right? We can do that mirror image. We
can maybe find a Carthus, maybe find a
hook. And this is where it gets crazy
cuz if we have a Carthus and or Hook,
>> our ruined Rex is lethal to everything.
We can send it into uh Starring, kill
two units or excuse me, send it into um
sigil, kill all three units that are
there. Uh you know, shoot the the Rift
Herald and the Elder Dragon that are on
the Star Spring with those triggers.
Kill those if we have that Carus because
of our mirror image elder dragon. And
then all they have in the back is one
Elder Dragon. Most of their units are
dead. They do have a forge in hand
though, so they can recycle those units
to see them again, which is always a
very real uh thing you have to think
about when you're playing against a
order Aurora. Yeah, and I I know that
Jesse, we saw the one repulse go to the
recycle. It's it's at somewhere towards
the bottom of the deck. Um, but Diden
theoretically shouldn't know that
there's only one in Jesse's list. I
wonder if there's a world where you
could have put the elder out to bait
that you have the repulse in hand. But
either way, we have some action here
from Diden. Now, we do find the harness
dragon off the hook. We hook the Glask.
So, the only target here for us is
Glask. Contrary to sacrifice,
>> baited hook kills the unit during its
resolution. So, you actually do the beta
hook effect before you resolve the Death
Note. So, a little bit of an inverse. Uh
Leblon's a tricky deck to play for sure
when it comes to the rules interactions.
And now we're going to bring back the
Carus perhaps. Looks like it. He's uh
poked it out of the trash there. Uh and
this is where it's going to get
>> the tempo of uh Leblon that we had where
he was got up to six points very
quickly. Bought himself some time
against Jesse where Jesse still has two
more turns needed to win. We saw two
development turns now from Ziden and now
it's anyone's game.
>> Yeah. And this is where you see the top
players navigate against Aurora uh so
expertly cuz you have time. You rush
early to see can I win before they get
the Aurora out. Sometimes they break.
No, they got the Aurora. Okay, pivot.
Now you play the long game.
>> Yeah, this is going to be really tough
cuz I think the strategy here was for
that mirror image
>> and we're going to lose that most
likely. The only targets that sabotage
can hit in this hand is mirror image and
sacrifice. Uh because we're letting
sabotage resolve, we can no longer
respond with sacrifice. So it is a
target and he actually takes a
sacrifice. That's very interesting.
>> Whoa.
>> Not scared of the mirror image perhaps.
>> Oh, what is notable though that if we
mirror image one of our elder dragons,
we could sacrifice it
>> with mirror image on the chain. That is
something
>> I suppose. Yeah. So, Jesse could have
the counter, but then
>> Oh, okay.
>> We're recycling with forge now. Looks
like we're putting the elder back into
play
>> or back into the deck, excuse me, and
then it'll get hit from the Aurora most
likely.
>> I also want to point out with the the
two VI peacekeepers. I I haven't done
the math yet, but maybe there's a world
that Diden just has enough might. I
mean, with the the double trigger of the
Rex, two VI peacekeepers, a harness
dragon, even a Karthus swinging in for
three with the one from Watchful Sentry.
There's some math that Diden's gonna
have to do on their turn.
>> Yeah. And I think that's these pro
players, they're always thinking, you
know, two, three turns ahead. I think
that one turn where,
>> you know, Desiden tanked for a bit and
then just played that Rift Herald to
base. I think that was him mapping his
next few turns. So now that the fact
that his mirror image is still in play,
this is not another Elder Dragon, right?
It's a Rift Herald.
>> This is ideal for Diden. This is not
It's a harness dragon that's going to
remove something. It's not an Elder
Dragon that's going to remove something
and be a big body on field. It's just a
body. It's just a body even though it's
again even though it's 24 might on one
battlefield and you know
>> that's 12 19 might on the other
battlefield if Diden manages to resolve
a mirror image and get a dragon it
doesn't matter right it everything is
one at that point
>> maybe even like I'm thinking of Diden's
best options here what he could draw
another Carus would be crazy you could
then crash the Rex into a harness dragon
triple snipe the Elder again
>> and then by peacekeeper. Yeah, there's
there's quite a few. You do have to
clear both though cuz Jesse just has to
hold one correct of these two
battlefields. So, Diden has a lot of
work ahead of him.
>> Yeah, and I don't I know there's a
couple cards in hand. I'm not sure if we
can perhaps take a peek and go into the
tank. There is two flurries that we have
to be careful of. Uh
>> yeah, I I didn't even take into account
how many runes Jesse has available right
now. He He's uh you know, pass the turn,
>> you figure it out is what he's saying to
>> Diden. Have fun over there.
>> Yep.
>> Good luck.
>> And this is where Diden um is going to
go into the tank here for a little bit.
Game one is super important in an Aurora
matchup because like you mentioned,
Leblon has their kind of quote unquote
auto win uh win swep game, but Aurora
also usually wins their aspirants.
However, if
>> Diden wins this one, we're going to see
Aspirants in uh game two. And this is
the kind of pivotal point now where we
have to
>> Oh, we did resolve the mirror image.
Okay, so
>> no sacrifice.
>> Perfect.
>> Interesting still that Jesse chose to
get rid of the mirror or the sacrifice
instead of the mirror image.
>> Maybe trying to just outplay it with the
uh with the flurry of blades. Maybe
assuming that the Zidon might push in
that Elder Dragon like too soon. There's
not really a reason to cuz at this point
you can just send in like one six might.
Yeah, like you were highlighting before
the Rex can just go into the uh sigil of
storm, clear all three of those and then
his uh death net will trigger twice
clearing out the elder dragon and herald
on the other side
>> or this works too.
>> Arguably even better or sequencing.
>> Yeah, we put we pass focus now and I
think Jesse's debating is this my flurry
or do I
>> one of my two flurries I should say. Uh,
and this is this is the most important
turn of the game obviously, right?
>> It's 24 might to six, but it doesn't
matter, right? Cuz everything is one.
There's the flurry. We're going to have
two Ruin Rex death nail triggers
obviously because of the Carthus uh
triggering an additional time. And now
we're going to kind of figure out what
our targets are. Looks like we're going
to get rid of Oh, there's only one Elder
Dragon in play, which is notable.
>> Yes, exactly. So, you can kill Elder
Plus uh probably a harness dragon. Well,
I mean, you're going to have to get
through the Rift Herald anyway, so I'd
say a Herald. I think you want to get
through that Rift Heralds after you
commit to combat because if they do have
another flurry blades in hand, which we
know they do, then getting rid of the
Elder Dragon just makes the Flur Blade
do one damage, right? It doesn't no
longer kill.
>> Yes, of you're always going to hit the
Elder, but I was thinking uh the second
target would be a Herald instead of the
harness dragon, but did go for the
harness dragon as a second choice. So, I
think maybe Desidon's read and Jesse
could have a Elder Dragon in hand or a
harness dragon in hand. You don't want
that trigger to come down now. Um, so
Diden now still has a sixmite harness
dragon that can go in and clear one of
these two battlefields.
>> Yeah, and we notably also we do have uh
beta hook that's still in play. So if we
manage to kind of clear the battlefield
where our um elder dragon is still kind
of
still lives afterwards, we can kind of
make a copy of it with our Leblash.
She's still ready. We could either hook
it or we can use something
>> like a VI to play that Starring to
bounce it back
>> um and just send our Carus in to kill
the other battlefield and then use our
copy of Elder Dragon to win the game.
>> Jesse said two death nails on the chain.
I don't think there's a unit in hand. So
>> potentially just reacting with
something. We're
>> Oh, there is an
spicy. Yeah,
>> that is very big.
>> And this is why Diden was very careful
about when to kill the Rift Herald
>> because this is something you don't have
to really play around if you're playing
into a, you know, Chaos Aurora. But when
you're playing into a Poppy, it's
something very,
>> very important you have to play around.
And I don't know that
>> we have four right there.
>> Even if we have the VIP peace creeper in
hand, that's is not enough to kind of uh
push both units off the battlefield. But
I'm not sure what else is in the hand of
Diden to try to clear this. Uh he hasn't
conquered either battlefield this turn.
So he does have to conquer both to win.
And with that one recruit in the base
from that forge of the future, even if
he clears,
>> there's a heat-seeking missile in the
backline. And I you could even argue
Diden could have fully optimized by
sending in the um watchful sentry first
to just like clear out the harness
dragon before taking out any herolds
because then at least you've you
maximize your value from your elder
dragon. But Jesse had the second flurry
of blades anyway. And I imagine you're
probably just going to hit that if uh if
you see that go in. So very interesting
game state that we found ourselves in
there. But now Diden, yeah, like you had
said, four might plus the five from the
VIP keeper is not going to be enough to
clear the sigil of the storm, which uh
you have to imagine means Jesse is in a
very good spot with the flurry blades.
And now a second or rather third elder
dragon established.
>> Yeah, we're counting our deck to see how
far Mirror images, one of our guaranteed
mirror images are.
>> Um because we can send the watchful
sentry in as a sort of, you know, die,
draw me two cards. Uh, obviously there's
a lot a lot more cards on top of those
mirror images unless you know it's uh
one of the the the third one, but I
actually don't believe D. Ziden runs
does he run three in the main deck is
Oh, no. He only runs two in the main
deck. So,
>> so both one was uh hit by the sabotage
and the other one was not. Um, but we're
going to be digging for that one that
was hit.
>> Yes, exactly. Uh, we're going to just
make a watchful sentry. I'm not sure
what this line is going to pan out to
because there is you have to keep both
units off next turn as well.
>> Yeah, maybe play a unit to the star
spring. Move back the watchful sentry
>> Rex
trigger.
>> Oh, we're going to send the token in to
draw cards. But at this point, we are
pretty tapped out.
>> There's a flurry of blades with a star
spring trigger on the chain. So, it's
going to prevent him. He will draw four
cards. He'll have eight damage to throw
around uh which can kill either the rift
herald or the harness dragon or the
recruit. But I'm not sure how you kind
of climb out of this.
>> No, I don't I don't think it's enough. I
think that these uh
>> unfortunately not going to be able to
get out of this one. Although I suppose
no cuz the eight damage.
>> Yeah. So, you're going to split the
damage cuz then Carthus can at least
trade with the harness dragon, but then
there's still three more damage or I
guess the herald either one of them, but
there's still going to be extra damage
left.
>> Yeah, you got it.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, we're going to go to game
two. Yeah, I mean, there's not much you
can do there. Uh, even if you manage to
clear it, that recruit, they just go
recruit the sigil, you know, harness the
star spraying. We go next. Now we're
going to see the windswept game which is
probably going to be met by the
aspirants from Jesse
>> which is a pretty comfortable spot for
uh Leblanc to be in as long as
>> we don't see that kind of creative turn
three Aurora. I mean
>> there's a very real chance Diden kind of
is able to push through and we saw how
close it was anyway. We had an optimal
Aurora open from Jesse and Diden was
right there. And even if uh like if it
wasn't Sigil of the Storm, I think the
Dion would have had that. The fact that
he had to D ramp so much was a big part
of why Jesse was able to take that game
one. But here we are game two went
helloc
>> and ideal starts for both players again.
>> Yeah, we have the soaring scout. I did
see two Aurora in the hand of Jesse. So
insulated as well. Um the ideal here
would be Oh, we actually didn't swap to
uh Leblanc everywhere at once as our
chosen champion against this. Obviously,
we don't want to really commit to
Battlefields against an Aurora deck. So,
probably part of the reason that we
still have Fragmented in our uh chosen
spot, but two Aurora in the hand for
Jesse. I'm not sure if we're going to
see a Carthus come down. If we do,
that's the now ideal start for the
LeBlanc. And there is
>> I could see the future.
>> Yeah. And this is where LeBlanc gets
really impressive. Windswept Hellog.
Again, I joke it's the auto win. I think
I have maybe a 5% win rate against
Leblanc when they open a two energy unit
going first with Windswep Hill. It is so
crazy how fast they can go, let alone
when they get a Carthus. But here's the
catalyst coming down from Jesse. So,
still just ramping up. This will be an
Aurora on the next turn.
>> It's an Aurora on the next turn.
Ideally, I would have loved to have um
>> maybe a Blood Money, so he can't just
make another soaring scout and he has to
commit a Carus to that battlefield.
>> You do technically give the runes ready,
>> but no copy notably here as well. So, I
mean, he could just gank over with the
Soaring Scout, which also is uh a very,
you know, totally fine play to do,
>> but
>> there is a world where you perhaps
>> use that to slow them down a little bit.
And there's the Ash
>> and he's going to have a very
unfortunate surprise where he sees two
units and two Auroras.
>> So, even if it's a Rift Herald revealed
off the Aurora, there's two big hits as
Jesse looks at the camera and says,
"What are you going to do?"
>> He's like, "Sorry about it, guys. Sorry
about it.
>> Just banish one, Aurora." Third reminder
of the stream chat voted on this. So,
uh, second Aurora is taken, but the
other one remains in hand for Jesse,
>> and we're going to see it here on turn
three. Uh, obviously, if that was the
one Aurora hand, these items looking
very, very good. Y
>> now, I mean, you do still have that Ash.
Uh, so what's cool is if you brought
multiple ashes in, if they hit a Elder
Dragon off the Aurora,
then they'll probably end up killing the
Carthus, which lets you maybe hook your
Ash to, you know, find something a glass
or maybe even another Ash to just thin
their hand down.
>> Uh, cuz the more you just take out of
their hand, the better, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You have a turn to dust that is in the
sideboard from Diden. Okay.
>> So, that is going to be a really good
answer to the Aurora if he has it in
hand or if he can find it.
>> Nice.
Well, Elder Dragon hits the Carus and
the Sorian Scout, but because that's on
Jesse's turn, that will actually mean
that the runes will channel and then
awaken for the Ziden, so we can use
those double runes from the Soren Scout.
And almost full ramped here. Let's see
what Leblanc can do.
>> Yeah, this is a again a very important
turn. We are playing to nine, right? So
being even is less impactful than it
would in a regular uh game of Riftbound,
but you always want to try to score two
points a turn when you're playing
against an Aurora deck. If you can score
more, great, right? If you can do eight
in one turn, you mean do that. But um if
not, you just want to score.
>> A fan of dual puzzles. I I did one of
those earlier. Yeah, that's great.
>> Um all right, so Diden, because of all
the energy ramp, has not had the same
draw death nail cards like the Watchful
Sentry, the Leblanc played out. So the
hand size is relatively low and going to
commit a couple of bodies to the field.
Presumably send this ash in for a point.
>> Doesn't have to trigger the Leblanc to
Sceiver. Yeah, there we go. So actually
going to pass. Not going to take the uh
the copy and score a second point
because like you highlighted, you don't
really need to to
>> it doesn't speed up your win. Yeah, it
being at five or being at six, you still
need, you know, two more turns to win.
Uh, so it doesn't really benefit you to
go even further down on card economy,
especially if those cards are something
you're going to need in later turns,
right? Uh, and now obviously Jesse has a
couple decisions to make. We know
there's a Rift Herald. We know there's a
harness dragon in hand. I saw a Forge, I
believe, as well. And then the mystery
card.
>> We're going to get rid of the Ash first.
Ash did her job, right? Took away one of
the Auroras that notably will come back
to hand if Jesse does hold one of these
battlefields this turn. But uh with a
Rift Herald in base and who knows maybe
a mere image in hand, this could be a
very big blowout turret on the side of
Diden. Uh the harness dragon will kill
the Rift Herald though.
>> Okay, he put it to the left and I
thought that was another Aurora coming
down the moment and uh nope, just the
harness dragon
>> into a harness.
>> That's really big. Very very big for the
here. This was kind of like you've
activated uh you know my my trap here.
You kind of walked right into it
>> as Jesse takes a big size.
>> Nice. Yeah,
>> sacrifices to air quote dodge the
damage, but still it will die. And um
because this watchful sentry, you can
just send the sentry in, copy it, send
it over with the gang. Like this is a
really nice spot for Diden to be in
because it puts you on winning next turn
without committing a lot of resources
while getting more resources back as
these sentries are going to die.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, we're going to go to the end of
this turn here. We're going to flip our
to Aurora. Another Rift Herald. This is
kind of best case scenario right now for
you if you're desided. Uh you don't want
to see a hardness dragon. You don't want
to see an elder dragon, right? You want
to just dodge the dragon, so to speak.
>> Uh, and now we still have a six might
unit out. Uh, and we can use a hook.
Harness dragon once you've played it is
much less impactful.
>> No flurry of blades. I was waiting to
see if Jesse had it cuz that's like the
best answer to Diden's current field.
But it seems like Diden is getting the
play I was talking about down.
>> Yeah, we're at the seventh point now.
And there's the glass. We are super
insulated here. And the Leblon
fragmented is going to come into play as
well. So we have a very big board in the
backside, right? We have technically 14
might 15 when we enter a combat showown
cuz of Leblon's assault and we are kind
of very well insulated on these
battlefields and all we got to do is
score two, but we saw this previously as
well where we were at six in the
previous game and then that Aurora
snowball just continued. Uh the odds
that we see another Elder Dragon off the
Aurora flip are now pretty high cuz
we've seen these Rift Heralds and these
harness dragons.
>> Yes. But even if it is that, I mean, the
14 might will check it. And we're going
to draw two off of the the watchful
sentry and then the uh mirror token, but
then also one for turn. So, three cards
can give us a lot of things. Vibe,
peacekeeper, mirror image, a lot of
different options. Now, we did see the
third Aurora get uh not revealed, but
you know, Jesse saw it off the Rift
Herald trigger, and then that's at the
bottom of the deck now, which will
probably be closer to the top after the
Aurora triggers at the end of the turn.
But
>> still only having to deal with one
Aurora, right? With decks like this that
aren't chaos decks that Chaos decks
usually run like four units.
>> Yeah.
>> So, they don't get a ton of value
through double Aurora, but decks like
this that are kind of running, you know,
six, eight units, getting double Aurora
really ramps you uh into a almost un
losable situation.
>> I believe nine was, was that it? There's
three elder dragons, three Rift Heralds,
and how many of harness? Only two. So,
eight. Yep. Eight units in the list.
>> Eight's usually your sweet spot if
you're playing a heavy unit Aurora deck.
Uh, and then four is your
>> I play chaos, so I just have a bunch of
funky stuff that I can do in tricks. So,
>> I'm going to kill it.
>> Last rights gets them back. You know,
it's fine. Lists are good.
>> Forge get, you know, forge gets it back
to me.
>> True.
So, that's going to get us the recruit
token as well as some uh cards back.
>> They're just confirming that everything
was, you know, recycled, shuffled
properly and stuff like that
>> and then we'll be able to kind of
continue here with the turn. I do see
another Rift Herald. I believe that was
in his hand.
>> Interesting. So, it seems like the
judges are ruling that Jesse because he
did not declare the recruit on playment
of the forge. He played the forge and
then immediately killed the forge to
recycle. The onplay effect would make
the recruit and the judges are upholding
that nope, you you clearly stated what
you were doing and Jesse gave a quick
sigh but is uh still focused on the
game. So unfortunate that you missed
that trigger, but you got to still find
a way to play through.
>> Yeah, the thing with triggers is they're
pretty lenient, right? You just got to
acknowledge it when it has an impact on
the game, right? Which creating
something is in fact a pretty big impact
on the game. And there's the ruination.
Ooh,
>> but both players insulated here, right?
Rift Herald from Jesse and Diden has
that glass.
>> I mean, that's game like glass can bring
something back and then attacks into
windswept. I the the Aurora.
>> Yeah, I don't know like what Jesse could
get here off Aurora. That will not just
mean game for the Zidan.
>> Harness or Elder will kill the one unit
that it brings back.
>> But then if you have a mirror image, you
just still win the game.
start getting back the watchful
sentries.
>> It makes sense. You're trying to dig dig
dig dig.
>> I don't hate bringing back the
fragmented LeBlanc here. Uh instead, cuz
>> Are you able to cuz they're sent at the
same time?
>> Uh yeah. So, uh Death Now will kind of
become pending when you're doing the
clean up that kills the units and then
they're in the trash when it's trying to
finalize those triggers. So, they're
legal targets at that point.
>> So, can you say without a doubt that uh
death nail triggers in the grave?
>> There triggers on field. Where's the
trigger then? triggers triggers from the
field into the grave
>> in the passing to the game.
>> Yeah. And there's the mirror image.
Yeah. And we're going to go to game
three. So again, like you mentioned that
windswep game kind of the auto win game
for our Leblanc player here. And now
we're going to go into a aspirance for a
Leblon player. And it looks like
>> on the side of Jesse, we're going to be
seeing
>> a Oh, forgotten monument. So that's
going to slow down the game quite a bit.
Yeah,
>> nine points and you can only score one a
turn for your first, you know, two turns
essentially from when you can start
scoring.
>> I'm imagining that Diden's pivot here is
going to be all right, we're going to
have to play a late game. Like you're
going to have to answer the Aurora,
maybe multiple, find a way to get
through it. Get your Carthus' out there.
Get your ruined Rexes out there.
>> That is the name of the game. Let's see
if Jesse gets the ideal start three
games in a row. Do we see the mobilize?
but this is not terrible. I mean, there
is a catalyst in the hand as well for
Jesse as well.
>> We'll see if we have the kind of
>> the ideal start here.
>> Second ideal start. The ideal start here
would be the black rose uh dignitary.
>> No recycle, three cost. It's a bigger
soaring scout, so to speak. Yep. And
we're going to have the uh ramp up here.
And again, we're going to six runes now.
>> Exactly for Jesse,
>> which means next turn is eight. So Diden
gets two more turns. this turn and then
one more after before the Aurora will
theoretically hit the field if Jesse
even sees the Aurora. I didn't see one
in hand yet.
>> I don't recall if I if there was one in
hand. We're going to make another token
here and we're just we're not going to
do anything with this token. It's just
going to draw us cards. We do have a
Carus that we can play out as well. So,
we can draw technically four
>> uh from that beginning trigger if it
lives to our beginning step. Uh but
obviously, we cannot
>> do anything on that forgotten monument
until our next turn.
>> Uh so, we're just going to retreat it
back. This is very heads up play where
we're now protecting our token that's
going to die because we want to draw
four and not draw two if it dies during
our opponent's turn.
>> Exactly. Exactly. All right. So, that's
a repulse draw for turn for Jesse. Let's
take a look at that hand. It's still
hard to see. Jesse's one some players
have cards upside down in their hand. I
never understand it,
>> but you know, I'm not going to judge.
It's the herald coming down here for
Jesse. Yeah. And we're going to get now
that draw four. I know some players flip
the cards when they're
>> when they reveal cards to their opponent
so they know what cards their opponent
knows that they have.
>> Oh,
>> I think Dewali is a player who does that
a lot. I don't
>> That makes sense. That's a mechanical
like uh purpose for it.
>> Yeah, which I I can't do that. Uh I get
confused at my own hand at that point,
but
>> I can't even have mismatching runes.
>> I mean, that's why we're on the desk.
>> True.
>> And this is where we have a full grip of
cards for our uh for our Leblon player.
We're still in our beginning where we're
trying to decide, hey, we're going to
make another copy of this. Fragmented.
Fragmented is great because it's uh
Watchful Sentry, hit the gym. You know
what I mean? Like if it dies, if it dies
when you want it to die, you're drawing
a ton of cards, especially if you have a
car this out.
>> And now with uh probably approximately
20 cards in these items hand, I would
say uh makes a second copy. Going to
keep developing. Keep developing. Now
with all these cards in hand, we can
also start to develop runes. And this is
D Ziden doing exactly what we had said
probably would happen. You accept the
game's going to go late. We're not
rushing Carlos into his death just to
score a point. We're saying nope, we're
just going to get bodies out there. We
already have a bunch of draw and now
we're going to get a bunch of energy for
next turn.
>> Yeah, and I think I did see an Aurora in
the hand for Jesse. But this is a really
heads up play here by Desid and bringing
everything home. Hey, if you hit an
Elder Dragon, cool, pick one, right? If
you, you know, for some reason find a
way to kill your Rift Herald on my next
turn, then okay, cool. You still get to
pick one. I'm going to try to make it so
you have the least amount of value
possible if you do hit this elder
dragon.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, even if there's no
Aurora, the Herald on field would have
checked to the six might anyway, but
this is also just giving less options
for that Elder. Aurora's out. The points
been scored from the Rift Herald as he
reveals three. And that is a hit. And
that is a big one.
>> Yeah, that's an interesting one because
now it's not going to get hit off
Aurora. It's in your hand.
>> But the the Herald when it dies, you
know that that's coming down. So,
>> can we find the second one here? If
we're just
>> That would be crazy.
>> And we can
>> come on.
>> Never punished.
>> I feel like Diden's playing against the
Is this the protagonist or the
antagonist? I don't know. But Diden's
going through an anime episode right now
trying to get through these auroras.
>> We're entering act three currently of
this of this fight.
>> This is the the trilogy happening right
now. We're still going to draw two, uh,
not four, unfortunately. But at least
we're drawing two cards, uh, in our
beginning step. We're going to channel
our runes. We're going to draw cards. We
already draw three cards this turn.
Again, one of the reasons I love this
deck is
>> you get to play with your entire deck,
which is always fun.
>> I think we're up to 47 cards in hand
now. Don't know how we got the extra
seven in this deck list, but
>> don't tell the judges.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You You won't tell
them, right?
>> No, I'm I'm over here. And we have a
safety inspector, which is one of my
favorite cards in this matchup.
>> Big big hit. Oh, and two harness
dragons. Okay.
>> So, sorry. This is ready. I haven't used
it yet. Good. Uh
>> yeah, we're going to ready that the that
deceiver
>> deceiver trigger.
>> Oh, and we're going to now we're going
to make the copy of the soaring scout
again. We're just trying to
>> a lot of energy, especially with that
hand that we saw. Like that actually is
a pretty good hand to deal with multiple
Elder Dragons.
>> Yeah, we're so early. It's ironic to say
we're in like, you know, turn four or
five at this point, but we're still so
early in this game, right? It's 3 to one
currently. So there's going to be, you
know, at least, you know, three to four
more turns that we're going to see from
these players. And rune economy is going
to be what wins or loses design in the
game here. So kind of insulating and
getting a lot of those u soaring scouts
out is very important. Hard casting a
safety inspector here I don't hate
because the option is you kill your
elder dragon or you kill your rift
herald and then you kill something that
doesn't really matter if you kill it if
you play your elder dragon from hand,
right? So, this is I don't know
something I would probably look at doing
if I was in this spot. Obviously, I'm
operating with more information cuz I
you know some of the contents of Jesse's
hand, but we're going to see the safety
inspector come down and now these items
are going to kill that Storing Scout,
>> make a channel run and then there comes
that Rift. There's a lot of moments in
games uh card games, Rift especially,
where you just have to chew through the
resources. This is one of those moments
where you know the Herald or the Elder
Dragon's in hand, you know it's going to
hit the field. You can't stop it. So get
it out of the way now so it's not a
problem later and then deal with it once
you have more runes to work with. So I
like this from Diden as well.
>> Dragons are facing opposite ways.
They're they're saying hi to each other.
I don't like that they're kissing.
>> I like keeping everything nice and clean
and organized on live board. But
>> no, agreed. But you know,
>> it kind of makes a cool like little
swirl.
>> It is. We're creating a a picture now.
This dazzling aurora.
>> They're just friends. Yeah, and it looks
like we're going to kill the safety
inspector and kill the soaring stuff
that's on the battlefield with the
dragon trigger, which is totally fine.
Uh, that safety inspector is a really
good hook target to find another safety
inspector. So, getting rid of it is
awesome. Obviously, getting rid of the
dusk rose or getting rid of the Leblanc
fragmented means you're giving your
opponent stuff. So,
>> so going for Leblanc sacrifice
essentially, whatever you send in to
conquer the point, you're expecting to
die. So, Diden here, what I'm learning
is he wants to draw more cards rather
than channel more runes. Y
>> um could go up to 11 runes as opposed to
10 at the start of the turn if you send
in the um uh dignitary instead.
>> Yeah, the mirror image here I think is
kind of a no-brainer at this point cuz
the hook, yes, while it can find you
>> uh scary units, that mirror image just
gives them an elder dragon. Uh we do see
a safety inspector in
>> Yeah, what a hand
>> in the hand. And again, these items was
very public about the law list and all
that stuff. So Jesse probably knows that
he runs two maybe and he's like, "Okay,
well this is in hand, so I'm not really
worried about the hook finding another
one catching me off off guard." So
>> and with the harness dragon in hand plus
one that was already pitched, you're not
expecting I mean you'd have to get like
the glass plus the uh the the hook, but
still
>> less likely that that's going to happen
as well.
>> Focus.
>> Yeah. So we're going to have the double
conquer here with the two big dragons.
And we're at down to four runes though
if we're Jesse. We recycled a lot,
right, to play those elder dragon, the
elder dragon from the rift trigger. And
now we're going to go to our Aurora,
find the harness dragon, and whatever
you kill, you're giving them a rune,
right?
>> Probably the dignitary here, just cuz
it's slightly more valuable.
>> Dignitary% and also deciding where the
harness dragon is going to go,
committing it to the battlefield. So
Jesse wants to try and hold. This is uh
something that you know Aurora obviously
is going to be harder to do it against
until you get the Aurora, but a lot of
decks just want to hold against Leblanc
cuz if you stop that Leblanc legend from
ever triggering, you're really slowing
down what Leblanc can do. And Jesse
saying, "Yep, I'm just going to try and
load up one of these at least."
>> Yeah. And the thing with LeBlanc is yes,
that's the game plan you want to do, but
it is very hard to hold against.
>> Yeah, I'm seeing a repulse in hand for
Jesse, but no body runes up, so not even
able to activate it right now. Yeah,
that would be a very very good into a
mirror image would be a very good
response to it. But again, we recycled
all our four runes to play our Elder
Dragon.
>> And we just used one more to play Sabo.
So I think we were we got the mirror
image with the Sabo. So that's kind of
what we used instead of holding up that
repulse. So it's a way of putting the
Sabo uh excuse me, putting the mirror
image back into the deck. And now we're
probably going to see a I would assume a
development turn here from Diden. And is
that a double Glask going to hit the
board?
>> I think it's a double Glask.
>> Yeah.
Let's see. Okay, decisions made.
>> So, that's going to be 10 energy, two
power,
>> and the entire turn essentially. I
imagine that's just a pass. Yeah.
>> Also noticing if we're keeping track of
the elder dragons that were saying hi to
each other and then separated. Now,
harness dragon. There's something going
on there.
>> Yeah,
>> with elder dragon. We got to we got to
look into Oh.
>> Oh, it's upside down.
>> Okay, correct.
>> Chaos. We think we just drew another
Aurora as well. So,
>> can't play it.
>> Dead H dead card in the hand right now.
We have the Vanguard Armory. We haven't
seen it make an appearance yet, but
still can't play that either. So, we're
just going to pass the turd.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Hold. Get another body off of the
Aurora. And it is a Rift Herald.
>> Let me look at my hand real quick before
I resolve that.
>> We do have a sacrifice. We don't really
have much interaction in our hand.
>> One repulse. That's really it. So, if
you put out the battlefield, that means
that mirror image can be repulsed. It
targets one thing
>> and one thing only and that's all
Repulse cares about as long as it's at a
battlefield.
>> That's exactly what Repulse cares about.
>> Very specifically
what he cares about. Yeah.
>> Oh, we do have a Carus in hand and a
hook in hand. So, I think it's going to
be probably develop a Carthus, play the
hook
>> and you can take another turn off to
develop uh at this point. But I mean
>> one and one target the mixologist
>> mixologist and hooks and multiple
caruses.
>> That's gonna get a little crazy. Yeah,
there's the Rex. I honestly think if
Diden doesn't do much this turn other
than just pass like it's still a really
good turn. You could even just crash the
glass and the Sorian Scout into the
harness dragon. Just deal with one body
there.
>> Yep. We're going to get the Leblanc
fragmented and another Carthus back
which is insane cuz now we're kind of
>> our glass gets us three things back now
when it dies. Yep.
>> And if we ruined Rex, if we either
sacrifice the rune Rex or something in,
you know, in response to them trying to
kill one of our carcasses, we still have
12 damage to kind of throw around. We
got a hidden blade in hand as wellidden
>> and we're going to have the hidden blade
on our own. This going to ramp us a ton
of runes, right? Whoa.
>> And there's a sacrifice.
>> Very heads up play here by design
because now you're pretty much holding
up
>> 12 damage at reaction speeds. No. Okay,
>> that is a heads up play.
>> I will.
>> And it's one of those plays that I watch
and I'm so happy I'm not at that table
cuz I promise you I already would have
lost playing this Leblanc deck. You have
to play with so much patience and when
you're playing with patience against an
Aurora deck, it just feels like you're
being suffocated.
>> But Diden keeping his head above water.
>> If I'm not mistaken, I might have seen a
salvage get drawn from Jesse. So that's
going to kind of
>> thwart the uh hook kind of scenario
there. Yeah, it looks like the salvage
is going to get played out.
>> Get rid of that baited hook. Uh if there
isn't another one in hand, which it
doesn't seem to be on the side of Diden,
it kind of makes him have to get a bit
more creative with how he kind of throws
his units around next turn. But I think
he's in a decent spot. Obviously, you
let Jesse double hold, you lose the
series here, but there's a crazy
backline on the side of these. And you
know what's crazy is that we still have
a third uh
>> you know I was about to say a third game
to play cuz it's gone so long. No, this
is the third game in fact.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Funny how memory works like that.
All right. Elder dragon's coming down.
>> And this is where you can kind of hold
up the Oh, we're just going to let it
go. Okay.
>> So, we're not going to sacrifice the
rift, the ruin rex, excuse me, or the
glass to get the additional trigger from
the carus. We're just kind of just
>> want to hold that sacrifice for
something else, maybe. It looks like
>> Yeah, bold move.
cuz it would have dealt with one of
three elder dragons.
>> Yeah,
>> which now seems to be a trifecta at the
uh aspirin's climb.
>> We do have a ton of runes available for
Jesse as well. We know that repulse is
in. Uh notably, if you do kind of use
that repulse for the ruin directs,
you'll counter one of its triggers, not
all of them, but that'll throw the math
off as well.
>> Yeah, cuz it is multiple instances
triggering.
Let's see what Deiden has. First card
looks like it's about to come down. Heck
of a board to get through.
>> Ash.
>> Ash will at least let you check what
Jesse's options are. You can get rid of
that repulse specifically. That's
probably the biggest target here.
>> Yeah, now Jesse's kind of deciding if he
wants to
>> do something. But
>> two sacrifice, a ruin nation, a Vanguard
Armory, and Aurora, another salvage, and
a catalyst. Trying to cover up the
Repulse with the catalyst like Yeah.
Don't look at this one, please. So,
really the only one that's going to be
uh notable here is the repulse um
salvage I guess like if you play baited
hook and then attack in before using the
baited hook uh could be an issue. But if
you're trying to clear out the entire
field,
>> it has to be for sure. Sacrifice
obviously you don't know what those
cards are going to create. Uh you now
know there's no units in hand, so you're
not scared of a sacrifice on the Rift
Herald. Yep. Uh, and if they sacrifice
it, it's almost always positive for you
>> for that to happen. So,
>> I think now Diden has, you know, looks
like what, seven runes, I think, ready
and ready to go. So, has some leeway,
can get a bit creative, has 11 might
that he can swing around uh with just
those two units. And now, if he puts
Leblon as well, it's going to draw him a
bunch of cards. And what's again notable
is if you swing glass with Leblon, they
die together. You bring Leblon back.
>> Yeah.
>> So, here we go. see what they decide to
go for. Yeah. So, how much might is just
straight up? That's nine. That's 14 that
can go in and deal with the Elder Dragon
>> plus the assault from Leblanc.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm counting that in there, I
believe. So, it's uh 4 plus. Oh, so 15.
Exactly. Yeah.
>> So, a pretty big swing. We can get rid
of an Elder Dragon. you could kind of
send them into uh Forgotten Monument,
clear that battlefield out by killing
the Elder Dragon and then using the two
Ruined Rex triggers to kill the Rift
Herald, but then you still have two more
Elder Dragons and a harness dragon to
deal with on the other side. So,
>> but if that doesn't win the game for
Jesse, that would hold him to eight
points. So, Ziden, if you can at least
clear the Forgotten Monument, could get
another turn potentially if you just
send the rune rex Leblanc and then you
have the glass mixologist that can go
in. You can copy the glassologist. That
can turn into a lot more later cuz we
know Diden sells that sacrifice in hand,
I believe. Yeah.
>> I wonder if even you would just like
sacrifice the Glask first, get multiple
Carus' back, then you can send in the
Rex, get an additional trigger.
>> So, let's say we're going 10 to kill.
Yeah. So, we're going sending in the
minimal amount that we need
>> to kill the Elder Dragon through combat
damage.
and then kill the Rift Herald through
the Ruined Rex triggers. What it looks
like we're doing,
>> you would imagine. Now, Jesse has some
options here. You could sacrifice like
your harness dragon on the Forgotten
Monument just to draw two cards cuz then
Yeah, and that's what we're doing cuz if
you draw into a unit,
>> you see the future.
>> If you draw into a unit, then uh
potentially that Rift Herald will uh
>> cost. Okay.
>> Then potentially the Rift Herald will
get you more value there.
>> Yeah. See what he draws. A sac. It looks
like a sacrifice. And I don't see what
the top card of the
>> Oh, come on, Jesse. Holding a little
forward.
>> Literally holding it close to his chest.
>> Yeah, that's what I was about to say.
>> He's kind of reading if he can play it
to a battlefield, I'm assuming. But
unfortunately, you do have to play it to
base when it comes to Rift Herald.
>> It's a fair card.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, we have another Rift Herald is what
he just
>> Nice. Well, that's something. That's
another seven might on your next turn
that allows you to kind of if you play
it to base, I mean it allows you to win
the game
>> potentially if he doesn't clear your
aspirates climb.
>> Jesse's going to salvage to just draw a
card.
>> Yep.
>> So looking for maybe another option if
you Okay, that's pretty good.
>> Okay, so I have four triggers. I'll
draw.
>> Yeah, Diden gives a sigh
>> and double ping. Another reason I was
thinking maybe it makes more sense to
sacrifice your glass early, get your
Carthus because then at least you could
death nail trigger clear out this elder
dragon
>> and then look to do something else
afterwards like a VI peacekeeper maybe
draw into a mirror image but at this
point Diden if you don't draw like a
mirror image here I don't really know
what else you could realistically do.
Yeah, I think the goal here was maybe to
clear that battlefield, play a safety
inspector, maybe have them sack a unit,
and then
>> send as much as you can at that other
battlefield cuz you do have a hidden
blade that you can use kind of
offensively to clear it.
>> I think there's actor.
>> Yeah. So, safety inspector is going to
come out. And what is chosen to get
sacked here is very important
>> because if you get rid of one of the
elder dragons, uh, you can just get
hidden bladed.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> That's all we have left. If you get rid
of the Rift Herald in the back, you
can't really push up next turn. So, this
is probably the safest thing to
sacrifice is the second elder dragon
because now you're still asking Designer
to solve two problems.
>> Yeah.
>> And you have the uh Rift Herald to have
a proactive play on your next turn for
Jesse.
>> Walk into here. My Focus play Hidden
Blade targeting the
>> Elder.
>> Yep.
Now, sacrifice. There's a two more
sacrifices in Jesse's hand. So, you
could just do that if you I mean, you're
going to draw two regardless, but then
you at least get the rune channeled. I
feel like that's worth it.
>> Yeah, and this is a good play because at
this point now, if this combat does
resolve
>> and we get to make another glass, we
have 10 might on that battlefield
defending against a seven might. There
is still Poppy though. Poppy, the
hammer.
>> Notably, she won't enter ready though.
>> She only enters ready if your opponent's
within three. That's a good point. it
within four cuz Aspirin's climb is
changing the math there.
>> So Poppy is not going to be a might
swing here and I think that's the line
he was looking for at the end. Kind of
made Lemonade out of lemons. It was what
that turn looked like for
>> still holding on for now. Jesse has a
lot of outs. If you draw a flurry of
blades, if you draw an Elder Dragon, I
guess you can't play the Elder Harness.
I suppose
>> even flurry is going to be rough cuz
you're going to give four units back to
that battlefield with
>> Oh, true. Yeah, I guess at that point
you just go
>> confront is Yeah, confront. Poppy wins.
Perhaps wins here.
>> Okay,
>> so draw off the confront. Poppy enters
ready.
>> Uh let me see.
>> We're doing it one at a time here. He's
I'm assuming we're going to see
>> the Leblanc come out. This is one of our
highest might units.
>> Oh no, Elder Dragon just killed both.
That's correct. Yeah. So, we're going to
see four four units come back. Our four
biggest units, which it's just going to
be LeBl
good.
>> So, we're at seven now. Nine.
>> Uh, thinking about where I'm putting
>> enough to prevent the win unless there's
a flurry in hand. If there's a flurry in
hand, it's just over.
>> So, you could you only need seven out
there.
>> All in the battlefield.
>> All in the battlefield. I thought maybe
you hold one back to base just in case
you need the extra body, but nope.
That's going to be all out there.
>> Don't know if there's a flurry in hand.
If there is, it's just GG
>> based on Jesse's thought pattern here. I
mean, you're smacking that down if you
right.
>> Yeah, it would be a slow roll of all
time.
>> Sabo looks like a Sabo. Okay.
>> Or Yeah,
>> but I don't hate putting all four units
here on the battlefield because Carus is
still going to trigger if they push the
Rex in. So, we're channeling four runes
and drawing two cards. And we're just
also killing the the Rift Herald in case
there's some funkiness going on.
>> Sure, that does make sense actually when
you put it that way.
>> No units off the Rift Herald is notable
as well.
>> Yeah. Uh so yeah. Uh trade. I have uh
369 death nail triggers. I'll have the
ramps res.
>> This is dead.
>> Yes.
>> Dang, that's a lot of runes.
>> So draw three cards and then ramp six.
>> Nothing on their death.
>> Okay. Three and then ramp. Yeah, draw
three.
>> Oh, sorry. Channel
>> six runes, excuse me. Yeah, because
there is three car or two caruses in
play.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah,
>> I don't think he had that many. So, uh,
>> he would have gotten all of them
regardless.
>> Yeah,
>> we got a harness dragon to kill the
Carus.
>> This is not a terrible spot now for
Diden, right? There's a mirror image.
He's tapped out. A mirror image is
insane if you can find it.
>> Um, does he have it?
>> He has not been drawing them. Harness
dragon can clear the elder.
>> Yep.
>> And then do we have was there also
another uh inspector? I think there was
a inspector too. Oh, but you don't have
enough. That's five and eight.
>> Yeah, harness is a expensive unit.
There's a hidden blade though.
>> Oh, that that's enough to at least get
us get D's added in another turn.
>> Yeah, this is
>> looks like there's more riftbound to be
played. We are at turns though. Turns
left at the bottom left. Uh, I've been
so focused on the gameplay. I didn't
even see when we hit that.
>> This has been a very interesting series.
Uh, I much prefer, you know, order
Aurora decks. I feel like there's more
uh fun and agency that you can have.
Maybe they're worse obviously, but it's
a lot of fun to watch uh design and kind
of navigate a more unorthodox version of
uh, you know, the big bad. So,
>> yeah, exactly. But it seems like Jesse,
all you need to do is win by two points.
So, uh, if you're able to just hold on.
>> Yep. You got it. Ziden's going to be
looking for a miracle essentially cuz
he'd have to score two. Does the Zid
even get two more turns?
>> Did gets if this is turn one
Ziden gets
>> Oh, there's he's going to score a point
here.
>> Yeah.
>> So, he's going to be at six
>> and then on his next turn he can go to
he can force a draw essentially
>> unless seems like that's the best Diden
has.
>> That's not ideal for either player then.
the the double losses are tough.
>> Yes,
>> some players will just choose to to give
it up, say, "No, I'll take the better
tiebreaker."
>> Some players aren't paying attention to
the timer. There's a lot of decisions
being made.
>> Yeah, this a ruination.
>> Yep.
>> Cap.
>> Uh, sacrifice.
>> Sacrifice
>> ramp draw two.
>> Okay.
>> No, it would be. Yeah. So, we need to
score one point to force a draw.
>> Yeah,
>> if you are winning by two or more, you
win the the match.
>> He has no more units in his deck as he
uh cheers a little bit. Uh
>> which is good because you kind of want
to draw. We don't have a mirror image. I
don't know that we have a way to draw
cards.
>> No, Thousand Tail. I mean, this is
sacrifice.
>> Rift Herald is interesting.
>> I have no way to accelerate, so
So GG
>> pass. It's a draw.
>> Yeah.
>> No, I don't believe
>> 86.
>> So win by two, correct?
>> Yeah. Two or more should be.
>> Okay. So is it is a draw or?
>> Uh I win by two.
>> The players are trying to figure it out
now with the judge staff to see how
we're ending this game.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, okay.
>> All right. Looks like D. Ziden was
thinking maybe he could get the win.
Maybe was not sure as to the points, but
either way, and lost and I want
>> there's the fist bombsh
>> and I think Jesse summarizing a lot of
uh the Aurora experience he's like I
felt like I misblade still got it
>> Victor Jesse congratulations uh Diden
very tough opponent to take down
>> yeah this match was kind of a little bit
of a I would say almost a masterclass on
how to play into these Aurora decks was
finding some very intricate lines and
>> obviously playing to his outs which
again Leblon's kind of favored into this
obviously the windswept game, but
>> it's still a tough matchup, especially
when you're playing into an order Aurora
that has access to Rift Herald and
Sacrifice. We saw that kind of just
swing the tempo back towards the favor
of Jesse.
>> And also, I don't think I mentioned it
uh earlier, but I do believe that Diden
was the best of Leblanc and Sydney, I
want to say. I got to talk with him
earlier today. I believe it was Sydney.
Um, so again, a very very good duelist
to take down. He was so close to getting
out of very, very tough Aurora
situations. Uh, wasn't able to do it.
That game two was a masterclass though
of like patience and winning against
Aurora. So cool to see there.
>> Yeah, and we saw that also in game three
a little bit where we're on turn five,
turn six, and no no one's broken four
points yet, you know, like we're just
all trying to set up. We're not trying
to, you know, overextend and we really
want to make sure that we don't put
ourselves in a position that's unwinable
at that point.
>> So, uh, after all that, Gren still fan
of Aurora?
>> I've always been a fan of Aurora. I
think I have like
>> set one I had 1500 games on Aurora MF.
>> What? Yeah, but
>> how do you even play that many games?
>> Well, I started playing when the game
came out uh in China as well.
>> Oh, I first proxied a deck and then I
had a friend who visited China and he
built me an Aurora deck and brought it
back home. So, a full Chinese MF Aurora
deck and then as the game came out in
the west, I you know,
>> got the English version of the deck and
played a bunch of it. I was a Mountain
Drake believer back then.
>> So, to be clear, Grenon is a fan of
Aurora and of the Limitless Lux. Yeah,
>> those are two two decks you're quite
fond of. feel like you're
>> Wow. Yeah, you're making a lot of fans
uh in chat right now. I'm pretty sure.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm sure you don't care. Again, the
players out there are the ones that
care. They they clearly uh um big fans
of you. Happy to have you on the cast
with me. Especially as a judge, it's so
helpful to just be like, "What's going
on there?" And you're like, "Oh, no.
This is what's going on." You know,
level three judge here. Let me just
explain things for you.
>> Level three caster as well, apparently.
>> Oh, is that what that says?
>> This is a little gift from someone.
>> Oh, that's adorable.
>> Little level three caster.
>> Well, that's a E. I It's a backwards E.
Okay. Can we show that to the I don't
know if the camera saw that. It's an L
and then a backwards E. There we go.
Okay. You know what? It counts. That's
good.
>> We'll give it to us.
>> That's creative is what that is.
>> But did this Poppy game make you like
Aurora anymore?
>> No. No. Not Not quite.
>> I thought maybe I was like, "Oh, it's
creative. It's a little bit intricate."
>> I did like when Jesse looked at the
camera and went, "H, you know, when
there are the two off of the ash, I you
know what? I liked that moment. That was
that was a good moment right there. But
it just shows how hard the deck is to
truly shut down because the moment that
Aurora gets out there, it just keeps
going and um especially with the list
that these had no uh you know sabotages
or not sabotages, salvage. There we go.
No salvages to clear out the Aurora.
It's like you you just have to play you
just got to play through it and just
deal with these giant bodies hitting the
floor every single turn.
>> Also notably no coal a week, right?
We're playing cold a week on a unit,
right, with Safety Inspector, but it's
obviously much more expensive if you're
playing it from your hand. Y
>> where if you had a call a week maybe
those games look different but
>> I think cold a week overall is probably
worse into the larger field right so
that's probably why design opted for the
safety inspector cuz obviously defy is
you know a very popular card of the week
falls over to defy but you can't defy a
safety inspector
>> yeah exactly uh and I'm hearing that
we're going to have a standby here to
for a a breakdown of some of that last
gameplay in a moment so uh while we're
waiting for that then um with the
Another match that was going on, I
believe. What was that one that was
voted on? I know that we voted for the
Poppy and Leblanc.
>> Master Y and Vi.
>> Mastery and VI. All right. I'm going to
imagine that the EU won that one. Do you
think so?
>> I'm going to imagine the V one.
>> You imagine the V one. All right. Well,
we may never know, but we do have uh an
analysis segment ready. So, let's throw
it over there.
>> Thanks, gang, for sending this over to
me. I am excited to talk to you quite a
bit about what we just saw because it
showcased two things that I think are
important. First, how you beat Aurora
and then second, why you might consider
playing the Poppy version of Dazzling
Aurora. First, let's talk about how you
beat Aurora. very early on in game two,
very early indeed because we see just
one point. We're going to see that
double conquer that happens early
because of the Leblanc being able to
make this reflection as well as send it
over because this is windswept Hill and
that's really important because again
you get these early points. The way that
you beat Aurora is very often scoring
points while they are setting up and
then capitalizing on it as well by
either slowing down the Aurora with
cards like salvage or here in a little
bit as this plays through you're going
to see the development from Diden with
an Ash and Ash is meant to snipe
Dazzling Aurora away. Now, the one
downside is when we see this Ash get
deployed, you're going to notice that
there's not one but two Dazzling Auroras
in the hand of Jesse, which did
ultimately give Desiden a little bit of
trouble in this game too. While they
were able to pull it off, there was more
struggle because of the second presence
of that dazzling Aurora. And it is again
one of those things where you have to
just capitalize on your moments if you
want to beat a deck like this. So, uh,
here we see the Ash come down. And as I
said before, one dazzling Aurora, great.
Two is a bit of an uh-oh. And then, of
course, you see the Rift Herald as well
as the dragon, that harness dragon
potentially problematic. And that leads
me to point number two. So, while
Desidon does ultimately win this game,
when you're playing Poppy as an Aurora
deck, the reason you would choose Poppy
is because of these big order units like
Harness Dragon as well as cards like
Ruination. So, this was still in game 2.
And while Desidon ultimately does go on
to win here because of mirror image
after the fact, what this ruination
does, if you let it play, is it sets up
a situation where Jesse had the
opportunity to clear the board and then
on passing the turn get first units on
the board from the Dazzling Aurora. So
the ruination serves as a reset button.
It's a bit of a panic button. You don't
have to lean as heavily on your Elder
Dragons like some of the chaos versions
of Dazzling Aurora do. Now, as I said
before, the one downside here is that
ultimately Desidon has the mirror image.
They're able to still get the double
conquer here. They'll end up taking game
two, but again, Ruination, an incredibly
important card because after all, it is
what gets Jesse the win. Let's go ahead
and jump ahead to the end of game three.
So, we're in overtime when this
ruination comes down. And this is
incredibly critical for securing this
game because you'll notice it's eight
points to six overtime rules in
Riftbound. If you end and you are at
least two points ahead, then you are
considered to win that game. They were
1-1 split. So, this ultimately gives
Jesse the series because of this
ruination. It clears the board. There's
no accelerate options on the side of
Desidon to try and force a draw, get
that last point. So again, if you're
wondering why you would ever consider
running Poppy or some of these non-
chaosdazzling Aurora lists, this is why.
Ruination and cards like Harness Dragon.
So ultimately, great series. You got to
see how to beat Aurora as well as why
you might consider other versions of
Aurora. Hopefully it inspires you at
home to either play Leblanc or Poppy.
But uh with that in mind, I'm just going
to send it back.
>> What's up everybody? Kangas here with
the best of Leblanc from Sydney, D Zon.
Thanks for joining us here.
>> Hey, happy to be here.
>> LeBlanc has not been performing at the
top that we were promised. Ditan, what's
going on with your chosen legend?
>> I think the demise of Leblanc is very
much overblown. I mean, some I know it
didn't make top eight in a couple of
events, but if you look at the placement
of Leblanc in the last event, Utrect, it
actually just placed 11th. So, it had
the same record as the guy who made
eighth place. The Breakers were just
worse. So, I think that the the idea
that the deck has like completely fallen
off is crazy. Um, I think the only
reason people are talking about that is
because they just expect me to, you
know, top every event and sometimes I
don't quite get there. So, uh, you know,
this time around I think we're going for
the trophy. So,
>> it feels like uh part of the the
difficulty of the deck is that there's
so many different tech options that you
can choose in it uh depending on what
the meta in the field is going to look
like. So, what were your choices for
this event? Were there any, you know,
interesting cards you decided to put in
or tweak? Yeah, so in Utrect, I went
down to one Rift Herald and I was
actually very disappointed with that
change because I started losing games. I
was doing well into the purple decks
that I've been having problems with, but
then I started losing games to deck like
decks like Yei and Azir and I'm like,
well, that's those are supposed to be my
best matchups. If I'm losing those, and
Rift Herald is one of the best cards in
those, clearly one is not good enough.
So, I put the second Rift Herald back
in. I still have two Watchers in the
main. Um, I found space for a third
hidden blade. And then in the sideboard,
we now have a one of Death Grip. um a
very spicy combat trick that nobody's
really playing around because Leblanc
for the most part has to play just
mostly units and creatures or sorry
units and uh the gear. So we don't
really have a lot of space for extra
interaction. So I think it's going to
catch people off guard.
>> I feel like that's one that I saw in a
lot of earlier Leblanc builds and uh a
lot of people are trying out like all
the death nail stuff with the spells
slinging out there. But you still think
that like unit list is the way to play
Leblanc right?
>> Yeah, I mean hook is one of the most
insane things you can do in the game. I
mean, if I can take a single card from
my hand, turn it into a copy of, let's
say, a mixologist and then hook it into
like a Rex or a harness dragon, I mean,
there's nothing in the game that can
really compete with that in terms of the
value engine. So, I think Hook is still
the way to go. The results clearly show
that where all the events or all the
lists that have topped the uh gotten
best of this season have all been Hook.
Um, so I think I I think it's always the
way to go.
>> Okay, cool. Well, thank you for sharing
your insight. Last question for you is,
where's the old shirt? When are you
going to bring back the white with the
Sharpie?
>> Maybe uh maybe if I get a trophy, I'll
bring it back for an event. You know, I
got to I I have it somewhere. It's, you
know, somewhere in the pile of stuff.
I'll I'll bring it back someday.
>> We should get Challenger TCG to make
custom just white shirts for you.
Somebody has the scan of it.
>> May we'll see.
>> All right. All right. We'll get on that.
Thank you so much. Best of luck.
>> All right. One last question for you.
>> You see Dazzling Aurora hit the board.
What do you do, Maddie?
>> You know, I'm going to stay calm. I'm
going to wait for their Elder Dragon uh
trigger and then I'm going to starcross
it and then I'm just going to keep on
scoring, baby.
>> I'll cry.
Um that was not the plan. Um if my ashes
have not removed it from the game
already, uh and it's hit the board, then
that's probably just my hand out.
>> Oh, I mean sideboard your salvages
immediately.
Thermmo beam anything you got. So take
that out immediately.
>> Salvage. I mean
>> salvage. Yeah, I'm playing yellow. So
>> salvage.
>> Salvage.
>> Salvage it.
>> I don't think that's so much of a hot
take. That's the way to go.
>> I forgot what show I was on.
>> Dazzling roar hits the board. What does
Shawn do?
>> Okay. Shawn cringes a little bit inside.
Says, "Is this really what you're
playing right now?" And then I act Sean.
Boom. Take that. And now it's mine. And
you cry.
>> Yep. There you go. All right. Well, that
is going to do it for a hot tank. I
don't think I could take any more. That
was great, Sean. Thank you so much.
We're going to send it back.
>> Hello everybody and welcome from the
regional qualifier here in Hartford,
Connecticut. I am Charmer and I am
joined by the wonderful glitched goober
here at the event. This is somebody that
has been part of our greater community
going all the way back to Legends of
Rune Terra, but has transitioned to
Riftbound and is a fan favorite.
Can you explain to people who you are?
Yeah. So, I am an artist that draws
really derpy art cards and I have been
traveling to all the North American
Riftbound regional events to hand out my
cards for free, mostly walking up to
people awkwardly and just asking if they
want to take a souvenir home with them.
>> Yeah. And what has happened at these
events is a lot of times you don't have
to walk up to anybody.
>> Oh.
>> You have been getting a line and it
really kicked off in Vancouver where you
debuted this cosplay. Do you mind
sharing what you're cosplaying as?
>> Yes, I am cosplaying as a warded brush.
I play Ivvern and I wanted to be one of
his many children, so I cosplayed as a
brush. I realized wards are not yet in
Refound. Don't know if they will be, but
I needed a way for people to find me.
Someone called me short once and I said,
"Not anymore."
>> No, definitely not. And speaking of
short, you're not short on artwork and
you have some amazing tokens that you've
been giving out at the event. Do you
want to maybe give us a preview here of
what the tokens look like?
>> So, here are some of my funny artworks
uh just as little alternative tokens for
people to use. Um again, they're just
really silly and I just really like
seeing people smile. So, everyone's
welcome to take one home with them for
the weekend.
>> That's right. So, if you are here at the
event and you see Glitch Goober, feel
free to get your amazing token. Now, you
said you like to see people smile. What
made you want to start doing both the
artwork, but also the giveaways and the
cosplay? Like, you're kind of doing a
little bit of everything for the
community.
>> Uh, so the I mean, the way this started
was I have the worst luck with pulling
from the booster packs. So, I just
started drawing furiously as my villain
origin story. Um, everything looks
really ugly, like you really want that
last five RP from Riot. Um, but I like I
started going to Vegas and I just
literally walked around just asking
people if they wanted one. I got really
lucky that people seemed to like them
and said yes. So, I just kept doing it
and I get they're the ones that are
really spreading the word for me. So,
like I'm just really grateful to the
community and it's so worth it just to
see them smile and laugh about it. Well,
I am definitely one of the people that
smiles and laughs about it because I did
run into you at Vegas and it has been my
mission at every regional qualifier that
I have attended to see if you were there
and if you were giving out tokens. I'm
actually collecting them now and I'm
sure that I'm not the only one. So, with
that in mind, how do you feel about this
particular event?
>> This event, you know, it's only been a
few hours in for me and I'm already
almost out of cards. It's crazy. Like I
I really can't believe how much of I
want to say, you know, like this
positive impact the cars have had
because I think well people just like
free things, but the fact that they're
using them um just for casual play is so
awesome and I think if it can brighten
up anyone's day, then my weekend's been
made. Well, speaking of brightening
days, I also want to call out the fact
that over in the content creator area
where you have been stationed from time
to time. Uh, there are also tokens that
you can color. Can you tell us about
that?
>> Yeah, so I drew these exclusive um
tokens that were also used at Utre and
they're being used for Hartford for uh
gold buff tokens uh in collaboration
with Riot. Shout outs to Diana for
inviting me. Uh, so people can color in
their own tokens and take them home.
I've heard there's plenty to go, so you
can even take more than one.
>> All right. Well, I really appreciate you
taking some time to come and chat with
us, kind of share your story, and I'm
sure that you'll be running out of cards
even faster now, but it's a wonderful
thing that you do for the community. And
uh, I just personally want to thank you
because like I said, I this is not just
for the interview. This is truly me. I
really do hunt glitch at every event to
get one of these tokens. So, thank you
for all that you do.
>> Thank you.
>> Those tokens are super sick.
>> They're awesome. Did you get one?
>> I did. I got a reflection one.
>> I got the bird and the brush on the
other side.
>> Oh, that's
>> Yeah. And the bird the bird is Gallio in
the chicken suit. That's That's the best
part. It's It's so good.
I you know what? I think we should start
a petition. Gallo should be a bird.
That's That's an Ivvern card right now.
I'llow it. Yeah. Okay. He's got wings.
>> That's not my official judge response.
I'llow it right now.
>> Okay. For for you you'll sign the
petition is what you're saying.
>> Correct. Correct. I'll put my name.
We'll work on that.
>> We were however talking about who we
thought was going to win kind of that VI
master matchup.
>> Yep.
>> And we actually don't have to guess
anymore.
>> Yeah. We're going to be able to Yeah,
we're going to be able to jump into game
three of of that matchup. So, I'm super
excited cuz I mean, you thought Master
Yon won.
>> I I thought Master Yi and I would have
assumed a 20, but you It's game three
that we're hopping into. All right,
cool. Well, let's take a look at it
because uh while we're waiting for the
next round feature match, we can catch
up on our secondary feature match from
round number two. Um, now Vai is in my
opinion like a very straightforward
deck. I I haven't seen many different
brews of it. It's just a punch deck,
right? You're just trying to hit hard
and then get off the battlefield
afterwards or gank over and do some more
damage. Yi is a deck that's great at
holding and absorbing punches, which is
why I feel like it would naturally be
side. So, why do you think Vi could take
this?
>> So, Vi has a lot of ways to kind of
>> make might big
number go up.
>> Number go up, brain happy.
>> Oh, yes.
>> And that's what Vi is kind of able to
do, right? We're running cards like
death grip. We're running cards uh like
long sword to kind of surprise our
opponents. Obviously, Falling Star is a
very good card. And in the sideboard, so
we're in game three now, right? We have
cards like Cleave that we can bring in
as well. Salvage to kind of get rid of
anything that that E's kind of using uh
uh best, but we're in game three now
here on a arena's greatest match.
>> All right, let's see what happens as
we're already a couple turns in, it
would seem. Currently, the uh Master E
has a Rengar trophy hunter with a ZAS.
has not played their chosen champion
yet. And then the VI pilot is got a Rex
eye with I think that's the VI sign.
Yep. The hex gauntlets. Really, really
nice uh gear.
>> And as we heard uh Ghost of Fireat
saying they're pondering their triggers
now, right? So you have to pay costs for
Vi to put her on the chain and kind of
figure out what you want to do.
>> Tap V Legend to ready Rexi.
>> And there we go. Yeah. So, we've decided
to we're going to ready the Rex eye by
exhausting our uh our Vi Legend and then
we're going to draw from the uh the
Hexte.
>> And this is the problem that a lot of
these uh fury order decks had is
consistent card draw.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, stuff like Hexte into decks
like E that need to be on battlefields
is a very good way to kind of allow
yourself to draw cards. Make might big
like we said, right? Rex eye with the
assault with the hex tech gauntlets on
top of it. If you can slap a cleave on
there as well, it's a pretty big uh
swing for might. a lot of assault, a lot
of uh ambush, finding great, you know,
efficiency in this type of list. But in
general, it's so straightforward in what
it is trying to accomplish most of the
time that that's one of the weaknesses
of the deck cuz you kind of see it
coming from the master side. And again,
Master very good at holding. So already
eight might defending with this Rex eye
or sorry with this Rengar. And now five
energy up. Let's see what Space King
decides to play.
>> Yeah, I mean there's obviously a few
options here. We haven't even played our
chosen champion just yet, right? So, we
can just take again a development turn.
>> The issue is VI is a pretty quick deck,
right? She likes to go fast. It's an
arena's greatest match, right? So, we
are on even points. Our opponent is on
odd points. So, even if they double
conquer next turn, they're not going to
win on their following turn. So, we can
take a little bit of a pause to develop
if we want to. That being said, Space
King seems like they're making a lot of
decisions based on cards in hand and not
so much that E. But, I did see him kind
of split that rune. He kind of took that
fifth rune and he put it off to the side
and he's kind of looking at those four.
Am I allowed to hold one for a defy
or uh you know on guard? A lot of
different one cost spells here.
Seems like it's going to be developing.
So you mentioning all the different
options you have. You're not in a rush
right now to develop the Yi.
And now with the mastery tempered on the
field,
>> Space King can probably just keep the
Rengar out there and try and hold
Damper's days cuz eight defending really
hard to get through the Rex eye on its
own with the gauntlets will not be
enough. So you kind of force ghost of
fire at to play something else if they
want to conquer and even then the zonas
will keep the reengar alive. So make
your opponent shoot you through
resources. Got
>> charm.
>> She's a six becomes a seven on attack
right now.
>> Oh that's really big.
>> I'll charm her here.
>> Okay.
>> Charm will easily clear out the first
Rex eye. There is a second Rex eye, but
that will make it so that Ghost of
Fireat will have to play something from
hand like a cleave, um, long sword,
something else to actually get over this
Rengar now.
>> Yeah, I think that's what Space King's
kind of debating. And I I like this play
to retreat here from Space King cuz
>> it's already going to be a seven on
attack, right? So, you just need to find
something over. Doesn't have to be a
specific thing. We do see the top deck
long sword. So, you know, hindsight
2020, but also foresight 2020 for Space
King here as he kind of insulates
himself against the uh the Rexai who can
just kind of slap that gauntlet on
almost for free, right? You just recycle
a power cuz it does get uh reduced.
>> Back yellow.
>> Sure, I'll salvage the Zus.
>> Ooh, very nice.
>> Pretty efficient salvage there.
>> For salvage.
>> Also important to note that because
Space King, this is game three, would
have probably seen the long swords at
some point. So you can expect Okay,
that's going to be like a seven
defending Rexi at that point or I guess
a eight defending Rex eye,
>> nine attacking, right?
>> Yeah, we're debating what we want to do
here.
Looks like a lot of cards in hand
actually for Ghost of Fire as well. He's
got full grip.
>> It's always fun getting air dropped into
game states where you're like, yeah,
we're just going to kind of figure it
out as we go
>> and then we get to be in the tank with
ourselves.
>> True. Yeah.
>> So, who would you say in this current
game state without perfect information
is leading?
>> I mean, he goes to six next turn, which
allows him to get a little bit creative.
Uh, it is still just a four might master
Y and a six might Rengar. You don't
really get a huge bonus, but if we don't
take over that Emperor Das, you can do
some funky stuff with, you know,
bouncing your units back to hand as
well. So, I like Ghost of Fire kind of
taking over there.
>> Did you know you don't have to spend an
energy to uh actually have the cost of
returning a unit to hand? You just don't
get the recruit or the the sand soldier
out there then. Yeah.
>> Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. I think I
>> I saw a tweet somebody put on socials
talked about it.
>> Yeah. Somebody I don't know.
>> Yeah.
>> Some guy.
>> You need to pay more attention to the
social media.
>> Sure. You're right.
>> For the record, anybody confused? It was
Grant that
>> Yeah, I was the one who made made the
poster
here.
>> Just want to make sure everyone's caught
up on the the bit we're doing here. All
right. Carry on. Dredger is going to
come down. one might when it dies. You
make the uh reflect to bird token
>> and a hidden card as well. So, looks
like Ghost of Fire's going to try and
hold the Emperor's Deis.
>> Yeah, some options here for the hidden
card as well. Could be Grim apothecary,
could be a hidden blade.
>> There's uh definitely multiple options.
>> A pike as well.
>> Oh, is he not? Oh, no, excuse me. I
think
>> he's an ambush. Yeah, correct. Correct.
Correct. I get him confused with purple
pike occasionally as well. I know purple
pike is hidden or or red pike as well.
Both of them are hidden. But yeah.
Uh, all right. Well, let's see what
Space King wants to do here. Four energy
up, or rather four energy that are in
his hand currently. I imagine that
they're going to be at spent.
>> Two power cost. And there's the action.
Nice.
>> My gauntlets. Now,
>> our gauntlets. Well, you're right. Mine
currently.
>> Well, space kings if we want to be share
about it.
>> We got to share.
>> We'll get our turn.
>> Space King is ready for those Aurora
matchups.
>> Gonna go in. Space King's ahead in
points. So, there's this concept that I
like to talk about when I cast. Uh, I'm
not sure how often you think about this
when you play Riftbound, but it's just
the timer, the natural timer. It's like,
okay, if nothing happens, who wins?
>> I'm I I'm one point ahead. So, if we
just both hold, then Space King would
win. So, I think that Space King kind of
opting into that type of mindset here.
Just saying I'm going to get the
guaranteed point. You can still send
rung guard in. See what that hidden card
is. Um, but prioritizing just getting
the point above all else.
>> Go here. Uh, six tier four pass. Yep.
And focus getting passed. Now we have a
hidden card again.
>> I will reveal Pike. I will pay the extra
cost for plus two on Pike and I'll pass.
Focus.
>> Turns it into a four might.
>> So this is now eight defending on six.
>> Four, five, six, seven, eight. Yeah,
sure.
>> Um I will punch first.
>> Oh, yep.
>> To 11.
>> Oh, he's ready. We have that long sword.
But um do we have anything else that we
can use?
>> Yeah, 10. Long show would put uh Ghost
of Fire at 10.
>> Yeah,
that can resolve and then I'll
>> Oh, Grim.
>> I'll
>> There it is. This would crash everything
just as a unit. Okay. And we'll trade.
>> Oh, very nice. Actually, unless there's
a another pump in the hand for Space
King.
>> 4 5 6 7 8 11.
>> Uh, sure.
>> So, that means Carryon Dreger will also
create that bird token. So, it goes to
fire will have a token. can score
another point. Space King is still
winning the clock. Is still ahead on uh
point tempo and Ghost of Fire's going to
be at five runes to start the turn.
Space King will go back to four. So,
both of them have dramped significantly.
Notably here though, we do have uh our
VI still in the champion zone, so we can
slingshot her in with the bird if we
want to. However, that auction is seven
might, which is a bit awkward because if
we bring the bird up and kill with the
VI, we're still just losing on board.
>> So, a lot of decisions that need to be
made here for the side of Ghost of
Fireat. Uh, obviously, you can go get
that Emperor's Das and you can turn your
bird into a sand soldier to get an extra
might, but then you can't play VI
anymore.
>> Tokens in the tokens.
>> Tokens in the tokens. Correct.
>> Or you could not pay the energy and just
return the bird token to hand.
>> Correct.
Correct.
Don't know why you would do that, but
just I mean listen options. That's the
job of a caster. Just say what they
could do, you know?
>> Correct. Yeah.
>> I've told my friend this before. I was
like the card game is really just a
really really intricate decision tree
where like only maybe 1% of choices are
good.
>> Yeah, you can do a lot of things. Most
of them are bad, but mechanically you
are allowed to. We could just attack
this master with a burst. You're allowed
to do that.
>> That is a legal game. could recycle all
of your energy and pass.
>> Also a legal game action. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> We do have space coming down those
trees, but you know.
>> Yes. I I doubt it.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh they're at a three a two table in
this uh insistent. We're on the desk.
>> True.
>> So
>> I like to remind people why I am at the
desk often.
>> I'll ambush.
>> Oh, he is.
>> No. Ambushing the buy. Okay. We're we're
doing the better decision here. Opting
to trade or take away the master. To
your point earlier, the Axan already
checks this current board.
>> Oh, no. Okay. I was expecting a hidden
card cuz right now Aan just walks into
there and wins, right? Unless I
>> Are we on turns? Don't know how to do
math.
>> 5 minutes.
>> Oh, Ghost of Fire asked, "Are we on
turns?"
>> Judges confirmed. Nope. 5 minutes.
>> We're watching the past right now. Uh,
for anybody tuning in, we're waiting for
round three. But while we're waiting for
that, we're watching this backup feature
match from round two. So, we're catching
just the end of it, but
I'm liking what I'm seeing so far from
Space King in a really good position
here. Four runes up. Can establish
another body if it's in hand.
>> Not going to, just going to pass. if
there's a way for Vi to accelerate like
a maybe another Rex eye with something.
There's no punch first runes available
cuz there's no body for us to recycle if
we're Space King. However, it is nine
that we have to get over, right? Cuz
that uh that uh Aan, excuse me, is going
to get that passive master Ebuff for
defending alone.
>> Uh Falling Star doesn't kill it because
it's at seven. So there's it's a very
awkward number for this VI to deal with.
you you're on order with vice so you
can't do like cold a week but with four
energy up I expect space king will have
a defy or something along those
>> lines call a week is it kind of walk
into defy here
we're thinking on the side of coast uh
ghost of fire excuse me
>> I don't see any um
>> for Fiora
>> two apologies I misspoke a moment ago
with this is round three we're right in
round four there we go in round four
feature match and this is the end of
round three's secondary feature match
And this is kind of a big gamble. Uh if
there's a way for if there's a first
mate for ye, they just win here. But you
got to make them have it, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Challenge the fur.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, that'll do that as well. Yep,
>> that that will do that.
>> That'll do that. So, safe to say there's
no first main.
>> Yeah, cuz otherwise you would expect
that to go down. You don't really need
to deal with the back line. But with
another pass, another four energy up.
Wait to hear. Looked like Space King
heard something from one of the judges.
>> Yeah, they just wanted to make sure that
he recycled for the challenge, I
believe.
>> Sure.
>> Uh make sure you can accidentally
recycle a a calm rune instead of a uh a
body rune, but seems everything's good
there.
>> Uh again, only one body run, so can't
touch first.
>> It's up to salvage.
>> Oh, that's good though.
>> That's big.
>> Salvage your own.
>> Space King in disbelief.
>> I don't think this is getting any better
here. I guess I'll defy it.
So that means that the um cold a week if
it's in hand of ghost fire would be live
>> and it will be an inferno to the dis
conquer bounce called a week.
>> Yep.
>> And then you replay the inferno
>> if we have it. But
>> I mean the fact that ghost to fire rats
>> Yeah. You got it.
>> There it is.
>> Didn't have it. So you were right in the
end. Space King taking it 2-1 against
Ghost of Fireat and advancing to 3 and 0
in our Riftbound regional qualifier here
in Hartford.
>> Not useful.
>> Well fought. Wellought.
>> I almost got there.
>> Yeah, close.
>> Like hearing the players talk with each
other as well. Seems like they're still
in good spirits. Space King undefeated
>> going three and 0 into round four
playing the Master U. Are you a Y
believer? A lot of people uh are are
kind of hyping it up, but then going
into this event we're like ah after Utre
like no it's not going to be this play.
So like where are you on the master hype
train?
>> I think it's a very and I
>> you need to choose my words carefully
here. I think it's a very simple deck.
>> Ah
>> right
>> because it's a very simple deck. It's a
very popular deck. That doesn't mean
it's not a deck that you can show player
agency or do some intricate lines
especially with cards like you know
Rengar Pouncing. But it is a deck that
you I can give to someone who's played
very few games of Riftbound and even
zero games of Riftbound. Say, "Hey, have
fun."
>> Exactly. I feel like uh the way I
describe decks like that is that there's
a a floor, a skill floor for a deck of
like how good you have to be to know
what's going on. And then there's a
skill ceiling of like if you spend a lot
of time on the deck, how good can you
get with it compared to people that
don't know how to play the deck? And the
skill floor and the skill ceiling of
Master Yi, the floor is pretty high. I
think the ceiling's also pretty high as
opposed to a deck like Aurora where I
feel like the floor is like really high
and the ceiling is like a little like
there is skill expression of course um
but that's probably the closest in the
floor to ceiling. Yei is going to be
maybe second closest in like the floor
to the ceiling how close that is just
like here try the deck out versus how
good can you get at it cuz the skill
expression really comes in in sequencing
and countering your opponents and
knowing your matchups and what you need
to counter on your opponent's field.
>> That's a lot of riftbound in general,
right? is just knowing
>> what your deck wants to do and then do
making sure you can do that, right? I
think every deck in Riftbound is very
easy to play when you could just do what
you need to do, right? When your deck
does the thing, it's not very difficult.
>> If you're playing against uh an empty
chair, it turns out you can pull off all
your combos and do a lot of cool stuff.
>> Exactly. But if you're playing against
players who are interrupting you and
kind of making unfavorable board states,
that's where you have to get creative.
And like you mentioned with Aurora, if
you don't see your Aurora, you know,
we've seen, you know, Swag Yolo 420 get
very creative with how he's going to use
his civer chosen champion, kind of get
around and create an advantageous board
state. So if and when he does find the
Aurora, it's not too late.
>> Yeah, exactly. Um but yeah, I I do like
E as one of those decks to be like,
yeah, it's it's on a lot of people's
radars for how good it is, but also if
you're looking to get into Riftbound,
check out Mastery. It's a very fun deck
to play. I'd say really anything that's
in the proven grounds box. I mean, maybe
not Lux because Lux is a little
complicated in terms of how you a lot of
the current builds are winning with it,
but funny to think that now um three out
of four of the uh the legends in Proving
Grounds like are doing well at regional
qualifiers.
>> I think I saw that all of our Proving
Grounds legends except for Garen. I
haven't seen Garen, but I think all of
them are three and at this point out
when's Garren going to show up? We got
to get some Garen love. I'm going to do
a little shout out because I have a
local from from Montreal who's here
whose name is Garen and he's playing
Gar.
>> Like government name is Garen.
>> Government name is Garen and he's
playing Garen. So
>> Well, we got to give him the best of
just by default, right?
>> Just by default. Yeah. Just just hand it
to him. Yeah.
>> Well, Garen's one of the tough ones to
get the best of though because a lot of
people go assuming it's usually towards
the bottom of like the deck population.
So then a lot of people are like, "Oo,
if I win a best of, I'm going to go for
Garen." Um, so is he on the Aurora build
or is he playing a
>> Oh, he's playing a real Garen.
>> An ethical Garen. Let's go.
>> Yeah, ethical Garen. Yeah,
>> that's awesome. All right. Well, that's
enough from us. I'm hearing that we are
ready with an interview from Oh, wait.
Sorry. No interview from that last one.
Okay, we're going to take a look at the
standings instead. All right, let's
update everybody on what's going on
right now. A lot of three's in the
field. We see Allan EQ there cracking
into the top 10. Um, left
>> HL at Lilia.
>> Oh. Oh, yes. If I if it's the same HXL
as I think that is another Montreal
local who is uh who is up there at the
top of the standing
>> man. You Canadians pretty good at Shadow
of my people.
>> Yeah, let's go. And do you think that um
HXL also says Leblon?
>> He does. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay, cool. I'm going to test that
later just to make sure.
>> Okay, perfect.
>> Um yeah, obviously a lot of three 0's
still, but we're seeing a lot of Diana
on that list. That's like the big one.
Uh there's one Mastery at least, not the
one that we just saw, but um what are
other surprises here? Draven. Okay, a
Draven 3 and 0.
>> Kha'Zix 3 and0 as well. Shout out Josh.
>> Shout out Josh out Colin K. Still
committed to the set. Seen him in many
Riftbound regionals performing well on
that champion. Bit of a pet deck for
him. And uh Okay, there's a Kai'Sa and
Azir.
>> Kai'Sa from our, you know, our set one
deck to beat.
>> Yep.
>> And now we have a Vex also who's 3 in
one there at the bottom at 30th. And
going in here, we have this is where
we're start seeing, you know, the
Dravens, the Fiora, we have a Lein who
is 3 and 0 as well. Uh Troy's doing
really well. They're at 36 currently.
And again, we're still seeing the Diana
and you know, Master's kind of sprinkled
in there. Y so not to not too surprising
in that in that aspect. But another
Kha'Zix there at the at the bottom at 3
and 0 as well. And then here we have a a
bit more, you know, a Jax.
>> Okay, Jax is interesting. Yes, some more
Rengar. Uh still pretty much every
single one of these we've seen at least
a Diana if not multiple. Um Lindsanity
as well piloting that one. Um so a lot
of uh a lot of Diana I think that is
going to be just gut. I obviously this
isn't every 3 that we're going to be
able to get through I imagine but this
is at least a lot of Diana in the
undefeated category still.
>> Yeah. And as the day continues right
that might you know shrink a little bit
right as they start dropping games. This
just is how math works, right? You have
so many people playing and Diana, not
all of them are going to be undefeated
because that's not how tournaments work.
>> And as you continue undefeated, you're
going to be against better and better
and better and better opponents cuz
you're going up against other undefeated
opponents. So then your matchups get a
little skewed. Start the Diana start
getting the mirror matches then and
those uh Oh, I pity anybody else to go
through a Diana mirror match. That's a
very complex match.
>> You need a break for that one. Yeah.
Yeah. Get some get some coffee in you
before and after.
>> It's a double. It's a double. you needed
some water, a little break afterwards.
>> Um, so yeah, I mean, round three was
very,
>> um, I like the two decks that we had on,
two games, excuse me, that we had on
stream. We kind of showed two very
different play styles, right? We had a
kind of ye mid-range hold deck versus
the Vi, I want to kind of come at you
aggro deck, and then we had the Leblanc
quote unquote unfair hook deck that had
to go up against the uh, Aurora, also
unfair deck, right? So, like we had two
unfair decks and then two very, you
know, ethical, fair riffbound decks that
were playing against each other. So, it
was a it was a fun little fun little
round. I I love how you're trying to
equate Baited Hook with Aurora in terms
of like Shane. They're both gears. They
both play units. You're right. You're
right on those accounts. All right. I'm
hearing that we're ready for our round
four feature match though preview. So,
let's take a look at what we have uh for
round four. We have up first. Ooh, a
pikelist. Oo, I like this. And this
looks like it's kind of pike control,
right? We have the bewitching spirit in
there which is a staple in most pike
decks where you know you can just play
that force your opponent to discard a
card get that on a battlefield and then
with your blood harbor ripper legend
ability you bring that back to hand you
have you know emperor disas in your
legend zone which is obviously fun. Uh
and then beast below being the other
kind of control pack in this where it
operates as you know a big gust right
where you're kind of bouncing a unit
back to your opponent's hand and you're
also using it to bounce one of yours.
>> Exactly.
>> Interesting. And you have a lot, you
already mentioned the bewitching spirit,
but also things like classic fizz. This
is one that you love to be able to
bounce back either through your legend
ability or through uh the beast below as
well as Ezreal. So really, really nice
tools. Even things like a Brin here,
thundersong in the main deck is
something that if you're able to loop
that multiple times, that can be really
annoying for an opponent to deal with.
>> Yeah, and this is very much a punish you
to do anything kind of pike list, right?
because we do have uh cards like one of
downwell also in the main deck.
>> I love downwell. That's one of my one of
my favorite spells I've ever read. It's
so cool. Return return all units and
gears to their owner's hand. So if you
liked ruination, but you're like ah it
doesn't deal with Aurora. Well, at least
down wall will slow them down a little
bit longer. Yeah. And the backpack. A
lot of people are playing, you know,
pack of wonders in Pike, Pike of Wonders
in Ezreal even and kind of doing this
control. I'm just going to continue
playing stuff that's very annoying with
when you play me. Did you mean to say
Pike of Wonders? Because that's a great
>> Did I say Pike of Wonders?
>> No, I mean own it. That's awesome. We're
gonna call it that now. Pike Pike of
Wonders. That's his
>> That's his backpack.
>> That's his backpack. Yeah. Return
another friendly gear unit or hidden
card to its owner's hand. Um, this is
what Pike wants to do anyway. You want
to be looping these like onplay effects.
So, this is kind of another way to do
that.
>> Yeah, this is a very interesting list.
Uh, it allows you to get very creative
with how you want to to fight. And he's
going to be playing against
>> Mr. Pandawan.
>> Okay.
>> Was on Le Aurora.
>> Lein Aurora. So, anybody deck has access
to Aurora plus Elder Dragon plus
mobilize plus Catalyst. And uh that's
pretty much the only orange that you're
going to see here outside the sabotages
and I guess flurry of blades as well.
But when you pair it with uh the calm
domain, typically this would be like a
master y that you see this with. But le
still has access to the same tricks. get
the counter spells, things like defy,
not so fast. Um, discipline as well to
buff up your units, help you draw. Uh,
and then speaking of draw power, even
things like back off helping you out in
in that regard. Uh, and this is a very
low unit list. It's just the elder
dragons and uh, two vile moths, only
five units total.
>> Yeah. So, I'm going to push my
proverbial glasses up to my forehead
here.
>> He's physically doing it for anybody
wondering at home. He he put his finger
on his between his eyebrows. As I look
at Aurora lists, I always like to see
what's different.
>> Okay, so here we're running, like you
mentioned, five units. Why are we
running le, right? Le allows us to buff
a friendly unit. So you can make really
weird break points where vioma
specifically putting him at nine might,
which means that anything that attacks
into you that's less than nine might
just does nothing,
>> right?
>> The le centered champion also allows you
to accelerate if you need to, but also
you can just put them on a battlefield
with your other buffed units and then
they're getting plus two. So now that
Vile is 11 might
>> which is crazy.
>> And notably we have three deserts call
in the deck as well.
>> So this allows us to on turn two play a
sand soldier or on turn sorry on turn
one play sand soldier or on turn two
play two sand soldiers and still use
that le to buff them. And we have three
might units that we can swing around as
well.
>> If you're going second you can just play
one and then buff it immediately that
turret. So you get some flexibility
there. All right, I'm hearing that we're
ready to hop in to the game here
shortly. So, Le Aurora, let's see if
it's enough to take on Pike. Pike as a
deck has a lot of ways to, you know,
return units on the field back to the
opponent's hand. So, I it's not like a a
terrible matchup, I would have to
imagine, for the Pike because you can
just use things like your Beast Below to
clear out that Elder Dragon as soon as
it hits the field.
>> Yeah, the Elder Dragon can get bounced
pretty quickly. You have the Star Cross
in the main deck as well for Pike. Also
notably, Vioma, if it's creating an
awkward board state for you, you could
get rid of that as well.
>> Yeah, but not so fast is in the main
deck here for Leon for Mr. Panda.
I, you know, props for the name. I'll
give you some credit there, Mr. Panda.
Game one for round four of Swiss
underway here. Not so fast in the main
deck. Not a lot of people are kind of
anticipating that. So, that's going to
be able to check a lot of what Aggressia
is going to have to answer. Yeah, we've
seen not so fast kind of fall off in
terms of its play rate a little bit, but
I do think that is obviously it is a
very good uh card here in the matchup.
Also, Aggressia has the ability to force
discards, right, depending on what we
have in our hand. So, the best way to
deal with Aurora is to make sure they
can't play an Aurora or have no cards in
hand or put their units in the trash,
right? So, all of that can be done with
Bewitching Spirit. So, Agressia is most
likely
>> looking to find that in their opening
hand here
>> as uh let's see. I didn't catch who was
going first here.
>> Good luck.
>> Looks like it's our Leen who's going
first.
>> Okay, fist bump comes in. Maroons are
channeled. Mr. Panda one will start the
game.
>> His cards are also upside down. Oh,
there we go. We fixed it. And there's
the turn mobilized. So,
>> yep.
>> You only need Okay, perfect.
>> It looks like there's another one in
hand, too. And is that a catalyst? I see
as well. I think Yeah, we got we got
mobilizing to catalyst.
>> Oh, there's the bewitching spirit off
the stack deck.
>> Can't play it this turn cuz now we've
already played the stack deck, but could
play a two energy unit.
>> Yep.
>> Let's see if he has one. Yep, there's
the traveling merchant.
>> Old reliable is what I like to call him.
Well, I I think it's so I talk about
this a lot with uh two energy units. I
think traveling merchant arguably one of
the best turn ones that you can get.
Maybe that and like irresistible faith
folk would be like the best ones. Um but
drawing it later in the game doesn't
feel as good. You know, it's like if you
draw this on turn five, you're like,
"Ooh." Um whereas like a tide turner,
you're still pretty happy to see it on
turn five, even not the best in turn
one. But if you can get that merchant
out immediately feels really good.
>> I will attempt to go to the Monastery of
Hondurana. Move trigger. I'll discard a
pack of wonders to draw a card.
Uh, I'd like to score.
>> Yep, that's good.
>> You got it. One to zero.
>> Point scored there from Aggression. And
now five energy still up.
>> I'll play a
Trying to decide where to play the
spirit here. Looks like for Aggressia,
>> I imagine you go into the
>> spirit over here.
>> Oh, not into the the base. Okay.
>> Uh, discard a card.
>> At this point, you if you need to, you
can bring it back to your hand if you're
scared of an Aurora hitting an Elder
Dragon, right? You can now that it's out
of battlefield, you can use your pike to
bounce that back to your hand.
Unfortunately, you only have one left uh
afterwards. So, you can't replay it, but
at least it's safe in your hand away
from that elder dragon
>> expose. Yeah,
>> different plans.
>> A pack of wonders and I'll
>> that also works.
>> Yeah, similar,
>> but not using it to bounce the spirit.
So, kind of giving we're insulating now
a little bit against that elder dragon
cuz if it does come in, we kill one of
our units, we still get our second
point.
>> That's a good point. the fact that Elder
can only target one thing at a location
>> as Mr. Pandawan does not have the Aurora
on curve which means it will just be the
le centered going in
>> with the buff from the le blind monk
legend.
>> Yep.
>> Spend the buff to draw.
>> There it is. Yep.
>> Four, five, six, seven, eight. We're
looks like we're on
>> Yeah. eight runes now. So, still on
Aurora for next turn. I don't hate this
at all. you don't know that he has
Aurora in his hand, right? So, this is a
play that doesn't damp you past getting
Aurora if you do manage to draw it, but
now gives you board presence where
otherwise, you know, you're just letting
your opponent go to two and there's a
way for them to just kind of have fun
with that Bewitching Spirit, right? Cuz
they can use Pike, play it, use Paco,
play it again, and now you just lost two
more cards in your hand.
>> And I'm just confirming uh that Elder
Dragon in the trash, I believe, was
discarded off of the Spirit. I I imagine
from the last turn, cuz otherwise it
would just be mobilizing the catalyst.
That means one elder uh used. I don't
know if this deck, this version has many
ways to get your units back once they're
all kind of spent here. So, might
actually be significant that that Elder
Dragon was discarded from hand and no
longer available. A lot of counter
spells in Mr. Pandawan's hand though.
There's not as fast. There's a I think a
discipline and a define.
>> I'll pack and I'll replay the spirit.
>> Nice.
>> This is
>> very good. This is where you're going to
kind of win.
>> If you can just rip all the cards out of
their hand and only have to deal with
El, that's totally fine. I think
>> I don't know if we mulligan the death
from below, but I know that the opening
hand from Aggressia had a death from
below in it, which is just kill multiple
things if they're three or three might
or less or just kill something.
>> Kill one thing at a battlefield. Yeah.
>> Yep.
We do have the desert's call for Mr.
Panda. So, we're going to find your
center here first. see what we can draw.
>> And then we can still develop these sand
soldiers uh if our hand bricks a little
bit, which seems to be the case if we
have just double defy.
>> Yeah. And this is the downside of Aurora
deck is sometimes you just don't see it.
When you do see it, it feels so good. So
impressive to play against, but if it
never shows up,
>> it's going to be tough. That's two sand
soldiers at least.
And this is what non chaos Aurora decks
I feel like need need to really focus on
is because you don't have the amount of
dig that chaos has you have to figure
out ways to not just auto lose if you
don't see it right so cards like
Desert's Call and even this you know Le
bringing it back protecting it
>> it's very important for them to kind of
keep some board presence to at least
continue to challenge as they dig for
the Aurora for
>> yeah and it's part of reasons why in
some of these other non- chaos lists
even Poppy can pull it off to an extent
like like the the order list but seen
flurry blades still in there. Sometimes
you opt instead for more things that can
dig you into your deck or just uh useful
spells cuz even like flurry of blades
now kind of a dead draw for Mr.
Pandawan. But
>> there's aggressia going in.
>> Here comes the spirit.
>> We can trigger this multiple times cuz
the spirit's going to come in from the
pike ability. Replay it. Pack of wonders
is still available as well.
>> Yeah, we're going to pack it. Replay it.
Looks like I'll pack the spirit.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. Here we go.
>> Many people have experienced this
already. The difficulty of not having a
single card in your hand. It looks like
I think that's only a not so fast. It
was uh kept from Mr. Vandan,
>> which is good cuz you can't defy the
death room below, but you can not so
fast it. But we're going to develop
another reliable and uh all of a sudden,
you know, your opponent has two cards in
hand when they draw for their turn. you
have four might and they have you know
seven plus the four they have you know
11 might but you have so much of a I
think there's a falling star in the hand
for aggressi as well so a lot of options
here
>> uh for the next turn
>> three points
>> another one that you cannot so fast but
cannot defy
>> and looking at death from below you
actually uh it is a four energy one
power cost so is defiable but
>> it isable but not also checks it so
that's I think the the bigger thing is
that it doesn't really quite matter uh
not can cover more options like the
units that bounce things specifically
that beast from below.
>> Yes, that is a unit all pun intended. It
is a it is a big
>> What would you rather run into? Death
from below or the beast from below. I
>> feel like one's guaranteed. The other
one's at least like he got a shot,
right?
>> Yeah, I think I'd rather run into the
beast from below.
>> Maybe he's a chill guy.
>> Yeah, maybe he's a nice guy.
>> All right, there it is. What do we
think, Chad? Is that a chill guy right
there?
>> Is he a chill guy?
>> I you know I think he's actively in the
uh action of eating a full ship.
>> But maybe
maybe they're bad people on the ship.
>> Maybe they were like Yeah, maybe they
were being rude and he's just telling
them off like, "Hey guys, no, maybe he's
defending his friend. Maybe his kids
back there and they were like throwing
straws at him or something."
>> Yep. And I mean, Master Panda now is
going to try to find some more cards so
he can defend his lease in because uh
this is
>> not a great position to be in being only
at four points. True.
>> So, not actually electing to spend the
buff it looks like to draw with
Monastery Fernata and just going to kind
of hang out with three cards uh in hand
here and uh try to just fight soldier.
>> I mean, if even if you get into that
Aurora, if you don't have enough cards
in your hand to kind of insulate, I
mean, there are three, so maybe getting
to fourth could have worked. Oh, not so
fasting the gust.
>> Yeah, wants to keep four might on that
battlefield because if you let that get
gusted now, forbidding waste is going to
make it a free battlefield to conquer.
It's like there's no unit there to be to
begin with.
>> So, good not so fast here. And it looks
like an elder dragon in hand for Mr.
Pandawan, unfortunately, and something
else that is tucked away behind it. So,
again, not the ideal two cards to have
in your hand.
>> Yeah, I will say if you're not going to
see the Aurora, an ethical Elder Dragon
is still an Elder Dragon. It's on the
field. that's representing a big threat,
but the problem being if you draw that
Aurora the next turn, um you're going to
be like gh
>> feels a little bad.
>> Yeah, it feels a little bad. Especially
we've already gone through one of them.
So that means that there's we know in
the deck list now one elder in deck with
two vile mods in deck.
>> Yeah, there's a falling star. Keep in
mind though, we have enough to play two
bewitching spirits.
Okay.
>> So, I think what we're going to say
three,
>> pack it back or sorry, bounce it back
with the pike,
>> then pack it back when you play it
again.
>> Wow, another gold.
>> No more cards in hand for Mr. Panda, it
looks like.
>> Yep. Welcome to Pike Shenanigans,
everybody.
Tough deck to play against. That means
Panda will not even have that elder
play. deciding between the Oh, actually
discarding the elder and saving
>> the back off. I mean, it probably
doesn't really matter. Yeah.
>> So, no more ethical elder dragon.
>> No ethical dragon,
>> but this lease in putting in work,
right? The lease in champion unit has
gotten him, I think, all his points
except for the one that we got on
forbidding waste with the sand soldiers
last turn. So, we're able to kind of at
least
>> try to grind through it. We draw the
sabotage. Cards in hand are useless
against Pike, right? They're they're
going to get hit pretty quick. So get
rid of it. You got rid of the star
cross. You know there's a 4runner so you
can kind of play around that. And now
you're going to pull back a little bit.
You have a ton of runes. So you're in
top deck mode. But now Vwitching spirit
doesn't really it's not a good bounce
target anymore. Right.
>> No. At this point you're just going to
use it as a body to get points. You've
fulfilled the function of the spirit.
That 4errunner is going to look really
nice. And what was that card drawn? It
looks like a tide turner. Okay.
And now I like this from Aggressia just
denying the potential draw from the
monastery cuz that's one of the big outs
from Mr. Pandawan is if you're able to
get that le in and then spend the buff
to draw a card. Aggressia saying nope
I'm not going to give you an easy path
there. Tieer is nice cuz you're at no
cards in hand. So when this uh merchant
moves you can discard nothing and draw
the one card.
>> I'll draw.
>> Efficiency. Very efficient.
>> Score five.
>> Yep.
>> In a world where you had a second card
in hand. I wouldn't have hated seeing
tide uh traveling merchant get moved to
that forbidding waste hiding the tide
turner there.
>> I'll draw two
>> so that if he does attack you bring the
forerunner over get rid of the passive
for forbidding waste and it's eight to
the seven.
>> Unfortunately it just didn't quite work
out mathwise but this is nice too. The
Ezreal also discards nothing and then
>> and draws a bunch of cards
>> gets you two cards in hand. So a very
efficient turn here from Aggressia.
>> I'll hide a card.
>> I wonder what it is.
Go ahead. Currently has a five to five.
>> One card and one card only for Mr. Mr.
Panda now has to make uh
>> I mean something happen here.
>> If he drops the Aurora and then that
plays into the Elder, that would be
crazy. But based on how long it's
taking, I imagine it is not Aurora.
>> Yeah. Would be a windmill slam. I think
if it was
>> that would be an anime moment there.
>> Six points. But again, still at six
points. Hasn't seen Aurora, but managed
to kind of scrape together six points.
And notably, we can't win on our next
turn if we're aggressive, right? We're
on odd points.
>> Going to hide a card.
>> Wa.
>> Looks like maybe a back off.
>> I would imagine cuz you it might feel
weird to do that because that can draw
you a card if you play it from hand. But
>> if you're expecting that, you're just
going to lose your hand anyway.
>> The spirit is gone. I don't think that
was that one bounce in hand. Oh, it is.
Okay. Okay. am
falling star.
>> Ooh, this is good.
>> The Ezreal will theoretically check it.
We're I'm expecting a back off as the
hidden card here.
>> I'll come in here. Uh the forbidden
waste will kill your yeast.
>> Oh, that actually is uh the the function
here.
>> You don't have a window to react.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yep. I don't want to say anything. I
wanted to give that moment to Aggressia,
but I I saw the line and I'm very happy
that we're using our battlefields to
their fullest potential there.
>> So, for those of who don't understand
why that happens is we've marked six
damage on a seven might unit
>> and forbidding waste is a passive effect
while a unit's defending here alone,
it'll get
>> trigger.
>> Correct. So the the game will apply the
minus two effect to the lease in and now
that it has damage marked equal or
greater to in this case than it might it
just dies in that in that cleanup before
the showdown begins.
>> You'd have to chain the zonas to the
falling star in order to protect the le
in that instance. But even from that
position I feel like aggressia was
dominating the board state. Mr. Handawan
had the ideal uh like kind of rune ramp
but was not able to actually find
>> for me. Yeah.
>> Aurora.
>> I'm so used to everything just being on
that side.
>> And like we saw right there was threats
in hand, but when you're playing against
Pike, you got to get those threats out
as fast as you can or else you're going
to end up in your trash.
>> And that's like what the the positive of
the uh the order side with body uh
Aurora builds is that you have the
counter spells. You have things like
defy, not so fast. Um, even you know
like discipline can be nice to help you
with your numbers, but you don't have
the ability to dig into your deck that
Chaos provides you. Uniquely terrible
into Pike because he's not going to
spend a lot of spells to get rid of your
entire hand.
Yeah.
>> So, uh, really tough match up here for
Mr. Panda.
>> Like, I'm good on your runes as long as
you shuffled them. Same.
>> A little sportsmanship here from both
players as they're setting up here for M
uh, game number two, excuse me. And
again, this is the aspirin game, so we
can go a bit longer.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay, cool.
>> But again, Aggressia is a deck that runs
a downwell. So if you get to a point
where you've played all your units and
your Auroras are in play and they down
well you
>> kind of a hard reset reset button,
excuse me, a little bit for both
players.
>> Again, I feel like the Pike deck is
naturally decent into Mr. Manawan. And
that does look like a spirit in hand.
That's such a good
>> Yeah, that's that's a really
>> And we drew our down.
>> Wow. Um
>> playing second. This is a phenomenal
hand for uh
>> and no mobilize. No mobilize for Mr.
Panawan. So not the ideal start. There
are catalysts in hand, but that is not
going to be the ramp for the dazzling
Aurora. And the first spirit lands.
>> Yeah, one catalyst is going to get
thrown away. Kind of a no-brainer here
when you have two of them in your hand.
It's a dragon it looks like perhaps that
we just draw drew off the top if we're
Mr. Panda. So again, we're just trying
to find this Aurora and at the very
worst case, we'll bring that le in like
we did in game one and try to uh try to
get ourselves some points.
>> Yep.
>> And now the spirits going in to get that
first. Imagine that it'll just be
looped.
>> Uh yes,
>> is just making sure you're on six. I'll
put a
>> here
>> knowing that the Aurora wouldn't come
down next turn anyway. Placing the Vex
to the battlefield so that way the
accelerated Le can't come in and start
scoring points.
>> Yeah, this lets you also kind of uh
play and bounce your Bewitching Spirit
next turn instantly, right? Cuz you're
going to most likely unless they, you
know, just they can't accelerate the
lease in cuz Vex will stun it, right? So
your Vex is more pretty safe here.
>> Yeah. And then next turn you can just if
you want to you could double Bewitching
Spirit and then bring the Vex back.
>> Yeah, I'm not seeing an Aurora in hand.
That looks like an elder dragon. Find
your center comes down.
>> I'll hold the two.
>> And now we get to see Pike do Pike
things as uh the cards in hand for Mr.
Pandawan are not safe.
>> Mr. Panda opted to not use the uh Le
Blind Monk Legend to buff one of these
sand soldiers. So I imagine trying to I
guess bluff a defy or something. I mean
looking at the hand it doesn't look like
there's a one energy card. I think I saw
immobilize.
>> I think I saw an unyielding. Yeah.
>> Oh okay. Okay. Sure. That actually could
be very valuable then.
>> Yeah. Just keeping one of those sand
soldiers alive might be very worth it in
this especially since we're not seeing
our Aurora.
And it looks like Yeah, we're going to
bounce it back. Replay it. Business as
usual so to speak for Pike.
>> Mhm.
>> Back.
>> And we're probably going to bring that
Vex home. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You have to imagine otherwise the
sand soldiers could just crash. Then
Leon could come down.
>> Mr. Padawan's in a tough spot here.
Discarding the Elder Dragon.
>> Go ahead.
>> We'll get on the board here for Mr.
>> Pan. Correct.
>> Sounds good to me.
>> And let's see what that card drawn was.
Maybe another dis. No, defy.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, we got a defy discipline and um the
uh
>> unyielding spirit.
>> Unyielding spirit. There we go. Yeah.
Thank you.
>> Notably now since Vex is back home.
>> Okay. Well, looks like we're fishing
naturally, which
>> Oh, and that would have been great if it
was a catalyst would have drawn us a
card, but we do have one rune that we
haven't channeled yet. So, if we
mobilize,
>> yeah, nothing really happens. It's just
something to insulate against all the
discards in hand. Leon will establish
onto the board and we'll get a buff.
>> Yeah, get a little buff on him.
>> I go.
>> Yep.
>> And now Mr. Panda's in that position
where because the Elder Dragon was
discarded earlier, you don't even have
that play on the next turn. That's where
sometimes I feel like if you haven't
seen the Aurora, just hold the Elder
Dragon cuz eventually you can just slam
it.
>> Yeah.
>> But again, this is an Aspirants game.
We're at two points.
>> Sure.
>> We're still in that early game.
>> A lot of rift bounce to be played for
this one.
>> Now it's dangerous obviously putting
your Vex on the battlefield.
>> Uh bounce and then uh thinking on the
channel.
>> Okay. So, we're going to ponder on this
rippers bay
>> and we're going to use the rippers bay
ability.
>> Yeah. When a unit returns back to your
hand, you can
>> three cards in hand. pay an entry cost
to a uh channel a rune exhausted
>> which was double dip.
>> Yeah, a little bit.
>> Exactly.
>> You're ramping more on Aggressia side
and because of the um aspirin's climb,
you don't need to be on the even point
number right now. So, you're not
pressured to send that Vex in
regardless. I wouldn't be surprised if
Aggressia just decides to pass here.
Maybe play another unit.
>> How about another spirit?
>> How about another spirit? How about it?
>> How about it? Now, we have one card in
hand, which was
>> immobilize. So, because it's next turn,
Mr. Panda can use it to or Panda Wan can
use it to at least draw an additional
card.
>> Correct. Unless we top deck the Aurora.
>> No, it looks like a flurry. So, we're
going to draw the Aurora now.
>> Does he have them in the deck is now the
question on my mind.
>> He looks a lot of cards up the deck
list. Is it there?
>> It is in the deck. Yes.
But that's the thing again with non
chaos aurora decks is you see a normal
amount of cards.
>> Exactly.
>> Right. You don't have stuff like stack
deck or bloom or lunar bloom
>> and all these cards that just say, "Hey,
you don't like what you have in your
hand? Great. Let's put more cards in
there.
>> Let's get different options." Instead,
you're operating with a couple of sand
soldiers and a lease in right now, which
will get Mr. Pandawan on the board and
at least scoring some points. But
Aggressia just has so much card
advantage right now. And the issue with
playing against fury decks when you have
these sand soldiers is they get
obliterated by falling star.
>> Yeah.
>> And we know that there spirit in hand
>> fizz in the deck if I'm not mistaken.
Yes, there's a fizz in the deck. So you
can technically falling star falling
star and just get rid of all those.
>> Yeah, you speak my language.
>> I mean we have three gold. It's not
going to cost us that much.
>> True.
>> It's like a stack deck probably.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Going to dig a little more. Both
players full ramp on their runes.
>> Let's see what Pike's able to do here.
It's such a unique deck in how it wants
to approach the game. Really, no other
deck is doing what Pike is doing. And
that something I love to see decks pull
off is like, hey, check out what makes
my deck unique, what makes my legend
unique. This looping of your units to
make your opponent just have no cards in
hand.
>> You're not putting out big bodies as the
pike. You're just kind of hoping that
your card advantage will [ __ ] your
opponent over time
>> and make it so that they can't really uh
do much in the game.
>> Flurry. Sure.
>> Yeah, we're going to do the pike. The
pike special, right? Bounce spirit. Play
the spirit.
>> So many cards in hand right now for
aggressi. There's a lot of different
options. Yeah, we're going to
continuously try to go up by two. Keep
on that odd point so we can close out
the game when we're at seven. And we're
going to star cross here. It looks like
>> make him kind of commit for that uh
>> that. Oh, that's very nice because yeah,
now we can just replay the spirit le
that's a
>> get rid of le. Yeah,
>> essentially removal, right?
>> What a card that combination
>> with uh the spirit and the star cross.
Usually think of star cross with like oh
fizz. Crazy combo with fizz. Well, how
about you get rid of the guard, you just
bounce back to your opponent's hand cuz
you've already cleared out their entire
hand of anything else.
>> Yeah, it's a really rough spot uh for Le
and we drew discipline. So, we get to
look at another card. I'm going to
discipline. Discipline. Sure.
>> I'm not sure what we took off the stack
deck, but I did see a fading memories on
the first three.
>> Okay.
>> So, if we did take that, the Aurora is
only going to trigger once if we do end
up finding it. Uh, it looks like it's
Yeah. So, we're going to go to seven
next turn and then it's kind of we're in
the danger zone if we're Aurora player.
>> It would appear Mr. Panda has one more
turn to try and find that Aurora.
>> Tough tough situation to be in in
feature match. You're undefeated so far
in the tournament at 3 and 0, but you
just don't see Aurora two games in a
row. That would be brutal
>> for the lease in Violet.
>> Oh, it was the fading. I see the fading
in the hand right now. Yeah.
>> Also, very interesting that we're seeing
Mr. Panawan not move those sand
soldiers.
>> Yeah, I I would have expected at least
the two that don't have the buffs to
move up.
>> Yeah, just make it inconvenient. Oh,
this this is a great downall turn, I
think. Oh, this is a phenomenal downall
turn. Yes. Yeah. Doesn't really matter.
>> Uh I'll float four gold.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, cuz we're going to lose those
anyway with the down well
>> cuz then you just get the zonas out with
the bewitching spirit anyways.
>> Here it is.
>> Yeah, this how you just lock out the
game. Now, if you're uh if you're pike,
>> you're going to play another spirit, get
rid of that zonas. The only thing you
don't have right now on aggressi side is
a second uh body to get the uh the
conquer, but it looks like uh a little
spoilers there. uh just takes it. Uh
>> I go
>> fist bump. There we go. That makes a
little more sense. Mr. Panawan extends a
fist bump. Says, "Yeah, this game's
over."
>> Did not see Aurora in two games in a
row.
>> Oh jeez.
>> But I mean, like we saw in game one,
right?
>> We're able to get up to six points.
>> Yeah.
>> Just with our chosen champion, right?
We're Yes. discarding everything because
of those bewitching spirits, but we were
able to kind of claw back into the game,
but unfortunately not finding what you
need to find in this situation. Aurora
in a deck that doesn't utilize it that
well in Le, right? It's a it's a
different take on it.
>> We saw get punished a little bit there.
>> I'd say a big part of that is the
matchup. Uh Pike's not great at holding,
especially against like a seven might
like the Le once he gets that buff on
him. But, uh the converse is that Aurora
Le's a very slow deck that's not going
to be doing very much. So Pike also
benefits from the matchup because your
little two might units going in. I mean,
they're able to score and then they're
able to rip out your opponent's hand and
like that Le was really the only threat
at any given time. And once you have the
Vex apathetic, it's like even that
Leon's not that scary anymore. So I
would imagine that the Pike pilot was
like, "Oh, I'm against Aurora Le. Yeah,
let's get some work done cuz this is
going to be one of the better matchups
for Pike. I played against Pike at my
locals and I play a lot of aggro decks.
I played against Pike as Jinx and I'm
like, "Sweet. you're just going to give
me two draws every turn. And the Pike
was like, "Oh, this is a bad matchup."
But then they go up against like an
Aurora deck next and they're like,
"Thank you. And now I can like rush down
and actually win a matchup." So
>> yeah, I I like you mentioned earlier,
I'm kind of the villain. I like these
control decks. I like these decks that
kind of make my opponent unable to
execute their strategy. So I don't know,
watching more and more Pike.
>> I might be sle up a Pike game at home.
>> Okay.
>> Not sure. Pike is one of those ones
where I I think it's uh it can be
frustrating sometimes when that loop
comes out and you lose your entire hand,
but it doesn't happen every game. And
even if it is happening, again, it's
like a two might unit your opponent's
putting out there. So, if you're able to
just get out your stuff from your hand
fast enough and just have a better board
presence, you can actually kind of
overpower the Pike. So, it's one of
those ones where it can be frustrating,
but I also think it's a very fair deck
in terms of where it lands in power
scaling. It's doing really unique things
that can sometimes be annoying, but it's
not like doing it while putting an elder
dragon on the field or anything even
remotely close. It's like maybe a
4Runner will hit the field at some
point, right?
>> Yeah. It's definitely not uh, you know,
one of those, you know, I'm going to say
Bader Hook again because with LeBlanc
copies, you're hooking air, so to speak,
right? Cuz you're hooking something. You
just discarded a card to make and then
you're getting, you know, a couple death
triggers with your Ruined Rex into a
harness dragon and you're just sitting
there with, you know, a machine gun
looking at their board of, oh, they're
in your base. They're not safe.
>> Yeah.
>> And Pike has to at least get those
before they come into play. Get them out
of your hand first, which is sometimes
more difficult
>> or bounce stuff back to your hand, which
we saw the cool like star cross bounce
back and then play to discard. Um, but
often times you don't have the energy
for that as Pike. It's like, okay, I'm
going to bounce back. Um, but then I
won't be able to play it again
immediately or if I do, you have
multiple cards in your hand. That was a
very unique scenario where again, it's
an Aurora matchup. So, the Leon didn't
really have anything to do. It's just
defies in hand that don't really stop
any of that. Yeah. But who better to
tell us how to play Pike and their
experience in this last match than
Agressia themselves? So, we'll pass it
over for an interview.
>> Excellent cast there. And you're right.
I want to pick the brains of Aggressia.
Congratulations on that win here now 4-0
at RQ Hartford. How does it feel not
only, you know, piloting a deck and in
that match up pretty dominating there,
but also getting paired into an
undefeated Leen, but with Pike, how are
you feeling in the tournament so far?
feeling really good so far. Um, Pike, I
think as a lot of players have said like
this deck has really broken interactions
and has not have not been able to solve
it and you always have like um people
going in the tempo way, the control way
and uh you know there's just a lot of
different decisions to be made in the
deck building process and I think that
I'm very comfortable with the version
that I came up with. Um it's a bit of
like a hybrid. Um yeah, so I've been
very happy with the list so far.
>> Good. I mean it worked perfectly well
for you at least in this matchup. You
know, you've got four more rounds to go
today. So, I kind of want to pick your
brain because I think a lot of people
have been talking about Pike, but I
haven't necessarily seen the results
that I think a lot of people are
thinking it will bring. So, why do you
think that is? Is there something in the
field that you really struggle against
to like get over that last big hump or
do you just think sometimes the deck
doesn't cooperate or is this maybe
hybrid version the answer to that?
>> Um, it definitely has a lot to do with
the deck building. Uh because one of the
the biggest issues is that you end up
leading into this like control shell of
like I'm going to you know pack and
bewitching spirit your de your your hand
apart and when you play into a matchup
like Diana where you're trying to do
that and they're just like running a
Hawaii around hoe around on the board
and you know drawing a bunch of cards
that that strategy doesn't work. A lot
of your units have really bad might
numbers like you're not very big. You
have treasure hunters at one. You have
the spirits at two. Um no soulful is
like one of your best things at four and
like the top end really is like a
struggle. And like you know, Baron is
also a really tough card to get off
sometimes. Uh a lot of the times you'll
play Baron into like a Diana or a Yei
and then they'll just beat right over it
and then now they're scoring three
points and you're so far behind. No, I
think that's actually exactly what I saw
last week. You know, I think we had a
Pike on stream and the Baron came out
and it was against a Yi and it the Yi
deck is just like well you've created
this third battlefield which means
winning on conquering is so much harder.
Now it's about holding and what does Ye
love to do? Holding on to a battlefield.
So I do understand how it can sometimes
be that detriment but sometimes you're
like I want this sort of like you know
unargetable untouchable unit like Baron
and also brings up the might like you
said as the detriment but that is kind
of the downside that we've seen a lot of
these and like talk about Annie right
you know same domains but it's all about
just using all the tricks that you have
and the deck is very good at doing those
things so that makes a lot of sense to
be honest um but I have to highlight of
course a big play that you had that I
think chat was really happy about um the
falling stars onto the buffed Lee Sin
centered which had the six damage on it
which means there was one left when you
moved into the forbidding waste as an
interaction that I think a lot of people
don't realize and why forbidding waste
can be so good when you know how to use
it as you were the one that brought it
out. So can you kind of speak to like
how good of an ability your battlefields
can be in those sort of situations cuz
that was just game one and like you know
is that always the game plan for
forbidding base being that sort of game
one battlefield or do you think it just
kind of mix up depending on what the
decks you can take advantage of? Uh, so
for me, one of the the biggest matchups
that I struggle with uh tends to be the
master y deck because even their little
scuttle crab is going to beat over my
units on defense. So having the
forbidding waste initially was the the
play for that, but there's a lot of
really like techy plays you get to do
where I falling star your unit and when
I swing in that ability is a passive. So
it'll immediately immediately happen and
your unit dies. There is no priority
window. You can't buff it. You can't
like you know flip the zonas like he had
there. And that is like that catches a
lot of people off guard. It also uh
gives me a lot of information. So if
they know about that line and they
falling star and then and I falling star
and they flip the zonas well now I know
there's a zonas there and I can decide
well do I want to go in and like you
know force this trigger and kick his le
in back maybe I change my my line and I
want to starcross it and therefore that
zonas is now completely useless. Um and
that that that just the fact that I have
that information like before I even
decide if I want to fight this like
fight that battle on that battlefield
and for me it's not even a detriment
because Pike I'm picking up my units all
the time. They're never sitting there
unless I'm using these big these big
might units like I'll stick a Vex and a
4Runner on a point and that's like 10
might you have to deal with and that's
two units so I'm not getting the
forbidding waste and when you usually
when they swing in something like uh
Master Y is going to try and punch first
a is going to come in by itself. So
usually I mean it tends to be a problem.
So therefore now they have to stick a
second unit there. If I'm up on point
tempo, which tends to happen sometimes
when I get the early two drops, then we
can kind of play this game where like
I'm on one side and you're on the other
and I actually am like I'm happy with
that because then I will eventually win
unless you find a way to get over. Um,
which I mean, you know, at that point
then I can figure out what to do from
there.
>> No, that makes a lot of sense. Great
insight. Thank you so much for talking
about that. But I know you have another
half of the tournament to get through.
Congrats once again being 4-0 on Pike,
but we're going to go ahead and send it
back.
And there it is. Thank you, Barrett, for
that interview.
>> I love players who really know the
intricacies of their deck. Obviously,
it's my little judge brain that gets
happy me, right? Who would have thought,
right? So, I love that explanation from
uh from Aggressia there. But a very
dominant duo, right? But then we're
going to we have another match that we
were, you know, we had on deck for uh
for the feature matches.
>> Yeah, that'll be coming up in a little
bit here. So, stick around everybody. We
will have some more. But more about that
interview first. I just want to
highlight the fact that he kind of
mentioned it's a bit of a skill check
like the the forbidden ways, right? It's
like does your opponent know about the
interaction? Does your opponent
understand what's about to happen? Uh
and then pivoting your decision-m on if
they activate anything at that point
because again I kind of gave the analogy
before of card games are just a really
long intricate decision tree. Um and
sometimes simplifying the board state
gives you an easier line to go through.
I I talked about this uh last regional
qualifier and I'm curious actually your
thoughts on it because there's some
players that I I find when they approach
a card game, they try and complicate the
board state. They want to make as many
options as possible. Um sometimes to
make it so the opponent makes a mistake
or sometimes just so that they have as
many choices as possible. I'm more of a
fan of I want to simplify the board
state. I want to make it so that I have
the cleanest lines I can possibly find.
Um and then I'm I'm not making the
mistake myself. So, do do you find
yourself like first off like agreeing
with that sentiment and if so uh you
know which side of the the aisle do you
find yourself on?
>> I'm going to give you an interesting
answer.
>> Okay.
>> So, uh I'm of the opinion that if you're
ahead, you should simplify the board
state.
>> Okay.
>> If you're behind, you should complicate
the board state.
>> So, you pivot the the decision based on
where you are.
>> Like you said, right, complicating the
board state allows my opponents to make
errors, misplays, which will get me back
into the game. If I'm already ahead, I
don't need to give myself the
opportunity to make a mistake or my
opponent, you know, more decision points
where they could actually find a more
creative line that maybe I didn't even
think about. I just want to simplify
them and know, okay, they can probably
do this on their next turn. I'm already
ahead, so I'm going to set up what I
need to set up. I'm going to clean up
their little units that I'm not really
wanting to account for, and I've
simplified the board state. It's,
>> you know, other other card games or
even, you know, games like chess, this
is very important, right? To kind of
like if you're ahead, you'll simplify
it. If you're behind, you want to keep
it complicated. You want to force your
opponent to make mistakes. And I feel
like Riftmount leans into that a lot.
We've seen it where,
>> especially with Aggressia, right? We're
ahead.
>> Just keep pounding. Make sure they have
no cards in hand. Keep it very simple.
They're playing top deck mode. And I can
play my game, right? And we saw it work
really well for him.
>> You don't need to build wide at that
point. You just want to keep doing the
the surgical strikes and finding the the
right line of victory. Yeah. I think
it's a fun conversation to have cuz when
when I watch some um of the pros play
like players like prismaticism, I've
noticed a tendency where he just kind of
goes wide and he's happy to just play a
bunch of units out there and then he'll
go in when he's ready to go in. Whereas
a player like Allen's EQ, he'll only
have like one or two units on the board
at a time because he's always going for
these little trades of like, okay, you
have a two might, I have a twoight, I'm
going to trade with a two might as
opposed to Prismat will be like, I'm
just going to hold my unit and like use
it as a resource later, you know? Um, so
I think it's fun when you compare the
different mentalities of pro players as
well cuz obviously they know the game so
much more than I do. So much more than
like pretty much anybody watching right
now. Um, so it's fun to learn from them
and like when they choose to pivot.
>> And it's interesting too cuz you just
talked about right Alan's EQ and Prismat
who have very different play styles,
right? Allan Allen's EQ
>> likes to play tempo, right? He likes to
be ahead. Yeah,
>> which lends to those
>> he likes to have more cards than his
opponent.
>> More cards, more points, you know, one
or two units, you figure it out.
Prismat,
when you're behind, you'll keep it
complicated. And that's what we're kind
of seeing with these pro players as
well.
>> And there is something to be said about
letting your opponent show their hand
because uh I mean even the example of
that last one where it's like the the
hidden zonas um at the I'm blanking on
the battlefield forbidden ways. Thank
you. uh is the fact that like you know
if you make the certain line you get
more information before you commit your
next uh three energy spent or something
along those lines, right? It's like get
as much information as you can before
making your decisions cuz you're going
to have a more informed decision. So if
you just kind of wait and let your
opponent play their hand, they might get
ahead on tempo, but you're like, "Okay,
but now I know what you're working
with." So
>> yeah, you can kind of climb back in. But
>> let's deep dive into some stuff, shall
we?
>> Let's do it. Yeah. I hear that uh we
have an analyst standing by to break
down some of that last match.
Thank you so much, guys. That was quite
the match. Love to see Lee Sin up there.
Unfortunately, it was a Le Aurora deck
and did not find the Aurora. There's
been a lot of talk about Pike and Pike
can do some really cool things with that
legend ability. Now, in game one, you
guys heard it in that interview. We
talked about that crazy interaction with
the falling star going on the lease end
and that hidden zona's hourglass was
unable to be played because moving in it
gets the minus two. There was no window
and that really locked up game one and
then of course the fact that there was
no Aurora but now we jump into game two
and here at this point once again no
Aurora and we can see that in the
backline Mr. Pandawan, he is trying to
develop and he is going to have to hold
at some point, right? And you're just
continuing to chip in and this is what
Pike can do. So, let's go ahead and play
it here. Pike is so good with the
Bewitching Spirit. You're dismantling
your opponent's hand, moving in here.
You're getting onto the battlefield.
You're scoring that point. And then this
Pike Legend ability is just so good.
Being able to bounce that unit back. So,
you're just going in, getting that
point, and then coming back and
continuing to rip your opponent's hand
with this bewitching spirit. And it's a
problem here for Mr. Panda one because
again, those points are just pouring in.
At some point, you have to get on the
battlefield and hold. You're not finding
Aurora, which is your win condition. So,
we have successfully made some tokens.
We've got to get up there and we have to
hold. So, we see the lease in being
bounced. But now I want to fast forward
to our second piece here in game two
where we're at a position we still have
the tokens in play. The lease in has
been dealt with and the bewitching
spirits are continuing to put the
pressure on. Again, no Aurora in play,
but now we have this moment where it's
coming up. We're at seven points here.
So, we're closing in on being exactly
where we need to finish this game for
Aggressia. And now we'll go ahead and
play it. And this is just an amazing
play here to really lock things up and
make sure that Mr. Pandawan cannot get
on these battlefields and try to hold,
try to stall out until he can find his
win condition, which is Aurora. The
downwell comes down and just wipes out
the board. The tokens are gone. They
can't go back to your hand and then that
is going to lead to victory. So, I love
the interaction with Pike. Very
versatile being able to take advantage
of those play abilities over and over
again. and also that offensive
capability of going in, getting on the
battlefield, getting your point,
bouncing it back, and then reusing that
unit once again. So, unfortunately, Lee
not getting to do what he really wanted
to do, but great to see these two at the
feature table. So, that's going to do it
here and we're going to send it back
over.
>> So, essentially, I think to summarize,
uh, Pike kind of bounced down crazy a
little bit, bouncing him up. That was
nuts.
Yeah, let's go with that for sure. For
sure.
>> Yeah.
>> You got anything to say after that one?
>> No. You caught me off guard with that
one. That's for sure. But, uh, we have a
little bit of a deja vu situation going
on.
>> Oh, yes.
>> We got a, you know, Rexai versus Victor
was our, you know, second feature match
that we're going to be able to jump
into. So, two very low to the ground. I
want to go fast. I want to also kind of
control the board kind of
>> order decks. Yeah, I'd say Rex is a
little more like pure rush down aggro
than the Victor cuz you're incentivized
to conquer to get your advantage. Victor
is a little happier to play a slower
controlled style, but still can't play
fast. Let's take a look at the deck list
though to get some insight into how
they're going to approach this cuz Rexi
is up first. And uh I think the staple
of every Rexi list is a lot of two
energy units. You always see a lot of
these ones in there. Although I haven't
seen I'm blank I I can't quite re take
out the name there. I believe it's the
hidden one that when you reveal it, you
deal damage.
>> Oh, mischievous Marai.
>> Mischievous Mariah. I haven't seen that
one. Thank you. Yeah, the screen uh it
was a little too far away for me to read
it when it was that small, but yeah,
when you play into Battlefield, deal two
to an enemy unit here and it is hidden.
I have not seen this tech yet.
>> Yeah, this is obviously a fun one cuz it
again throws off the math. It's
essentially a four might, I say, an air
quote swing cuz it doesn't reduce the
might, but kind of like Teemo.
>> Kind of like Teemo. Yeah, the hidden
Teemo that you know will reveal cards
and depending on the amount of hidden
ones you can that Teemo.
>> Sure. bad team. But even even the purple
one just goes to four might, which would
essentially be the same math there. So
yeah,
>> what I like too is the one of
Facebreaker in here, right? The one of
Marai in here, you're showing your
opponent that you have multiple
different hidden cards and they have to
again play around for both. But the way
you play into a faceer might be
different than the way you play into a
Marai, which might be different than the
way you play into a hidden blade, right?
So keeping your opponent guessing is
very important in these matchups. And
then like we saw, we have the Rengar
pouncing, you know, we have the pike. We
have ways to go very fast if we need to
because Rexi specifically that Rexai
breacher champion unit allows us to
accelerate if we're seeing stuff off our
Rexi Legend trigger, right? And we're
allowed to kind of just go as fast as we
can and stuff like Undertain gives us
that rune economy to do so.
>> I believe the main deck is one card
different from the best of Rex eye that
we saw in Utre last weekend. and they
have the face breaker instead of or
rather um the mischievous Mariah in
instead of like a secondary and porro
and that face breaker was something else
in that list but uh we'll catch up on
that later. Now let's take a look at the
other list today cuz that's going to be
a Victor. A lot of similar order cards
you'll see in here like the face
breaker, the hidden blade, uh the
carry-on dredger, but then also a lot of
Victor stuff as well.
>> Yeah, one of my favorite cards that came
out this set uh was actually shock
dancer. So, this is a card that doesn't
damp you, right? It's just three runes,
but it you can play it at ambush speed
and you give all your units shield that
turn when you play it. So, it could
potentially be a huge might swing,
especially if you have three or four
recruits at that battlefield.
>> Yeah, and that was one of the things I
highlighted. I don't know if we've shown
it yet on stream, but I did a deck
breakdown of the best of Victor that
made finals at Utre, and I was like,
Victor essentially, if you kind of count
down the line, got better in every way
from Unleashed. Chakum dancer helps you
hold better. Victor used to be bad at
holding. You used to be good at like
swinging with Imperial Decree and maybe
like your thousand tail and hitting Vice
helps you with that as well. Um, but now
you can hold a little better with this
and also you can uh go faster with
things like Sprite Fountain. So I want
to highlight that one next because this
is a three of in the list. Victor also
sometimes struggled outside of Thousand
Tail Watcher and maybe Zingo to get in
fast. Sprite Found is a fantastic card
to just let Victor get points early, get
points quickly, and has turned it into
somewhat of a more rush down style of
deck.
>> Yeah. And as we jump into the game here,
something to note while we're kind of
waiting for these players to get all set
up is that Victor specifically the
leader specifies when a non token, a
non-recruit token dies. So when those
sprites are dying out of placing them
with recruits, which is very important.
>> It looks like we're hopping into game
number two. So, a reminder, this is our
backup feature match of round four. Uh,
so round one, um, I would imagine went
over to, uh, the Rex side player, who I
think is on the the right. Yeah, the or
Victor, Victor's on the right, it looks
>> Victor must have won game one since
we're seeing arenas from the Rex side.
>> Exactly. In game two,
>> I would assume at least typically when
you go arena's greatest, you're choosing
to go first, which means you lost the
first round. And here we go.
>> And you are correct. And classic turn
one play from Victor.
>> No turn one play from
>> one play from Rexai. Yeah, which is
important. Yeah,
>> but we do get a, you know, pretty good
turn one play from the Rexai, right?
Where we get to make two bodies. So, we
do have a bit of tempo here. But again,
we have a Zenzho in hand, so we could
just,
>> you know, make a recruit. Oh, Bellos
works too.
>> That's pretty nice.
>> Cleansed it up, right?
>> Yeah, cast that one uh repeated. And
that will clear out the two might and
the one might and then go score. If you
can prevent Rexi from ever scoring, that
means that you essentially don't have a
legend and the entire build of the deck
revolves around getting cheap cards
spent on the top of your deck.
>> Yeah, I wonder the thought process
behind uh playing that faithful
manufacturer instead of the Rexai
champion unit last turn. Maybe trying to
play around cold a week instead of that
bellow's breath,
>> which we saw both are in hand, right? So
you're you were kind of, you know,
>> it didn't matter what you did in the
grand scheme of things, but I think
playing around that call a week is
probably more important. That Rex size
is a very impactful unit for your deck.
So losing it this early, especially when
you're down a game in this series, uh,
is less than ideal.
>> We might even see it right now. It's one
of those ways that you can just
guarantee you get in and use your legend
ability. And there it is. So Rex eyes
hit the field. Going to clear out that
recruit.
>> Yeah. And this is going to let us look
for units now as well.
That being said, we only have two
available, so we can't really accelerate
them with the Rexai breacher
>> Rexite trigger,
>> but we can at least uh, you know, get
some card economy, maybe find an Noxis
hopeful. Uh, but it looks like it's
going to be a blood rush and an inferna.
Do we want to play the inferna?
>> I feel like you play inferno to base.
That's one of the benefits of Rex size.
You essentially have two hands. One is
the cards in your hand, the other is the
cards at the top of your deck. This is
kind of like just drawing a card if you
think of it that way. Essentially, you
got a draw one. You just didn't get to
choose what that draw one really was.
Like you just have to play it off the
top.
>> And this is good to do because again it
insulates against the weaker, right?
>> Yes. Very nice.
>> Oh, top victory.
>> Uh I'd say Zinga is probably the next
biggest threat here cuz the Victor can
get out a recruit and if a Zingo hits
the forward field,
>> he comes.
>> Okay, there it is. Yep.
>> Yep.
>> I didn't get a look at uh the hand of
the Victor player, but you always have
to be ready for the Zing when you're
playing against Victor.
>> Yeah, it's a it's such a low investment
accelerated unit for this. a good card.
>> Something that, you know, really
propelled the deck forward in Spirit for
now with all the additional
>> Oh, and there's
>> Feels bad.
>> Doesn't even have to repeat it. It's
just a
Yep.
>> Yep.
>> It does feel bad as a Rex eye player
when you don't have a unit. You've
triggered your uh legend once.
>> Once this game so far. Yeah,
>> once this game so far. Well, yeah, true.
Game one, I imagine. Maybe more.
>> Um
>> hopefully more. I'm noticing Ruger is
one of those types of players that likes
to have one of every different rune.
>> I would have scooped by now if I was
against that. I I don't want to look at
it. I can't.
>> It's okay. We got uh the Victor player
here who has the OG basics.
>> The OG basics. You can tell that's from
Origin, not from Unleash.
>> Yeah,
>> that's what you meant by OG, right?
>> It's from the Victor
>> starter deck.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, you think he hasn't changed them out
at all?
>> Yeah,
>> I do. You know, I never even thought
about that, but Origins being OG, that
actually is pretty good.
>> Yep.
>> Hopeful.
>> Hopeful is good.
>> And now we're taking another time to
develop, right? Unfortunately, this is
where tempo is really in the favor of
our Victor player here.
>> Pass.
>> Uh we do have, you know, three bodies,
but again, we still have that cold a
week that's available for us uh for
Victor.
>> Obviously, we dramped a little bit last
turn with the bellows and the Zen,
>> but we're back up to five runes. You
don't really need a ton of runes,
especially when you're on six runes. No.
uh or six points, excuse me. Uh and if
you do have some sort of It doesn't look
like we have a decree in hand, but I
mean, if you did have a decree, just
kind of pull everything back and uh and
figure it out next turn. But
>> you can just go in for the the push
turn. Yeah.
>> And it looks like that's what he's
doing. So, you called it. Uh if if uh
TSM MA, I'm going to assume that's it.
>> Probably an esport fan. Um has a lot of
units, you can just establish all of
them. You can play one here, then use
your Victor Legend. Yep. get the recruit
and then go for a big swing to win on
the next turn.
>> And I think we have two extra Zins in
the hand by the way. I think I unless I
saw it wrong, which means we have eight
might swing. Do we have enough to play
both next turn? Yeah, we're on five. We
have exactly enough to play two.
>> Now, the downside of this move from TSM
Ma though is that um you're allowing
Rexai to get the legend ability off. You
could have opted to try and use your
chock dancer to hold uh and and not uh
allow your opponent to get that Rex. I'm
also hearing from production it's suma.
So, thank you for uh our go to
production for letting me know there.
>> Um I also don't have to say TSM anymore.
So, as a CLG fan, that feels very good.
>> Um but but the the point I'm making is
that you're allowing the Rexai to play
the game. You could have opted to try
and hold and just not let the Rexai get
that ability off, but I think you're so
far ahead as a Victor. This is still the
correct line of play. I'm just trying to
like list the the downside of this
option is that now Rexai does get to get
a little more card economy here. Yeah,
we can finally again get up to
>> about four points if we conquer the
other battlefield. And now we're trying
to look for something to thin the back
line of uh
>> and then a void rush is a really good
>> Very big hit.
>> Yeah, very big hit. Obviously the face
breaker would have been great to have in
our hand, but it looks like it's going
to probably be a void rush into two more
flips. I would imagine
>> void rush.
>> Yeah.
>> Can we get another void rush?
>> Can we chain them together? That's
>> runner runner void rush.
>> That is the most fun thing playing Rexa.
Have you ever pulled it off?
>> Void rush into void rush is a rush, let
me tell you.
>> I've done it once,
>> but I've seen someone do void rush into
void rush into void rush once and that
was crazy.
>> How about double hidden blade?
>> It does only cost a power and it does
draw you two cards. So, if you're
looking for more cards, you can hidden
blade your own recruit uh for one power.
Draw a couple cards, but you're really
thinning
>> the options you have. I think
>> because it's void rush, you just draw
them.
>> Yeah, you just don't uh play either. You
just add them both to hand. You hide
them both. put both to hand.
>> There it is.
>> Drawing some.
>> Just maybe,
>> just maybe, just maybe. Again, this
throws the math
>> throws the math off now for Suma on his
side where he's going to have to figure
out, okay, well, now I have to play
around two hidden blades
>> and potentially some other mystery cards
in the hand of uh of Rub Murk.
But man, Suma has so many units on the
field and with those zingas in hand,
like I don't think it's I guess there's
a lot of energy up for Rugmer. So, let's
let's see what they do.
>> It's seeming tough. It's seeming like uh
the Victor pilot will have the game
here,
>> but you never know.
>> Suspicious looking card.
>> Yeah,
>> suspicious card.
>> Suspicious card.
>> I love when the players have fun up
there.
>> Yes.
Now we're deciding what to do the rest
of our runes because this is most likely
going to be the last turret unless we
can really thwart Suma's uh attack next
turn.
>> I mean the crazy thing is Suma could
just play more units and then pass.
>> He's another hidden blade in hand. If he
hit both, he has a third hidden blade in
hand.
>> Pass.
>> Okay, a pass there from Aru Merk.
>> Noticing he also had a cold a weak in
hand. So keeping cold a weak
>> not siding it out against Victor.
>> Interesting cuz it usually Victor will
get more value out of that. But
>> we'll see what value Suma can get right
now with what's on the field. There's
five might
>> down at the rockfall path. Wages of pain
will go to the arena's greatest.
>> Good start for Zuma.
>> Wages. What do we We're going to ambush
something in. It looks like
>> cycle one for long sword.
>> Oh, long sword works too.
>> Nice. Clean answer. One might remain or
one health rather remains on
>> I'll grab a gold
>> the unit and that means that now uh
there's something we'll have to go in. A
recruit can still trade with it but
you're just making suma use more
resources.
>> Yeah,
>> the recruit might be the difference of
you know not being able to conquer
Rockfall for example. So
>> y
>> uh however notably here there is a
hidden blade. If we push the recruit in
and it gets hidden bladed then if that
combat ends we're healing the
>> Oh, that's a good point. So you have to
push in with enough to kill it through
the hidden blade, but are you going to
expect the hidden blade from hand as
well?
>> Yeah. So you can send in two recruits.
That would be the kind of obvious line
if you're not reading another
interaction from the hand.
>> Yes. Yeah. If you think they have maybe
another hidden blade or ambush unit that
they could play from hand, then you have
to send in more. And this is where it
gets very tricky for Suma is you
probably have the answer, but with the
fact that we know there's two hidden
blades and now there's two hidden cards,
you might be psyching yourself into
being like these have to be the two
hidden blades.
>> They can't be anything else.
>> And you're probably not going to expect
that third hidden blade from hand.
>> Especially cuz you already saw a face
breaker uh earlier go away. So you're
like pretty confident that yep, it's not
a face breaker. And you saw the two.
There's a zinga on hand that he could
use. Let's see what Suma decides to opt
for here. Doing some math right now.
For my uh for my money though, I think
the Rugmark could survive or rather will
survive another turn here.
>> Yeah,
>> he's going to have to play this very
well to close out the game here.
>> We do have two more uh Zen Xiaou in
hand, but we don't have enough to play
them anymore cuz we wages. So, we can
add four might to this board that's
ready.
>> The urge to just shove it
four.
>> I feel you. Yeah. So, this is actually
good. This plays around both.
>> Uh, this plays around two hidden blades.
>> That being said, if we have an inferna,
uh, it also allows us to still win this
com uh, this showdown cuz we can hidden
blade one,
>> hidden blade the other.
>> Uh, and then inferna in as well, which
will only let one of the recruits kill
either the inferna or the faithful.
>> I am surprised to see the zing go
>> cycle one to give him. So now Suma will
know there's a hidden blade in hand.
That is now known information cuz you
saw two were drawn.
>> Thank you.
>> And this one's not a hidden blade.
>> Nope.
>> Uh pass focus too.
>> But this one does make it 8 to six.
>> Okay. And I'll I'll pass back. We'll do
damage.
>> Yep.
>> Everything will crash.
>> Four and one. And you'll clear me.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. So a full trade here because of the
already the damage from the wages of
pain earlier. But this again makes it so
that we're probably not winning here.
Unless we think that we can just
>> I actually no I don't think there's a
way for us to win here because the Zen
>> we'll need to move in with a shock
dancer to clear out that Rockfall path
and the recruit and you can actually do
that. Yeah. So we're going to see
another turn here at least from Ruger.
Well played by him to kind of claw back
into this match
>> and not holding the or not using the
hidden blade on the Zen Xiaou because
you could have Ruger could have kept a
unit alive. But then you're also giving
Suma more draws and I think Ruger should
be pretty confident that you're going to
survive. Don't give them the resources.
Save that hidden blade for the next turn
because Ruger is actually potentially
back into the game.
>> Top for one group. And in what world do
you just maybe
>> one
>> stack that other battlefield
>> and just play for the hold?
>> Um thinking
>> I feel like Suma could just Okay. I was
going to say sometimes you can just send
in the Zinja and just be like I'm just
going to draw two. I'm just going to
force the hidden blade
>> hold. It's good. Yeah. Pass. Okay.
Sorry. Yeah. Sorry.
>> All right. So I believe I saw two cold a
week
>> five
>> in the hand for Rugm. M
>> with four units this gets really awkward
cuz two cold a week weak will just still
give them lethal next turn.
>> Yeah. I mean if you can clear the
recruit that's out of battlefield and
then double cold a week weak that could
be nice. But we also know that there's
the zingo in hand. So then
>> we do have a hidden blade. So we could
hidden blade
>> call the week but then we lose to
anything that gets accelerated.
>> But I think that might be the only line
here. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I haven't quite seen what else is
in Rugenberg's hand. Have you caught any
units that uh Ruger has access to?
>> I saw Blood Rush. I saw two cold week. I
saw Hidden Blade.
>> Oo, that's not an ideal.
>> Yeah,
>> not an ideal hand. I mean, I think
>> I seeing Porro as well, which again is
an ideal here, but
>> thank you uh for the observers for
highlighting that. I'm wondering if uh I
mean, there's also a off chance you just
hidden blade your own recruit, draw two,
try and dig into something else. seems
daring. Must might I say
>> as much as the poro is.
>> Rugmark agrees.
>> Yeah.
>> You got four.
>> He's in the tank right now.
>> Oh, it looks like is that an honest
broker at the end? No, that was a red
card.
>> Let's see what Ruger does. The one thing
we know he guaranteed can do is just
hidden blade the recruit to deny Suma
from winning because if that recruit
lives, Suma's recruit lives at the
battlefield, then uh Suma just wins at
the start of their turn. So Ren has to
do something.
>> Yeah, he's going to do exactly that.
Looks like he's going to hit and blade
his route.
>> Look for some sort of answer.
>> It's not ideal, but sometimes you got to
dig.
>> Draw two. Yep. I'm
>> not sure if we brought in the falling
stars from the sideboard, but if we did
that, we'd go crazy here.
Falling star into double cold the week
would completely wipe the board.
>> Tapped out.
>> Yes,
>> I think that might be it.
>> Uh three one
>> and recycling a fury rune. So probably a
pike
>> or pike.
>> Yep.
>> Ready?
>> We can only call the weak once now.
>> Pass focus. Pass focus.
>> And that recruit is just
>> Yep.
>> Just there.
going to decide if we want to use our
Rexi Legend ability here.
>> I feel like you might as well cuz you
don't have to play whatever's revealed.
You might get an undertitan which then
gives you more energy.
>> That will be a double kill a week if you
do hit an under.
>> Yeah. So I I feel like you always should
do this
>> inferna and
>> no undertitan. Hopeful is not bad here,
right? You can play it make an eight
might battlefield which means they would
have to swing their entire board to kill
that battlefield unless they have
something in hand.
>> We know there's another Zin in hand
>> which doesn't necessarily change the
grand something in the grand scheme of
things but could theoretically also hide
the hidden blade. So have eight might
plus a additional hidden blade out there
>> or there because the zinga would have to
crash into the Nox is hopeful. So I
think that this also causes a headache
as well. You're not giving a clean
conquer to Suma,
>> I think. Yeah, you definitely have to
hide the hidden blade here.
>> This is gonna be a lot.
>> I'll do one for the long sword equip.
>> Oh, yes, the long sword is still in play
as well.
>> I guess I should probably do it one at a
time.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> we're hiding two cards, it looks like.
>> Yep. Okay, so Ruger is essentially
>> spending everything to try and prevent
Suma from not only winning but then also
potentially winning on Ruben's turn. If
Rub can hold both of these, I know
>> that's game.
>> We have uh order sorry yeah order fury
Teemo
Victor I don't
>> don't ever reverse it.
That's sometimes the difficulty in
tournaments, in regional qualifiers like
this. There's so many good players out
there on so many decks that people at
your local people at your testing groups
just don't play. You just don't get the
reps in certain matchups. And we heard
Rugenberg say, "Yeah, I just don't play
against Victor a lot. This is a a weird
matchup."
>> Yeah. I I I mentioned it a little bit
when we were doing the uh the opening
for the show is that your day one Swiss
is very much a zoo. Yeah. Right. You
don't know what you're going to play
into. You can play into your worst match
up eight rounds in a row just like you
can play into your best match up eight
rounds in a row.
>> Uh and this is again Rum
>> like you mentioned right he doesn't have
a lot of practice into Victor but
>> holding his own doing a lot here to to
kind of keep up with the uh the
onslaught that is uh this Victor deck.
>> So Suma just attacked in with the chamom
dancer and then past focus.
>> So Ruger
straight with the pike
>> on top.
>> Interesting.
>> Make a recruit.
>> Yep.
>> So we're going to call the weak here is
what they were doing. Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> It'll guarantee one of these
battlefields as long as there's not a
hidden unit and there's not.
>> This will fizzle.
>> Yeah. I guess I mean if it's okay the
react to the call.
>> I'll let the judges.
>> Is that fine?
>> Yep.
>> Would have had a window to react with
hidden blade. See if the judges allow
it.
>> Yeah.
Seems like the judges are determining if
uh if they will.
That's one of those things you just got
to remember your triggers. Remember your
own hidden. I know it's a stressful
moment. So, I always like to remind
people at home that are watching of
like, oh, why did that happen? It's like
this is a stressful moment for people.
Most players have never been on camera
before. Most players have never been on
this stage before. Um and you're
undefeated down a game in a tough
matchup. So, I always like to give grace
to players and we'll see if the judges
have the same opinion or if they believe
that nope, the static
>> game was accepted.
>> Yeah. I was like,
>> and this allows you to still have a
second unit in your base so you can play
your
>> It's like up to the judges how they want
to rule it.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. And then the double zen means
that they could go into the Nox's
hopeful battlefield and then the recruit
can go over to the arena's greatest.
>> I know.
>> Can I look at your trash? Uh yeah, we'll
just wait.
>> Yeah, I mean I think I mean it's free.
It's free vision. So
>> yep, Mark being a
>> So you're telling me you have your third
one there?
>> Free vision. Look at my trash. You're
very welcome.
>> Uh
>> so Suman never actually uh triggered the
arena's greatest conquer. So he could
just move the recruit there and draw a
card as well. Just try and dig into more
potential answers.
>> Yeah, that's fine. Yeah, it's fine.
>> Okay.
Uh, looks like I'll take a draw.
>> We We missed it. We're not allowing them
to to draw.
>> It's hard. It's obviously hard to to do
when the player takes the unit, puts it
in the trash, and then we're now
resolving the rest of the turn. So, uh,
minus two card, but I don't know that
there's anything that's one energy that
can really help Rud here, right? It'll
give him
>> options for next turn if there is one.
>> Do you have it or not?
>> But yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> Oh, there it is. So, we're going to
actually say we're stacking, which is I
like this play a lot.
>> This is much safer cuz if you assume
it's the hidden blade under the nox is
hopeful the double zing will not be
enough.
>> Hidden blade that I forgot to grab.
>> I mean with four energy I don't know if
two extra draws would have I I don't
think there's any combination that can
kill this board. Like even double
falling star would be enough. And we
don't have the fury runes for it.
>> Okay.
>> I did get this hidden blade. Yeah, I
know.
>> They're having fun up there. I like it.
>> That's it.
>> That's it. Yeah, it's really hard.
>> GG.
>> GG's.
>> GG's. They give the fist bump and Suma
will take it. Continuing undefeated,
four and zero as Victor.
>> But I'm Victor.
>> I messed up my sideboard. I'm not going
to lie.
Oh, I would have loved to hear his
thoughts on it. My my immediate thought
was cold a week. I was like, maybe he
was like, "Yeah, I should have taken
cold weeks out against Victor." Like,
it's just going to get a recruit and I
have to maybe get a recruit of my own if
not something bigger.
>> Yeah, I'm wondering. I'm looking at a
sideboard here, right? There's a Shen
that he could have brought in. The
Ferris 4runner would have been very good
into that matchup.
>> Salvage, you're not really using much.
>> Falling stars,
>> an Ash maybe, but I feel like you take
out those three call weeks and you can
bring in, you know, the falling stars.
Ferris Foreigner, maybe a Shen.
>> Ash Focus is pretty good into Victor,
I'd say, cuz Victor can struggle to hold
and you can get rid of like an Imperial
Decree just like or a Thousand Tail
Watcher just be like, "No, we're going
to get rid of those like big swing cards
and then you're you have a recruit maybe
a Zinga out of Battlefield. Well, I'm
Rexa. I'm going to be able to keep you
off anyway." So, I I don't know what he
actually ended up citing, but I'm sure
that there were some things that he
could uh optimize there. Um I love it
when players immediately are like,
"Okay, I lost GG. Man, I got to learn
from that." You know,
>> this is what I always tell people.
People I one of my favorite cards is
Gutter Palace. Um
>> Okay.
>> Uh where I going with this?
>> So, I like winning with style.
>> Okay.
>> And I think there's you either win a
game or you learn from a game.
>> You don't actually lose. Obviously,
there's winners and losers in here. But
if you finish a game and you don't know
why you lost,
>> it's a good opportunity for you to kind
of review and figure out where did I
lose. So, everyone here's a winner
technically. Obviously, some more than
others.
>> Oh, really?
>> But you're either winning or you're
learning. And that's we've seen players
get better at every regional by doing
that. Reviewing their games, figuring
out, oh, I don't have a lot of
experience against this Victor. I'm
playing a Rexai. You best believe Roomer
is going home and he's going to watch
this VOD over and over and over again
and examine it.
>> So, so what I'm getting is that I can
claim currently that I'm undefeated and
very knowledgeable about the game.
>> Learned a lot.
>> You got it.
>> Learned a lot. Um, all right. I believe
that we are uh we are actually going to
be sending to a break here up next
before our round five feature match. So
stick around everybody. We'll be right
back after this.
Down.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,